GOOD AFTERNOON. THE ASSEMBLY AND
SENATE COMMITTEES ON HEALTH WILL
COME TO ORDER. MY NAME IS
RICHARD ROTH. I'M PRIVILEGED TO
SERVE AS CHAIR OF THE SENATE
HEALTH COMMITTEE. ASSEMBLY CHAIR
MIA BONTA IS NOT ABLE TO JOIN US
THIS AFTERNOON, SO WE WILL
PROCEED. OBVIOUSLY. THANK YOU
ALL FOR BEING HERE, ALL
PANELISTS THIS AFTERNOON WILL BE
TESTIFYING IN PERSON FOR TODAY'S
HEARING. WE WILL BE HEARING ALL
OF THE PANELS OF WITNESSES ON
THE AGENDA PRIOR TO TAKING ANY
PUBLIC COMMENT. ONCE WE HAVE
HEARD ALL OF THE WITNESSES, WE
WILL HAVE PUBLIC COMMENT PERIOD.
FOR THOSE WHO WISH TO MAKE A
STATEMENT OR COMMENT ON THE
TOPICS OF TODAY'S AGENDA, WE ARE
GOING TO ALLOW A TOTAL OF 30
MINUTES FOR PUBLIC TESTIMONY,
WITH A TIME LIMIT OF ONE MINUTE
PER WITNESS. TESTIMONY WILL NEED
TO FOCUS ON THE INITIATIVE
BEFORE US. OBVIOUSLY, AS THE
CHAIR, I WILL NOT PERMIT CONDUCT
THAT DISRUPTS, DISTURBS OR
OTHERWISE IMPEDES THE ORDERLY
CONDUCT OF LEGISLATIVE
PROCEEDINGS. I'M CONFIDENT THAT
WE WILL NOT HAVE ANY OF THAT
TODAY. WITH THAT SAID, WELCOME
AGAIN. OUR GOAL IS TO HAVE A
FAIR AND IMPARTIAL PRESENTATION
OF THE RELEVANT FACTS ABOUT THIS
INITIATIVE. SPECIFICALLY,
PROPOSITION 35, WHICH PROVIDES
PERMANENT FUNDING FOR MEDI-CAL
HEALTH CARE SERVICES TO AID ALL
OF US AND THE ELECTORATE IN
REACHING AN INFORMED JUDGMENT
REGARDING THE PARTICULAR MEASURE
INVOLVED. FOR OUR FIRST PANEL TO
PROVIDE US WITH AN OVERVIEW OF
THE PROPOSITION AND FISCAL
ANALYSIS, WE'VE ASKED THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE TO
JOIN US. AND ONCE YOU ARE IN
PLACE, PLEASE INTRODUCE
YOURSELVES FOR THE RECORD, I WAS
GOING TO SAY TO MY LEFT, YOU'RE
RIGHT. SO WE'LL SEE HOW YOU ALL
LINE UP. AND THAT'S FINANCE.
OKAY. LÀ Ó, INTRODUCE
YOURSELVES FOR THE RECORD, AND
YOU MAY PROCEED WHEN READY.
GREAT. AND IS EVERYONE ABLE TO
HEAR ME? PERFECTLY. GREAT MY
NAME IS JASON CONSTANDUROS. I'M
WITH THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE. I'M GOING TO BE SPEAKING
FROM THIS HANDOUT THAT SHOULD BE
IN YOUR MATERIALS, THE HANDOUT
IS ORGANIZED INTO FOUR KEY
SECTIONS. THE FIRST PROVIDES A
BRIEF OVERVIEW OF OUR ROLE IN
THE BALLOT MEASURE PROCESS, AND
THEN PROVIDES BACKGROUND ON THE
MCO TAX, WHICH IS THE MAJOR PART
OF PROPOSITION 35. I WILL THEN
DESCRIBE THE PROPOSITION AND
PROVIDE OUR FISCAL ANALYSIS. IF
YOU TURN TO PAGE ONE OF YOUR
HANDOUT AGAIN, THIS DESCRIBES
OUR ROLE IN THE BALLOT MEASURE
PROCESS. I JUST WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT THREE KEY POINTS ON
THIS PAGE. THE FIRST IS THAT OUR
OFFICE IS TASKED WITH PROVIDING
ANALYZES OF BALLOT MEASURES FOR
INITIATIVE MEASURES,
SPECIFICALLY, WE DO IT TWICE.
THE FIRST IS WHEN, RIGHT BEFORE
THE MEASURE GOES TO COLLECT
SIGNATURES, WE PROVIDE AN
ANALYSIS JOINTLY WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE, AND THEN
WE DO IT A SECOND TIME. IF THE
MEASURE QUALIFIES FOR THE BALLOT
INDEPENDENTLY. AND THEN THE
THIRD POINT I WANT TO EMPHASIZE
IS THAT OUR OFFICE, OUR OFFICE'S
ROLE HERE IS A BIT DIFFERENT
THAN WHAT YOU MIGHT BE USED TO
IN BUDGET COMMITTEES, AND THAT
WE DO NOT WEIGH IN ON THE POLICY
MERITS OF BALLOT MEASURES. WE'RE
TASKED WITH STRICTLY PROVIDING
AN INDEPENDENT FISCAL ANALYSIS
OF THE MEASURE. TURNING TO PAGE
TWO. WE'LL PROVIDE SOME QUICK
BACKGROUND ON THE MCO TAX. AND
THERE ARE THREE KEY POINTS WE
WANT TO EMPHASIZE IN TERMS OF
BACKGROUND. THE FIRST KEY POINT
IS AROUND WHAT THE MCO TAX IS.
SO THE MCO TAX IS A TAX ON
HEALTH PLANS SUCH AS KAISER
PERMANENTE. THAT WOULD BE AN
EXAMPLE OF A PLAN IN CALIFORNIA.
AND IT'S SPECIFICALLY A TAX ON
THE NUMBER OF PEOPLE THAT PLANS
ENROLL, INCLUDING THOSE THAT
THEY ENROLL IN MEDI-CAL. THE TAX
RATE IS MUCH HIGHER ON FOR THOSE
IN MEDI-CAL COMPARED FOR THOSE
WHO HAVE OTHER KINDS OF HEALTH
COVERAGE. AND BY CHARGING THE
MCO TAX, THE STATE IS ABLE TO
DRAW DOWN MORE FEDERAL FUNDING.
SECOND KEY BACKGROUND POINT IS
WHAT IS THE PURPOSE OF THE TAX?
WELL, THE TAX HAS TWO KEY
PURPOSES. THE FIRST PURPOSE IS A
KIND OF THE HISTORICAL PURPOSE
OF THE TAX, AND THAT IS TO HELP
SUPPORT THE EXISTING MEDI-CAL
PROGRAM. WHEN THE STATE USES THE
TAX IN THIS WAY, IT MEANS THAT
IT DOESN'T HAVE TO SPEND AS MUCH
MONEY FROM THE GENERAL FUND TO
COVER THIS COST. AND SO
THEREFORE IT HELPS REDUCE COSTS
TO THE STATE. THE SECOND KEY
PURPOSE IS TO INCREASE FUNDING
FOR MEDI-CAL AND OTHER HEALTH
PROGRAMS. THIS IS A RELATIVELY
NEW USE. THE STATE STARTED TO DO
THIS IN 2024, AND HAS ADOPTED A
SERIES OF AUGMENTATION OF
INCREASES FOR MEDI-CAL AND OTHER
PROGRAMS, MOST OF WHICH ARE
SCHEDULED TO BEGIN IN 2025 OR
2026. THE THIRD BACKGROUND POINT
I WANT TO EMPHASIZE IS THAT IF
YOU TURN TO PAGE THREE, IT'S
LISTED THERE, AND THAT IS THAT
THIS IS NOT A PERMANENT TAX. SO
THE STATE HAS HAD THE MCO TAX
FOR A NUMBER OF YEARS, BUT HAS
NEVER PERMANENTLY AUTHORIZED IT
IN STATE LAW. INSTEAD, THE
LEGISLATURE HAS AUTHORIZED IT
FOR LIMITED PERIODS OF TIME. THE
TAX ALSO MUST BE APPROVED BY THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT, AND THAT
FEDERAL APPROVAL IS ALSO FOR
LIMITED PERIODS OF TIME. THE
MOST, THE CURRENT TAX IS
APPROVED. THROUGH 2026, AT WHICH
POINT IT WOULD EXPIRE AT THE END
OF 2026. UNLESS IT'S UNLESS IF
IT'S APPROVED AGAIN, YOU TURN TO
PAGE FOUR. WE PROVIDE AN
OVERVIEW OF PROPOSITION 35. AND
THERE ARE TWO KEY POINTS I WANT
TO EMPHASIZE. THE FIRST IS THAT
THE MEASURE MAKES THE MCO TAX
PERMANENT, AND STATE LAW. SO
THIS YOU KNOW, BECAUSE THE TAX
ALREADY IS IN PLACE, THIS WOULD
REALLY BEGIN IN 2027. THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT WOULD STILL
NEED TO APPROVE THE MCO TAX. AND
SO THIS THE STATE WOULD STILL
NEED TO SEEK PERIODIC APPROVAL
FROM THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT. THE
TAC ALSO WOULD BE CONTINUED TO
BE BASED ON THE NUMBER OF PEOPLE
THAT HEALTH PLANS ENROLL, AND
WOULD HAVE A SIMILAR STRUCTURE
TO HOW IT HOW IT THE STRUCTURE
THAT IS CURRENTLY IN PLACE. THE
PROPOSITION DOES ALLOW THE STATE
TO CHANGE THE TAX IF NEEDED FOR
FEDERAL APPROVAL, IT DOES HAVE
CERTAIN LIMITS TO THIS. WE'RE
ALIVE. THE SECOND KEY ASPECT OF
THE PROPOSAL I WANT TO EMPHASIZE
IS IT ALSO CHANGES HOW THE STATE
WOULD USE THE MCO TAX REVENUE.
GENERALLY, THESE RULES WOULD
REQUIRE THE STATE TO SPEND MORE
ON AUGMENTATIONS ON MEDI-CAL AND
OTHER HEALTH PROGRAMS THAN IT IS
CURRENTLY. THE RULES ARE QUITE
EXTENSIVE AND COMPLEX. THERE
ARE. THERE ARE A SET OF RULES IN
THE SHORT TERM IN 2025 AND 2026,
AND THEN ANOTHER SET IN
BEGINNING IN 2027. THEY'RE ALSO
IT ALSO WOULD CHANGE WHICH KIND
OF SERVICES GET AUGMENTATIONS
UNDER THE PACKAGE. AND FOR YOUR
REFERENCE WE SUMMARIZE SOME OF
THESE KEY CHANGES IN ON PAGE ON
THE BOTTOM OF PAGE FOUR. IN THAT
FIGURE. AND AGAIN AS YOU CAN SEE
HERE, THERE IS A LOT OF
SIMILARITY BETWEEN CURRENT LAW
AND PROPOSITION 35, IN TERMS OF
WHICH SERVICES GET
AUGMENTATIONS. BUT THERE ARE
SOME DIFFERENCES FOR EXAMPLE,
THERE ARE CERTAIN LONG TERM
SERVICES AND SUPPORTS THAT WOULD
GET AUGMENTATIONS UNDER CURRENT
LAW, BUT WOULD NOT RECEIVE
AUGMENTATIONS UNDER PROPOSITION
35. ALTERNATIVELY UNDER
PROPOSITION 35, THERE WOULD BE
CERTAIN HOSPITAL SERVICES THAT
WOULD RECEIVE AUGMENTATIONS THAT
DON'T CURRENTLY DO SO. UNDER
CURRENT LAW. LET'S TURN TO PAGE
FIVE. WE SUMMARIZE OUR FISCAL
ANALYSIS, AND WE THINK OF THE
FISCAL EFFECT HERE AS REALLY
BEING DIFFERENT IN THE SHORT
TERM IN 25 AND 26, WHICH IS OVER
THE CURRENT TERM OF THE OF THE
EXISTING TAX. AND THEN THE LONG
TERM IN BEGINNING IN 2027, WHEN
THERE WOULD BE A NEW TAX IN THE
SHORT TERM, THERE ARE THREE
FISCAL EFFECTS. FIRST, THERE
WOULD NOT BE AN EFFECT ON STATE
TAX REVENUE. AND THIS IS BECAUSE
THE MEASURE DOES NOT CHANGE THE
EXISTING MCO TAX STRUCTURE.
SECOND, THE MEASURE WOULD RESULT
IN MORE FUNDING FOR MEDI-CAL AND
OTHER HEALTH PROGRAMS. AND THIS
IS BECAUSE THE STATE WOULD BE
REQUIRED TO USE MORE MCO TAX
REVENUE FOR THIS PURPOSE THAN IT
DOES CURRENTLY, THESE INCREASES
WOULD ALSO COME WITH ADDITIONAL
FEDERAL FUNDING TO. SO WHEN YOU
FACTOR IN BOTH THE STATE AND
FEDERAL FUNDING, WE ESTIMATE
THAT THIS INCREASE WOULD BE
BETWEEN ROUGHLY 2 TO $5 BILLION
ANNUALLY. AND AGAIN, ABOUT HALF
OF THIS WOULD COME FROM THE MCO
TAX. THE THIRD KEY EFFECT IS
THAT THERE WOULD BE AN INCREASE
IN STATE COSTS. THIS IS BECAUSE
THERE WOULD BE LESS FUNDING
AVAILABLE TO HELP PAY FOR
EXISTING SERVICES IN MEDI-CAL.
INSTEAD, THE GENERAL FUND WOULD
HAVE TO COVER THIS COST. WE
ESTIMATE THIS COST TO BE BETWEEN
ROUGHLY 1 TO $2 BILLION IN
ANNUALLY IN 2025 AND 2026. OUR
ANALYSIS ASSUMES THAT THERE ARE
TWO SETS OF RULES FOR IN THE
MEASURE. AGAIN, ONE IN THE SHORT
TERM AND ONE IN THE IN THE LONG
TERM, AND THIS MEANS THAT THERE
WOULD STILL BE ADDITIONAL
FUNDING AVAILABLE IN THE MCO TAX
TO HELP OFFSET GENERAL FUND
SPENDING. IN THE LONG TERM, THE
EFFECTS ARE UNKNOWN. AND THIS IS
THIS IS FOR MANY REASONS. ONE
KEY REASON IS THAT IT'S UNKNOWN
WHETHER THE STATE WOULD
OTHERWISE RENEW THE TAX IN THE
FUTURE. WITHOUT THE MEASURE IN
PLACE. THIS HAS BEEN THE
TRADITIONAL PRACTICE THE STATE
HAS RENEWED THE TAX,
PERIODICALLY, BUT IT'S NOT A
REQUIREMENT IN LAW THAT THE
STATE DO SO. ALSO, IT IS
UNCERTAIN HOW LARGE OF A TAX THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT WOULD APPROVE
IN THE FUTURE. AND THAT HAS KEY
IMPLICATIONS FOR HOW MONEY IS
ALLOCATED IN THE FUTURE. AND
THEN THIRD, WE ALSO WANT TO
EMPHASIZE THAT THE MEASURE DOES
HAVE AN IMPACT ON THE STATE
APPROPRIATIONS LIMIT, THIS IS
ALLOWED UNDER THE CALIFORNIA
CONSTITUTION. PROPOSITION 35
TEMPORARILY INCREASES THE STATE
APPROPRIATIONS LIMIT BY THE SIZE
OF THE MCO TAX FOR FOUR YEARS.
AFTER THAT TEMPORARY INCREASE
ENDS, THE LONG TERM EFFECT OF
THE MEASURE ON THE STATE
SPENDING LIMIT IS UNCERTAIN, AND
THIS AGAIN, IS BECAUSE THE LONG
TERM IMPACT OF THE MEASURE IS
UNKNOWN. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SIR. DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
COMMENTS. GOOD AFTERNOON, CHAIR
ROTH AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. NICK MILLS,
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE, WE
UNDERSTAND THAT THE ESTIMATED
GENERAL FUND SHORTFALL DIFFERS
FROM THE ADMINISTRATION'S. WE
WERE TAKING TIME TO FURTHER
EVALUATE THEIR ANALYSIS.
HOWEVER, BOTH THE ADMINISTRATION
AND THE LAO ANTICIPATE A GENERAL
FUND SHORTFALL TO THE EXTENT
PROPOSITION 35 IS APPROVED BY
THE VOTERS, THE ADMINISTRATION
ESTIMATES THE GENERAL FUND
SHORTFALL OF APPROXIMATELY $11.9
BILLION ASSOCIATED WITH THE TERM
OF THE TAX, $2.6 BILLION IN
2425, 4.9 BILLION IN 2526, AND
4.3 BILLION IN 2627. BASED ON
THE ADMINISTRATION'S ESTIMATES
STARTING JANUARY 1ST, 2025, THE
INITIATIVE WOULD NOT ALLOW FOR
NEARLY ALL NET REVENUE FROM THE
TAX, INCLUDING ADDITIONAL
REVENUE FROM THE TWO MCO TAX
AMENDMENTS OF ABOUT $6.7 BILLION
TO BE USED TO SUPPORT THE
MEDI-CAL PROGRAM. THE INITIATIVE
SPECIFIES THAT IN CALENDAR YEARS
2025 AND 2026, ONLY $2 BILLION
ANNUALLY MAY BE USED FOR THIS
PURPOSE. ANY REMAINING FUNDING
WOULD BE REDIRECTED TOWARDS NEW
EXPENDITURES OR DEPOSITED IN
NEWLY CREATED SUBACCOUNTS. IN
CONTRAST, THE 2024 BUDGET ACT
MCO TAX PACKAGE INCLUDED $6.9
BILLION IN FISCAL YEAR 2425, 6.6
BILLION INCHES 25, 26, AND
5,000,000,000 IN 2627, AND MCO
TAX FUNDING TO SUPPORT MEDI-CAL.
WE'D ALSO NOTE THAT THE GENERAL
FUND SHORTFALL COULD BE GREATER
BY HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS IF THE
TIMING OF MCO TAX REVENUE
COLLECTION AND FEDERAL APPROVAL
OF THE TWO MCO AMENDMENTS ARE
DELAYED, FINALLY, PER THE 2024
BUDGET ACT, TO THE EXTENT THAT
VOTERS ADOPT PROPOSITION 35, THE
$133 MILLION IN 2425, $728
MILLION IN 2526, AND 1.2 BILLION
IN 2627 FOR NEW TARGETED
MEDI-CAL PROVIDER RATE INCREASES
AND INVESTMENTS THAT WOULD TAKE
EFFECT EITHER ON JANUARY 1ST,
2025, OR JANUARY 1ST, 2026 WOULD
BECOME INOPERABLE AS BOTH THE
INITIATIVE AND THESE RATE
INVESTMENTS CANNOT FISCALLY BE
SUSTAINED, THANK YOU AGAIN FOR
PROVIDING FINANCE WITH THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK ON THE
FISCAL IMPACT OF PROPOSITION 35
AND AVAILABLE TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU. MEMBERS.
QUESTIONS. COMMENTS. CONCERNS
SENATOR MENGIBAR. THANK YOU.
NICK. MY QUESTIONS FOR YOU. THE
LAST PART YOU MENTIONED,
INOPERATIVE, THAT LANGUAGE IS
PUT IN ON THE REQUEST OF THE
ADMINISTRATION DURING THE DURING
THE BUDGET NEGOTIATIONS, REALLY
RENDERING US WITH THE INABILITY
TO FURTHER INVESTMENTS OR
FURTHER THE INVESTMENTS WE
FOUGHT SO HARD, THOSE ADDITIONAL
INVESTMENTS, CAN YOU TELL ME,
WAS THERE A POSSIBILITY TO HAVE
EXCLUDED THAT SENTENCE, MEANING,
LET ME REPHRASE. IF THAT
SENTENCE WASN'T IN THE BUDGET,
PLAN AND THIS PROPOSITION WERE
TO HAVE PASSED, WOULD THE
ADMINISTRATION WOULD WE HAVE
BEEN HAD THE ABILITY TO SUSTAIN
BOTH OF THEM? LARA LÀ DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE, BASED AT ON THE
ADMINISTRATION'S ESTIMATE,
ESTIMATED COSTS AND THE GENERAL
FUND SHORTFALL THAT WE WERE
FACING AT 2024 BUDGET ACT, THE
DECISION WAS MADE TO ADD THAT
LANGUAGE. SO IT'S, I THINK THAT
OUR INTERPRETATION AT THAT TIME
WAS THAT THEY COULD NOT BE BOTH
FISCALLY SUSTAINED. IS THERE
MAYBE A QUESTION FOR BOTH OF
YOU? DO YOU SEE ANY ROOM FOR
FINDING, I GUESS, ROOM FOR THOSE
INVESTMENTS TO GET SUPPORT IN
THE UPCOMING YEARS? THE
ADMINISTRATION WILL PUT FORTH A
PROPOSAL IN JANUARY TO BUDGET TO
BALANCE THE BUDGET AS
CONSTITUTIONALLY REQUIRED. IF
THIS WERE TO BECAUSE THIS THIS
YEAR, LEGISLATORS WERE TOLD,
HEY, YOU GOT TO DO HARD, HARD
DECISIONS BECAUSE WE'RE GOING TO
BALANCE TWO YEARS WORTH OF
BUDGETS. THIS PROPOSITION
PASSES. DOES THAT REALLY NEGATE
ALL THE HARD WORK WE DID THIS
YEAR AND NEXT YEAR? WE'RE GOING
TO START WITH A REALLY WITH
ANOTHER HUGE DEFICIT. LARA
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. I DON'T
THINK WE COULD SPEAK TO THAT
YET. WE WILL BEGIN OUR BUDGET
DEVELOPMENT IN THIS FALL AND
COME OUT WITH THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET IN JANUARY. THANK YOU.
SENATOR. DOCTOR WEBER. THANK
YOU, SENATOR ROTH, I WANT TO
THANK OUR PANELISTS FOR KICKING
OFF THIS VERY IMPORTANT
CONVERSATION. I WANT TO GO BACK,
IF I MAY, AND JUST ASK AGAIN,
WHAT EXACTLY IS THE INTENDED
PURPOSE OF THE MCO TAX? WELL, I
THINK HISTORICALLY, THE MCO TAX
HAS EXISTED TO, YOU KNOW,
PROVIDE ADDITIONAL FUNDING TO
THE MEDI-CAL PROGRAM. IT'S
SERVED DIFFERENT FUNCTIONS OVER
TIME DEPENDING ON WHAT VERSION
OF THE TAX YOU'RE WE'RE LOOKING
AT IN MANY YEARS, IT'S EXISTED.
IT SUPPORTED THE SORT OF
EXISTING PROGRAM IN MEDI-CAL,
BUT THAT THE LEGISLATURE
EXPANDED THAT PURPOSE WHEN IT
ADDED, SET ASIDE SOME OF THE
FUNDING FOR AUGMENTATIONS. SO
THE PURPOSE HAS EVOLVED OVER
TIME. YOU KNOW, I THINK ONE OF
MY CONCERNS IS WE TALK A LOT
ABOUT HOW MUCH IT WILL COST, YOU
KNOW, TO HAVE SOMETHING LIKE,
YOU KNOW, PROP 35 OR BEFORE WHEN
WE WERE TALKING ABOUT THE
ORIGINAL MCO, TAX, WHICH REALLY
WAS TO ENSURE THAT THE PATIENTS
WITHIN OUR MEDI-CAL SYSTEM HAVE
ACCESS TO PROVIDERS. RIGHT.
WE'VE DONE A GREAT JOB IN THIS
STATE OF ENSURING THAT PRETTY
MUCH EVERYONE IS COVERED. BUT
LIKE I'VE SAID, MANY TIMES ON
THE ON THE ASSEMBLY SIDE, YOU
CAN HAVE EVERYONE COVERED, BUT
YOU DON'T HAVE. IF YOU DON'T
HAVE PROVIDERS THAT YOU CAN
ACTUALLY SEE, THEN WE'VE REALLY
DONE NOTHING. SO MY QUESTION IS
TO FINANCE, HAVE YOU ALL LOOKED
AT WHAT WOULD BE THE ESTIMATED
COST TO ENSURE THAT ALL
CALIFORNIANS ACTUALLY HAVE
ACCESS TO CARE? BECAUSE WE KNOW
THAT THAT'S CLEARLY NOT THE CASE
AT THIS POINT, HAVE WE LOOKED AT
THOSE NUMBERS TO SAY, WHAT WOULD
IT COST US TO ENSURE THAT ALL OF
THESE PATIENTS THAT WE ARE NOW
GIVING INSURANCE TO HAVE
ACTUALLY PHYSICIANS AND
PROVIDERS THAT THEY CAN ACTUALLY
SEE IN A TIMELY MANNER? I THINK
AS, THE, THE ADMINISTRATION
SPOKE DURING ALL OF THE BUDGET
HEARINGS, WE HAVE NOT DONE THAT
ANALYSIS. I DON'T KNOW THAT
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT'S POSSIBLE
TO PUT A NUMBER ON. BUT NO, WE
DON'T WE HAVEN'T DONE THAT
ANALYSIS. ALL RIGHT. WELL LET'S
LOOK AT IT FROM A DIFFERENT
ANGLE. WHAT IS THE PURPOSE OF
ALLOWING SOMEONE TO HAVE ACCESS
TO THEIR PRIMARY CARE PROVIDER,
WHETHER IT'S A FAMILY PRACTICE
DOCTOR OR PEDIATRICIAN, INTERNAL
MEDICINE, I GUESS EVEN OB GYN AT
TIME. WHAT'S THE PURPOSE OF THAT?
FROM A HEALTH CARE STANDPOINT,
IT'S TO PREVENT CHRONIC
CONDITIONS. IT'S TO PREVENT LONG
TERM ILLNESSES. IT'S TO PREVENT
HOSPITALIZATIONS, SURGERIES,
CHRONIC MEDICATIONS. SO HAVE YOU
ALL LOOKED AT IT FROM THE STANCE
OF IF WE DON'T PROVIDE ACCESS
AND THESE INDIVIDUALS ARE UNABLE
TO GET THAT PREVENTATIVE CARE,
WHAT THE COST WITHIN THE
MEDI-CAL SYSTEM, WHAT THE COST
OF THE STATE WOULD BE TO CARE
FOR THESE PEOPLE ONCE THEY HAVE
THESE CHRONIC CONDITIONS,
CHRONIC HOSPITALIZATIONS,
CHRONIC, MEDICATION SURGERIES.
HAVE WE LOOKED AT THAT? AGAIN,
NO, WE HAVE NOT. AND THE BUDGET
THAT WE THAT THE LEGISLATURE AND
THE ADMINISTRATION AGREED UPON
WAS TO BALANCE THE BUDGET
ACCORDING TO THE LARGE, GENERAL
FUND DEFICIT WE'VE BEEN FACING.
SO THOSE ARE THE BUDGETS THAT
THE LEGISLATURE AND THE
ADMINISTRATION HAVE AGREED TO
DO. WE BELIEVE THAT MEDI-CAL
PATIENTS TODAY HAVE THE SAME
ACCESS TO HEALTH CARE SERVICES
AS PATIENTS IN COMMERCIAL
INSURANCE?
I DON'T KNOW THAT WE COULD SPEAK
TO THE ACCESS IN COMMERCIAL
VERSUS MEDI-CAL. YEAH, I THINK I
THINK IF WE'RE DOING WORK WITHIN
THE HEALTH CARE SPACE, EVEN FROM
A FINANCE STANDPOINT, WE SHOULD
HAVE A BASIC UNDERSTANDING OF
THE LANDSCAPE OF WHAT WE'RE
DEALING WITH. AND I KNOW FROM A
LEGISLATIVE STANDPOINT, WE'RE
CONSTANTLY HEARING ABOUT ISSUES
OF ACCESS, THE INABILITY FOR
PATIENTS TO EITHER HAVE OR SEE
DOCTORS OR BE ABLE TO SEE THEM
IN A TIMELY FASHION, WHICH
ULTIMATELY, LIKE I SAID, IF YOU
CAN'T SEE YOUR DOCTOR OR YOUR
PROVIDER, WE'RE NOT REALLY DOING
MUCH. SO OUTSIDE OF THAT, CAN
YOU ALL PROVIDE ME WITH A
DETAILED LIST OF PROVIDER RATE
INCREASES THAT HAVE BEEN
PROPOSED BY ANY ADMINISTRATION
IN THE LAST 20 YEARS? WE CAN
WORK ON THAT AND GET BACK TO
YOU. OKAY SO ESSENTIALLY YOU
DON'T HAVE THAT INFORMATION TO
SAY WHEN THE LAST TIME AN
ADMINISTRATION OR DODD SUPPORTED
RATE AUGMENTATION FOR OUR
PROVIDERS IN THE MEDI-CAL
SYSTEM, I DON'T WANT TO SPEAK
OFF THE TOP OF MY HEAD, AND I
DON'T WANT TO GIVE INCORRECT
INFORMATION, BUT WE HAVE
PROPOSED THOSE, AND WE WILL
PROVIDE YOU WITH THE
INFORMATION. OKAY, I'M GOING TO
TURN IT BACK OVER. SENATOR
MENGIBAR, YOU HAVE A QUESTION.
THANK YOU. ASSEMBLYMEMBER, I
THINK YOU BROUGHT UP A POINT
THAT REMINDED ME WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT INVESTING IN PREVENTATIVE
MEASURES, ENTITIES AND SO FORTH.
THE WHOLE GOAL IS TO, LIKE THE
GOOD DOCTOR MENTIONED, IS TO GET
PEOPLE OUT OF ERS. AND THAT'S
WHAT I THOUGHT WE DID WITH THE
BIG WINS THAT WE GOT THIS YEAR
WHERE WE INVESTED IN
PREVENTATIVE NATURE AND
PREVENTATIVE, ENTITIES. WE WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE INVEST IN
CBAS AS THE SENIOR ADULT
CENTERS, BECAUSE WE GET THOSE
SENIORS OUT OF ERS, OUT OF
HAVING BEDSORES AND SO FORTH.
GET THEM ACTIVE. SO THEY'RE
LIVING LONGER AND NOT HAVING TO
GO TO ACUTE HOSPITALS. PEDIATRIC
DAY CENTERS ARE THE SAME THING,
I SAW THE AD FOR PROP 35 ABOUT
HELPING KIDS IN MEDI-CAL. BUT IN
CALIFORNIA, WE HAVE KIDS WHO ARE
FALLING OUT OF MEDI-CAL AGES 0
TO 5 BECAUSE THERE'S NO MONEY
FOR US TO GET THEM TO STAY IN
MEDI-CAL. SO YES, WE CAN FURTHER
INVEST AND WE SHOULD INVEST IN
PROVIDER RATE REFORM OR PROVIDER
RATE INCREASES. I'M 100% FOR
THAT, BUT WE'RE GOING TO DO THAT
AND STILL HAVE KIDS WHO AREN'T
EVEN ABLE TO MAINTAIN ACCESS TO
MEDI-CAL BECAUSE THEY'RE FALLING
OFF OF MEDI-CAL. SO I DON'T
UNDERSTAND HOW WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT PREVENTATIVE INVESTMENTS,
WHERE WE'RE GOING TO UNDO THE
HUGE WINS THAT WE HAD THIS YEAR
THAT ARE ACTUALLY GOING TO HELP
IN PREVENTATIVE NATURE. KIDS WHO
ARE IN HOSPITALS RIGHT NOW WHO
CAN'T GO HOME, WE'RE PAYING
HUNDREDS AND HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS TO KEEP
THEM IN HOSPITALS WHEN THEY
COULD BE AT HOME, BE. BUT WE'RE
GOING WE'RE GOING TO UNDO THOSE
INVESTMENTS. AND I'M WONDERING,
DOV LAO, HOW COMMON IS IT?
BECAUSE THIS IS MY SECOND YEAR
HERE. HOW COMMON IS IT FOR
ELECTED OFFICIALS WHO WERE VOTED
INTO THIS BODY TO PASS POLICY TO
GO THROUGH A WHOLE PROCESS, TO
PASS A BUDGET AND HAVE
NON-ELECTED OFFICIALS THEN UNDO
THEIR WORK? HOW COMMON IS THAT?
YEAH. I DON'T KNOW IF I HAVE A
COMPLETE ANSWER. I DON'T HAVE
ALL THE COMPLETE INFORMATION. I
WILL SAY THAT THERE ARE A NUMBER
OF BALLOT MEASURES. EVERY YEAR
THAT CAN HAVE INTERACTIONS WITH
THE SORT OF STATE BUDGET AND
POLICY MAKING, I WOULD ALSO
EMPHASIZE THAT YOU MAY HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO EXPLORE SOME OF
THE QUESTIONS YOU HAVE IN THE
FOLLOWING PANELS. THANK YOU. I
JUST WANT TO, NOT LOSE FOCUS
THAT, THE LEGISLATURE AND THE
ADMINISTRATION IN THE 2024
BUDGET ACT DID INCLUDE
SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENTS ON
PREVENTATIVE CARE AND, FOR
PRIMARY CARE DOCTORS. AND IT
ALSO INCLUDES THE CONTINUOUS
COVERAGE. SO IT WAS A GOOD MIX
IN MY OPINION. THE LANGUAGE AND
THE FUNDING INCLUDED IN THE 2024
BUDGET ACT WAS AN AGREEMENT
BETWEEN THE LEGISLATURE AND THE
ADMINISTRATION, WHICH WOULD BE
UNDONE. AND WE CAN'T SPEAK TO
WHAT IS OR WHAT IS NOT INCLUDED
IN THE INITIATIVE. SENATOR
LAMONE, THANK YOU, YOU KNOW, I
HEAR A THEME AMONG SO FAR, MY
COLLEAGUES ON THE ASSEMBLY AND
HERE IN THE SENATE IN TERMS OF
SOME OF THE THINGS THAT WE'RE
ASKING. AND I'VE OFTENTIMES, YOU
KNOW, WE ALL THINK OF HEALTH
CARE AS A STATEWIDE ISSUE, BUT
CERTAINLY ALSO A REGIONAL ISSUE.
YOU THINK ABOUT THE DISTRICT YOU
REPRESENT. AND I THINK OF THE
FACT THAT IN MY DISTRICT, I HAVE
RURAL, VERY RURAL AREAS, OF OUR
STATE. BUT I ALSO HAVE, YOU
KNOW, THE COAST. I HAVE AN
URBAN, YOU KNOW, CENTER AS WELL.
AND I THINK OF WHAT IT WILL TAKE
TO HAVE TO INCREASE ACCESS. AND
WE CAN'T HAVE A CONVERSATION
ABOUT ACCESS WITHOUT THE
PROVIDERS. AND THE MORE THAT I
WORK WITH OUR COMMUNITIES AND
OUR HEALTH CARE PROVIDERS, THE
PIECE THAT THAT KEEPS COMING UP
HERE HAS TO DO WITH OUR MEDI-CAL
REIMBURSEMENT AND ALSO
AUGMENTATION, AND I THINK THAT
THOSE ARE BOTH REALLY IMPORTANT
ISSUES. AND SO WHEN WE TALK
ABOUT WHAT'S HAPPENED HERE AND
WHETHER, YOU KNOW, REGARDLESS OF
WHAT DIRECTION WE'RE GOING, I
THINK IT CONTINUES TO PRESENT A
CHALLENGE FOR US TO SEE AN
ABSENCE OR A VERY LOW FREQUENCY.
I, I ACTUALLY HOPE THAT YOU WILL
ALSO SHARE, MAYBE WITH THE WHOLE
COMMITTEE, THE NUMBERS AS WELL,
WHEN WE DON'T SEE SOME OF THE
RATE, YOU KNOW, AUGMENTATIONS
AND I FEEL LIKE THAT IS A TRUE
OBSTACLE TO CARE WHEN I, WHEN I
THINK OF THIS CONVERSATION AND
HOW IT GETS TRANSLATED TO THE
DISTRICT, AND WHEN YOU GO OUT
AND YOU'RE A REPRESENTATIVE AND
YOU MEET PEOPLE WHO TELL YOU
THAT THEY HAVE TO DRIVE 40 MILES
TO SEE SOMEONE, AND THEN YOU
MEET PROVIDERS WHO ARE LIKE,
WE'RE TRYING TO SEE AS MANY
PEOPLE AS WE CAN, BUT YOU NEED
TO UNDERSTAND, LIKE WITHOUT THE
RATES GOING UP, WITHOUT
REIMBURSEMENT, WE DON'T HAVE THE
CAPACITY BECAUSE THEY ARE
ALREADY WORKING, AS MUCH AS
POSSIBLE. I'VE SAID THIS VERY
PUBLICLY. I'VE BEEN TO THE
DOCTOR BECAUSE I HAVE A TODDLER
MORE THAN I HAVE THAN I'VE BEEN
PROBABLY MY WHOLE LIFE. THERE
ARE WEIGHTS AND WEIGHTS AND
LINES OF PEOPLE LIKE, IT'S HARD
TO GET IN, AND THIS IS PART OF
THE OVERALL CARE AND SO I SHARE
THESE COMMENTS AS A WAY TO ECHO
AN ISSUE THAT'S REALLY IMPORTANT
TO I THINK, SEVERAL MEMBERS, AND
YOU KNOW, I APPRECIATE THAT YOU
ALL HAVE A PERSPECTIVE AND A
KNOWLEDGE TO ADD TO THIS, BUT I
WANT TO UNDERSCORE THAT WHEN WE
CONTINUOUSLY BRING UP
AUGMENTATION, MEDICAL
REIMBURSEMENT RATE, MEDICAL
MEDI-CAL REIMBURSEMENT RATES,
IT'S BECAUSE THIS IS WHAT WE'RE
HEARING FROM CONSTITUENTS IN OUR
DISTRICT. THIS IS A PROBLEM TO
ACCESSING CARE. AND I DON'T WANT
THAT TO BE DISMISSED BECAUSE
THIS IS A, YOU KNOW, A HEARING.
AND I DON'T WANT IT TO BE
DISMISSED IN A SENSE OF LIKE,
LOOK, THEY'RE IN A PARTICULAR
PLACE. WE ARE ARTICULATING THE
ISSUES THAT WE SEE EVERY DAY
THAT ARE VERY REAL, THAT BLOCK
ACCESS TO CARE. THAT IS WHAT I
THINK WE'RE TRYING TO DELIVER.
AND SO I WANT TO BE A VOICE TO
ECHO ON THAT, BECAUSE IT'S VERY
IMPORTANT. AND IT IS ALSO AN
ISSUE THAT IN A LOT OF
COMMUNITIES, REGIONAL
COMMUNITIES LIKE, IT IS EVEN
WORSE IN RURAL AREAS. AND I
CANNOT BEGIN TO TELL YOU HOW
DIFFICULT IT IS TO SEE FAMILIES
TO SEE INDIVIDUALS WHO NEED
CARE, WHO BEST CASE SCENARIO,
HAVE TO DRIVE MILES AND MILES
AWAY TO SEE A PROVIDER. AND I'M
TALKING ABOUT GENERAL CARE.
DON'T EVEN GET ME CAUGHT UP ON
SPECIALTY CARE. SO I THINK THAT,
YOU KNOW, I HOPE THAT THESE
COMMENTS AREN'T DISMISSED IN ANY
WAY AND THAT THE QUESTIONS WE
ASK, WE'RE ABLE TO ENGAGE AT
SOME POINT ABOUT WHAT IT WILL
TAKE TO GET THERE. TO BE ABLE TO
DO BETTER MEDI-CAL REIMBURSEMENT
RATES AND TO ENSURE THAT WE'RE
ALSO LOOKING AT AUGMENTATION.
AND THAT IS SOMETHING THAT I
THINK IS VERY REAL BECAUSE IT
HAS AN IMPACT. AND I WILL TELL
YOU THAT JUST SEEING THE LINES
OF PEOPLE THAT ARE TRYING TO SEE
A DOCTOR, ANY KIND OF DOCTOR, IS
REALLY IMPORTANT AND IT'S REALLY
DIFFICULT. SO I HOPE THAT THAT'S
SHARED HERE. I THINK IT'S A
COMMON THEME, I KNOW YOU'RE ONLY
IN POSITIONS TO GIVE US VERY
SHORT, SUCCINCT ANSWERS, BUT I
HOPE THAT THAT WILL BE SOME PART
OF WHAT YOU TAKE TO DELIBERATE
ON HOW WE CAN WORK TOGETHER TO
BETTER ADDRESS THIS. THANK YOU.
SENATOR. ASSEMBLYMEMBER
JONES-SAWYER, THANK YOU. AND I,
I KNOW THIS IS THE INITIATIVE
OVERVIEW AND A FISCAL IMPACT.
AND, YOU KNOW, I, I THIS IS MY
LAST YEAR, AND I ALSO SERVED IN
LOCAL GOVERNMENT AND ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT HAS ALWAYS BOTHERED
ME, DISTURBED ME, OR ME OFF HAS
BEEN THE FACT THAT BUDGET
ANALYSTS, WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT
COST BENEFIT ANALYSIS, THEY
NEVER LOOK AT COST AVOIDANCE,
COST AVOIDANCE IS LIKE, YOU
KNOW, IT HAPPENS. IT HAPPENS
SOMEWHERE. BUT WE WILL NEVER
CALCULATE THAT. BUT WE WILL
CALCULATE WHAT IT WILL COST
EVERY DAY AND EVERY WAY. AND I
SAY THIS IN THIS CONTEXT, I AM A
DIABETIC. I WAS PRE-DIABETIC
THEN. I WAS DIABETIC, AND THEN I
WAS ON METFORMIN, INSULIN AND, A
WHOLE BUNCH OF OTHER PILLS, A
NURSE SAT DOWN WITH ME AND SAID
SHE WAS TIRED OF SEEING AFRICAN
AMERICAN MALES COMING INTO THE
OFFICE, THAT IMMEDIATELY THEY
WERE TOLD THAT THEY WERE
DIABETIC. IMMEDIATELY THEY WERE
PUT ON METFORMIN. IMMEDIATELY
THEY WERE PUT ON INSULIN. AND
SHE SAID TO ME AT THE TIME, IF
YOU LOSE A LITTLE WEIGHT,
BROTHER, YOU GET OFF THE SWEETS,
YOU EAT, RIGHT, WALK A LITTLE
BIT MORE DIET, I LOST 40 POUNDS.
START WALKING AROUND THIS PLACE.
EVEN AT 150 DEGREE, 15 DEGREE
HEAT. AND I'M NO LONGER ON
INSULIN. I'M NO LONGER ON
METFORMIN. AND MY NUMBERS NOW
SAY THAT I AM NO LONGER A
DIABETIC. I HAVE INSURANCE, WITH
THE STATE. LUCKILY BUT HOW MUCH
WOULD WE BE PAYING FOR ME AS AN
INDIVIDUAL TO CONTINUE TO PAY
INSULIN AND MEDICATION COSTS FOR
THE REST OF MY LIFE? LET ME SAY
THAT AGAIN. HOW COME WE CAN'T
CALCULATE THE COST AVOIDANCE
THAT YOU CAN NOW CALCULATE ON ME
ALONE? HOW MUCH WE'VE SAVED
TAXPAYERS BECAUSE I'M BEING PAID
BY. BUT WE CAN'T. ABSOLUTELY YOU
CAN'T WITH ME. ABSOLUTELY. YOU
CAN. AT LEAST ESTIMATE BECAUSE
YOU ESTIMATE EVERY DAY WHEN WE
COME UP WITH NEW BILLS, YOU
ESTIMATE WHAT IT WILL COST THE
SYSTEM. SOMETIMES IT'S REALLY
EXTRAVAGANT NUMBERS. YOU'RE REAL
EASY AT MAKING THOSE ESTIMATES.
BUT WHEN IT COMES TO THIS, WHERE
WE CAN SAVE TAXPAYERS TAXPAYER
MONEY, I DON'T KNOW WHY WE'RE WE
DON'T DO IT. IS IT SOMETHING
THAT WE SHOULD MAYBE WITH THE
SENATE AND ASSEMBLY THAT BECOMES
PART OF THE BUDGET PROCESS THAT
WE ADD IN COST AVOIDANCE IN THE
CALCULATIONS THAT WE GET FROM
THE BUDGET. LAL FROM DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE. IS THAT SOMETHING WE
SHOULD ACTUALLY DEMAND SO THAT
WE CAN GET A FULL COST BENEFIT
ANALYSIS OF WHAT IT ACTUALLY
COSTS OR WHAT WE CAN DO TO BRING
DOWN COSTS, BECAUSE, RIGHT NOW
IT'S ALMOST AS IF LET'S JUST
KEEP SPENDING AND SPENDING AND
SPENDING AND SPENDING AND WE'RE
REALLY NOT TRYING TO SOLVE THE
PROBLEM. WE JUST WANT TO
CONTINUE PAYING FOR THIS
INDUSTRY. AND BLOATING THAT THAT
DOLLAR AMOUNT. AND SO IS THAT
SOMETHING. AND I'M GOING TO MAKE
A SUGGESTION. IS THAT SOMETHING.
AND THIS IS MY LAST YEAR. SO
THAT WOULD LEAVE IT WITH SOME
PEOPLE HERE THAT MAYBE IS THAT
SOMETHING WE CAN LEGISLATE THAT
YOU'RE ABLE TO DO. AND PUT IN
THE BUDGET ANALYSIS THAT YOU
GIVE TO US SO THAT WE HAVE A
FULL UNDERSTANDING OF WHAT WE'RE
VOTING ON OR EVEN WHAT WE CAN DO
TO HELP BRING DOWN COSTS. SO
OUR, YOU KNOW, OUR OFFICE IS
ALWAYS AVAILABLE. PEOPLE GETTING
UP NOW. ALL RIGHT. OUR OFFICE IS
ALWAYS AVAILABLE TO WORK WITH
THE LEGISLATURE ON ON THINKING
OF NEW LEGISLATION OR ASSISTING
THE LEGISLATURE ON FISCAL
MATTERS. SO WE'RE WE'RE ALWAYS
AVAILABLE TO HAVE THAT
CONVERSATION, YOU KNOW, I WOULD
EMPHASIZE THAT, YOU KNOW, OUR
ANALYZES, YOU KNOW, GENERALLY
TRY TO CONSIDER COSTS FROM MANY
DIFFERENT ANGLES. THERE ARE
COSTS AND REVENUE IMPACTS THAT
THAT ARE OFTEN VERY CERTAIN AND
DIRECT FROM MEASURES. AND AS YOU
NOTE, WE OFTEN HAVE A, YOU KNOW,
A MORE DIRECT WAY OF GETTING AT
THOSE. THERE ALSO ARE MORE
INDIRECT IMPACTS, AND SOMETIMES
THOSE ARE HARD TO QUANTIFY. THIS
IS A PERENNIAL CHALLENGE IN IN
THE HEALTH CARE AREA BECAUSE,
YOU KNOW, WHEN YOU INCREASE
FUNDING FOR HEALTH CARE THAT CAN
HAVE MANY DIFFERENT IMPACTS ON
UTILIZATION, ON OUTCOMES, AND
THAT CAN HAVE, YOU KNOW, VERY
UNCERTAIN IMPACTS. IT COULD IT
COULD INCREASE SPENDING IN SOME
CASES. IN SOME CASES IT COULD
DECREASE SPENDING. IT WOULD
DEPEND ON NOT JUST HOW OFTEN
SERVICES ARE UTILIZED, BUT THE
LONG TERM EFFECTS OF THAT. SO,
YOU KNOW, IT IS JUST A PERENNIAL
CHALLENGE THAT WE FACE IN THIS
AREA IS HOW TO GET AT THESE MORE
SORT OF INDIRECT IMPACTS. AND
ALSO WERE THERE A LOT MORE
UNCERTAIN. I THINK MY COSTS ARE
NOT UNCERTAIN. I KNOW YOU SHOULD
KNOW WHAT YOU PAY OR WHAT YOU'VE
BEEN PAYING FOR ME, WHEN I WAS
ON INSULIN, METFORMIN AND HOW
MUCH YOU'RE SAVING FOR ME NOT TO
BE SO I WOULDN'T CONSIDER THAT.
OR IF YOU TOLD US OTHER PEOPLE
OFF AND GOT BETTER CARE AND
PREVENTATIVE CARE, YOU COULD
ESTIMATE WHAT THAT COULD BE. AND
I DON'T UNDERSTAND WHY WE CAN'T
DO THAT. CAROLYN TRUE WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE
VERY MUCH APPRECIATE THE POINT
THAT YOU'RE MAKING, SIR. I THINK
WHAT WE WOULD OFFER IS THAT, YOU
KNOW, WHEN OUR OFFICE,
PARTICULARLY IN THE BUDGET
CONTEXT, MAY BE SPEAKING OUTSIDE
OF OUR ANALYSIS FOR THE FISCAL
EFFECTS OF THIS MEASURE
SPECIFICALLY, BUT TALKING ABOUT
BUDGET ANALYSIS IN THE BUDGET
CONTEXT, WE OFTEN GET QUESTIONS
FROM YOU AND YOUR COLLEAGUES
ABOUT THE POSSIBLE LONG TERM
SAVINGS FROM REDUCING
UTILIZATION OF A OF A PARTICULAR
SERVICE OR IMPROVING THE HEALTH
OF, CALIFORNIANS OVERALL. AND WE
DO TRY TO LOOK WE LOOK, OF
COURSE, AT THE RESEARCH AND WHAT
THE STUDIES CAN TELL US ABOUT
WHAT THE POTENTIAL LONG TERM
SAVINGS CAN BE. SOMETIMES THOSE
SAVINGS DON'T ACTUALLY ACCRUE TO
THE STATE. THEY ACCRUE TO OTHER,
COMPONENTS OF SOCIETY, EITHER
JUST THROUGH GENERAL SOCIAL
BENEFIT OR FOLKS LIVING LONGER
OR DIFFERENT THINGS LIKE THAT.
BUT WE VERY MUCH APPRECIATE THE
POINT THAT YOU'RE MAKING, AND
IT'S ONE THAT'S COME UP IN THE
BUDGET CONTEXT QUITE FREQUENTLY
IN THE, SPECIFIC, BALLOT
ANALYSIS BEFORE US, AS MY
COLLEAGUE MR. KONSTANTARAS, WAS
REFERENCING, WE'RE FOCUSED ON
REALLY THE DIRECT EFFECTS OF THE
MEASURE IN TERMS OF HOW THE TAX
REVENUES CAN BE SPENT OR NOT
SPENT RELATIVE TO THE CURRENT
LAW DISTRIBUTION OF THOSE
REVENUES. BUT GO AHEAD, NÓ AND
ASSEMBLYMEMBER'S. DOES THAT
ANSWER YOUR QUESTION OR NOT
REALLY. BUT I. THAT THAT BECAUSE
YOU YOU WILL I MEAN, I'VE SEEN
THE LAW AND THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE WHEN I'VE HAD BILLS GO
THROUGH AND ALL OF A SUDDEN YOU
PULL A RABBIT OUT OF THE HAT AND
SAYS, IT'S MORE EXPENSIVE, ALL
OF A SUDDEN IT'S $6 BILLION OR
IT'S $2 BILLION. WHEN I KNOW FOR
A FACT IT'S $100,000, AND ALL OF
A SUDDEN THERE'S THESE NEW
MITIGATING CIRCUMSTANCES OF WHY
IT COSTS SO MUCH. AND IT SEEMS
TO BE REALLY EASY TO PUT A LOT
OF COST ON THINGS WHEN WHAT I'M
WHAT I'M SAYING IS THERE IS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO SHOW THAT, LIKE
RIGHT NOW, IF THIS BILL DOESN'T
GO TO ANY KIND OF PREVENTATIVE
OR THIS INITIATIVE DOESN'T EVEN
LOOK AT PREVENTATIVE, WHERE
THERE COULD BE BENEFITS, NOT
ONLY JUST THE HEALTH BENEFITS,
WHICH WE ALL WANT THAT, BUT
FINANCIAL BENEFITS THAT, MY
QUESTION WAS, HOW DO WE INCLUDE
THAT? IS THAT SOMETHING? THAT'S
SOMETHING I CAN ASK FOR RIGHT
NOW. I KNOW YOU JUST SAID YOU
CAN ASK THEM, SO I'M ASKING FOR
IT RIGHT NOW TO BE ABLE TO GET
THAT KIND OF COST BENEFIT
ANALYSIS. MAYBE THAT IS THE BEST
WAY. SO WE'RE NOT SITTING HERE
ALL AFTERNOON GOING BACK AND
FORTH ON WHETHER OR NOT WE CAN
DO THAT. AND SO I, I WOULD LIKE
TO REQUEST THAT, EVEN IF YOU
JUST USE ME AS A, AS A, AS A
MICROCOSM OF WHAT YOU COULD
POSSIBLY GET. WE CERTAINLY CAN
FOLLOW UP WITH YOUR STAFF TO
MAKE SURE WE'RE ANSWERING THE
QUESTION THAT YOU'RE POSING TO
US. THANK YOU. THANK YOU SIR.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SCHIAVO. MY
COLLEAGUE GOT TO A LOT OF WHAT I
WAS WANTING TO ASK ABOUT, SO I
ALSO LOOK FORWARD TO SOME
ANALYSIS IN THAT SPACE, BECAUSE
I THINK HEALTH CARE, ESPECIALLY,
IS ONE OF THE AREAS IN WHICH
THERE IS A LOT OF COST BENEFIT
WHEN YOU PROVIDE CARE,
PREVENTATIVE CARE EARLY CARE AND
PROACTIVE CARE. AND WE ALL KNOW
HORROR STORIES OF PEOPLE ON
MEDI-CAL WITH LONG WAITS, AND
LONG LINES AND STRUGGLES TO GET
CARE WHEN THEY NEED IT. AND, YOU
KNOW, AT THE END OF THE DAY, I
THINK THERE'S BROAD AGREEMENT
THAT THE COST OF CARE IS NOT
REIMBURSED AT MEDI-CAL RATES.
MEDI-CAL DOES NOT COVER THE COST
OF CARE, AND THAT'S WHY WE ARE
NOT GETTING THE PROVIDERS THAT
WE NEED. THAT'S WHY WE ARE NOT
ABLE TO HIRE AND KEEP THE STAFF
THAT WE NEED, AND UNTIL WE AS A
STATE DECIDE THAT WE ARE GOING
TO TRULY ADDRESS THIS ISSUE,
THIS IS GOING TO CONTINUE TO BE
A PROBLEM, AND SO, YOU KNOW, I
THINK WE WERE REALLY ATTEMPTING
TO GET AT THAT, AND, YOU KNOW,
AND THERE'S CLEARLY A LOT MORE
WORK TO BE DONE, BUT I THINK,
YOU KNOW, WE KNOW THAT THESE
INVESTMENTS, WHEN WE MAKE THESE
INVESTMENTS, THAT IT WILL COME
BACK TO US IN TERMS OF SAVINGS
TO PREVENT THE KIND OF LONG TERM
AND CHRONIC HEALTH ISSUES THAT,
ASSEMBLY MEMBER JONES-SAWYER IS
DISCUSSING AND HIS EXPERIENCED
HIMSELF, SO, YOU KNOW, AGREE
THAT THAT NEEDS TO BE KIND OF
CALCULATED IN. BUT I THINK WE
ALSO REALLY HAVE TO GET SERIOUS
ABOUT LONG TERM THINKING OF
MEDI-CAL RATES, AND, AND
MEDI-CAL REIMBURSEMENT LEVELS
BECAUSE IT'S NOT SUSTAINABLE AS
IT IS RIGHT NOW. AND, YOU KNOW,
AND I THINK THAT'S WHY THERE'S
LOTS OF KIND OF GRASPING FOR
SOLUTIONS BECAUSE WE HAVE TO
FIGURE IT OUT. AND, AND WE HAVE
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE ABLE TO
REIMBURSE THE COST OF CARE.
SIMPLY REIMBURSE THE COST OF
CARE WOULD JUST BE A NICE START
STARTING POINT, SO, YOU KNOW, I
THINK THAT'S WHERE WE'D ALL LIKE
TO GET TO. AND AND, AND LOOK
FORWARD TO BEING ABLE TO WORK
TOGETHER TO GET THERE. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU, SENATOR
MENGIBAR. I JUST HAVE A
TECHNICAL QUESTION, EITHER ONE
OF YOU. SO THE CURRENT MCO TAX
EXPIRES IN 2026, AND PROP 35
WOULD START IN 2027. IF THE PROP
STARTS IN 2027, WHY CAN'T WE
MAINTAIN THE MCO UP IN THE
CURRENT MCO AS IS UNTIL THIS
KICKS THE MCO? THE PROPOSITION
35 BEGINS IN 2025. I THINK WHAT
YOU'RE LOOKING AT IS ON PAGE
TWO. YOU'RE LOOKING ON PAGE TWO.
YES. AS PROP 35 MAKES IT MAKES
EXISTING HEALTH PLAN TAX
PERMANENT BEGINNING IN 2027.
YEAH. WELL I THINK IT'S A
DIFFERENT PAGE ON MY HANDOUT.
BUT YEAH. SO THE WHAT WE'RE
SAYING THERE IS THAT THE IT
DOESN'T, YOU KNOW, CHANGE THE
STRUCTURE OF THE CURRENT TAX.
BUT IT DOES IMPOSE NEW RULES ON
HOW THE EXISTING MCO TAX WOULD,
WOULD BE SPENT FROM THE GET GO.
YEAH. FROM, FROM STARTING IN
2025 OKAY. SO NEW RULES START IN
2025. BUT THE NEW STRUCTURE
STARTS IN 2027. SO UNDER CURRENT
LAW THE EXISTING MCO TAX ENDS AT
THE END OF 2026. AND SO WITHOUT
THE MEASURE UNDER CURRENT LAW,
THERE WOULD BE NO MCO TAX
BEGINNING IN 2027 UNLESS IF IT'S
EXTENDED. RIGHT. SO UNDER THE
MEASURE IT WOULD BECOME
PERMANENT. SO THERE WOULD BE A
THERE WOULD BE UNDER STATE LAW,
A PERMANENT MCO TAX IN 2027.
OKAY, OKAY. THANK YOU. I'M JUST
CURIOUS UNDER THIS PROP 35 AND
PAY ON PAGE FOUR OF AT LEAST MY
VERSION OF THE LÀ REPORT. IT
LISTS SERVICES THAT ARE GOING TO
RECEIVE FUNDING INCREASES,
STARTING WITH DOCTORS AND
RELATED PROVIDERS AND GOING DOWN
THE LIST IN THE FUTURE, IF THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT APPROVES AN
MCO TAX BUT AT A LOWER TAX
LEVEL, OR TAX RATE, WHAT HAPPENS
TO THE LIST? IS THE IS THE
FUNDING REDUCED PRO RATA? IS
THERE AN OPPORTUNITY UNDER THE
INITIATIVE TO REVISIT WHAT WAS
FUNDED AND NOT FUNDED, MAKE
ADJUSTMENTS OR SOMEWHERE IN
BETWEEN? YEAH. NOW I WANT TO
EMPHASIZE THAT, THE TABLE YOU'RE
LOOKING AT ON PAGE FOUR IS, IN
THE SHORT TERM. SO 2025 AND
2026, IN THE LONG TERM, IT'S A
LOT OF THE, A LOT OF THE SAME
SERVICES. THERE ARE SOME
ADDITIONAL SERVICES THAT COULD
QUALIFY, AND GENERALLY THAT, YOU
KNOW, IN THE LONG TERM, THE, THE,
THE RULES ARE A LITTLE
COMPLICATED, BUT MUCH OF THE
FUNDING IS WOULD BE ALLOCATED ON
A, ON A PROPORTIONAL BASIS. AND
SO IF THE TAX WERE LARGER AND
SMALL, DEPENDING ON THE SIZE OF
THE TAX, THOSE COULD BE PRORATED
UP OR DOWNWARD. IF THE TAX
REACHES A CERTAIN THRESHOLD
ABOVE, JUST OVER 4 BILLION, THEN
THERE ARE ADDITIONAL, PROGRAMS
THAT ALSO COULD SERVICES THAT
ALSO COULD RECEIVE FUNDING TOO.
SO IT JUST DEPENDS. IT IS A
COMPLICATED FORMULA. IT DEPENDS
ON ON HOW MUCH FUNDING IS
RAISED. BUT, DEPENDING ON HOW
MUCH FUNDING IS RAISED, IT DOES
DETERMINE HOW MUCH FUNDING GOES
TO EACH OF THE SERVICES. AND I
WAS MORE CONCERNED NOT ABOUT
GETTING MORE, BUT ABOUT GETTING
LESS. SO IF THERE'S IF YOU IF
YOU HAVE A 50% REDUCTION TO THE
AMOUNT OF MONEY GENERATED BY THE
MCO TAX BASED ON THE FEDERAL
APPROVAL, IS THERE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO READJUST WHAT
GETS FUNDED AND AT WHAT LEVEL?
OR IS IT SIMPLY APPLIED ON A
PRORATED BASIS? EVERYBODY GETS A
50% HAIRCUT, THE MEASURE, THE
MEASURE IN THE LONG RUN DOES
HAVE A FORMULA IN PLACE FOR
ALLOCATING MONEY. SO THAT WOULD
THAT WOULD SORT OF BE THE
OPERATIVE, YOU KNOW, PART OF THE
MEASURE THERE IS A THERE IS A
PART OF THE MEASURE THAT DOES
ALLOW THE LEGISLATURE TO MAKE
AMENDMENTS WITH A THREE FOURTHS
VOTE IN EACH HOUSE. IT WOULD
HAVE TO FURTHER THE PURPOSES AND
THE INTENT OF THE MEASURE. BUT
GENERALLY SPEAKING, THERE ARE
THERE IN THE LONG RUN. THERE ARE,
THERE IS SORT OF A FORMULA IN
PLACE TO DETERMINE HOW TO
ALLOCATE FUNDING. SO LIMITED
ADJUSTMENT AUTHORITY ON THE PART
OF ON OUR PART AS A LEGISLATURE.
CORRECT. WHICH IS SOMEWHAT
CONCERNING GIVEN THE FACT THAT
IF, IF FOR EXAMPLE, I'M NOT, I
PROBABLY NEVER WOULD HAPPEN. BUT
WHO KNOWS IF THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT APPROVED A
DRAMATICALLY REDUCED MCO TAX?
LOOKING AT THIS LIST OF
SERVICES, A LEGISLATURE MIGHT
PREFER TO FUND, YOU KNOW, FIVE
OF TEN ITEMS AS OPPOSED TO SEVEN
AT A REDUCED RATE. IN OTHER
WORDS, TRIAGING WHAT WE DO BASED
ON THE ABSOLUTE NEED IN THE
POPULATION RIGHT? AM I MAKING
SENSE? YEAH I UNDERSTAND THE
QUESTION. I MEAN, WE WENT
THROUGH THIS WHOLE THING IN THE
BUDGET PROCESS AND THAT WAS
TRIAGING AT ITS BEST RIGHT? WE
GOT TO DETERMINE AND SAY WHAT WE
PREFERRED TO BE FUNDED. THE
ADMINISTRATION. ADMINISTRATION
HAD ITS VIEW. AND THEN WE PUT
THE TWO TOGETHER AND IT WORKED
OUT, SORT OF DIFFICULT TO HAVE
AN INITIATIVE THAT TELLS US WHAT
TO DO WHEN WE DON'T KNOW WHAT
THE FUTURE CIRCUMSTANCES ARE
GOING TO BE. RIGHT I THINK YOU
RAISE A KEY, A KEY ISSUE THAT
YOU COULD EXPLORE FURTHER IN THE
SUBSEQUENT PANELS. YEAH, I
DIDN'T MEAN FOR YOU TO, BUT I
APPRECIATE YOUR INFORMATION,
COLLEAGUES. ANY OTHER QUESTIONS?
DOCTOR WEBER? THANK YOU. SO
ALONG, THE LINE OF WHAT SENATOR
ROTH WAS REFERRING TO WHEN YOU
ACTUALLY READ THE INITIATIVE AND
THEY, YOU KNOW, BREAK DOWN, YOU
KNOW, IN EACH CALENDAR YEAR,
LIKE 22% INTO THE PRIMARY CARE
ACCOUNT, 22% INTO SPECIALTY
CARE, TWO AND ONE HALF PERCENT
INTO THE EMERGENCY DEPARTMENT.
SO WHEN THEY GO WHEN THEY LIST
THAT, IS THAT HOW THE FUNDS WILL
BE DISTRIBUTED? YOU KNOW,
REGARDLESS OF HOW MUCH IS
ULTIMATELY GIVEN OR IS. YEAH,
YOU'RE LOOKING AT THE LANGUAGE
THAT DETERMINES HOW FUNDING IS
ALLOCATED IN THE MEASURE. YEAH.
OKAY. THANK YOU. OKAY. ANYTHING
ELSE? IF NOT, I WANT TO THANK
YOU ALL FOR STAYING AROUND AND
GIVING US SOME VALUABLE
INFORMATION AND ANSWERING OUR
RESPONDING TO OUR QUESTIONS.
LET'S NOW BRING UP THE SECOND
PANEL. AND THIS IS THE PANEL OF
SUPPORTERS OF PROPOSITION 35.
THERE ARE A LOT OF YOU, BUT
THAT'S GOOD. BUT JUST TO REMIND
YOU, THIS SUPPORT PANEL WILL
HAVE A TOTAL OF 20 MINUTES. AND
THE OPPOSITION AND OTHER
STAKEHOLDER GROUPS THAT FOLLOW
YOU WILL ALSO HAVE A TOTAL OF 20
MINUTES. WE'LL TRY TO KEEP TRACK
OF THE TIME, BUT I WOULD ASK
THAT YOU DO SO AS WELL SO WE CAN
MOVE FORWARD WITH THIS AGENDA.
AND AFTER YOU ALL HAVE TAKEN
YOUR SEATS, LET'S HAVE YOU,
LET'S JUST START OUT WITH
INTRODUCTIONS TO MY LEFT. YOUR
RIGHT. THAT'S YOU, SIR, AND A
NICE TIE AND WE'LL MOVE DOWN THE
LINE. UP. SO YOU'RE ON. GOOD
AFTERNOON, MR. CHAIR. MY NAME IS
DONALDO HERNANDEZ. I'M A
PHYSICIAN FROM SANTA CRUZ,
CALIFORNIA. JOINING US. EX CEO
AND PRESIDENT OF AFFILIATES OF
CALIFORNIA. GOOD TO HAVE YOU,
MISS NEXT, GOOD AFTERNOON, AARON
KELLY WITH THE CHILDREN'S
SPECIALTY CARE COALITION. I'M
THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR. THANK
YOU SIR. Ó NOT ON. OH, YEAH. HI
RAKESH PATEL, THE CEO OF
NEIGHBORHOOD HEALTHCARE. THANK
YOU. WE'RE JUST BUILDING A
RECORD HERE, SO FOLKS ARE
WATCHING. THEY WANT TO KNOW WHO
YOU ARE. THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON. CHAIR. MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE, PAUL LAWRENCE, CHIEF
EXECUTIVE OFFICER FOR SANTA
CLARA VALLEY HEALTHCARE. GOOD TO
HAVE YOU, SIR. MA'AM. YES,
JENNIFER KENT AND I'M AN ADVISOR
TO THE COALITION. AND HERE FOR
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS. OKAY.
PERFECT WHO WANTS TO START? I
WILL, MR. CHAIR, THANK YOU. AND
AGAIN, THANK YOU FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY. CALIFORNIA HAS MADE
SIGNIFICANT IMPROVEMENTS IN OUR
HEALTH CARE SYSTEM IN RECENT
YEARS. THE STATE HAS
DRAMATICALLY INCREASED THE
NUMBER OF AND INCREASED THE
NUMBER OF PEOPLE ELIGIBLE FOR
HEALTH CARE AND THE SERVICES
COVERED BY MEDI-CAL. AND I WANT
TO THANK YOU. THE LEGISLATURE
AND GOVERNOR NEWSOM, FOR THAT
NATION LEADING WORK. AND YET,
THIS HAS HAPPENED WITHOUT AN
INVESTMENT IN OUR MEDI-CAL
SYSTEM THAT WOULD HELP MAKE
THOSE ASPIRATIONS A REALITY.
BECAUSE OF THE UNDERINVESTMENT
WE HAVE SEEN AND WILL CONTINUE
TO SEE CROWDED EMERGENCY ROOMS,
HOSPITALS CLOSING THEIR DOORS TO
KEY SERVICES LIKE LABOR AND
DELIVERY, AND PATIENTS WAITING
FOR MONTHS TO SEE A DOCTOR. AND
THAT'S WHAT PROPOSITION 35 AIMS
TO FIX. PROP 35 SECURES
RESOURCES NEEDED TO ASSURE
ACCESS TO PROVIDE CARE TO ALL
CALIFORNIA PATIENTS. THERE ARE
ALMOST 15 MILLION CALIFORNIANS
COVERED BY MEDI-CAL, INCLUDING
ONE HALF OF THE CHILDREN BORN IN
THE STATE. THESE ARE OFTEN LOW
INCOME FAMILIES, THE ELDERLY ON
MARGINAL OR LIMITED INCOMES AND
FIXED INCOMES, AND IMMIGRANTS.
THESE ARE THE PATIENTS I TAKE
CARE OF EVERY DAY. AGAIN, I AM
DOCTOR DONALD HERNANDEZ. I'M AN
INTERNIST BASED IN SANTA CRUZ
COUNTY, AND THE IMMEDIATE PAST
PRESIDENT OF THE CALIFORNIA
MEDICAL ASSOCIATION. MANY OF MY
PATIENTS ARE ON MEDI-CAL.
THEY'RE POOR. THEY SUFFER FROM
SUBSTANCE USE DISORDERS. THEY
ARE THE ESSENTIAL AGRICULTURAL
WORKERS THAT FED US DURING THE
PANDEMIC. MANY ARE INDIGENOUS
PEOPLE WHO SPEAK ENGLISH. AS A
SECOND LANGUAGE. LIKE MY FATHER.
THEY ARE OUR NEIGHBORS. THEY'RE
OUR FRIENDS. THEY'RE OUR PARENTS.
AND THE SAD REALITY IS TOO MANY
DOCTORS AND HOSPITALS ARE UNABLE
TO ACCEPT AND COVER THESE
MEDI-CAL COVERED PATIENTS, AND
WE DON'T CHECK THEIR INSURANCE
WHEN THEY COME THROUGH THE FRONT
DOOR. BUT THE REALITY IS, THIS
IS THE WAY THE SYSTEM WORKS. AND
FOR ME, THE OVERRIDING PRINCIPLE
IS SIMPLE ACCESS EQUALS EQUITY,
AND EQUITY EQUALS ACCESS. THAT
MUST BE THE FOUNDATIONAL COMPASS
THAT GUIDES US FORWARD. WE MUST
HAVE HONEST REFORM SO THAT WE
CAN EXPAND AND PROTECT ACCESS TO
HEALTH CARE FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS. PROPOSITION 35
WOULD ACHIEVE THAT GOAL AND MAKE
MEANINGFUL CHANGE IN OUR HEALTH
CARE SYSTEM BY PROVIDING
DEDICATED RESOURCES TO IMPROVING
PATIENT CARE, REDUCING EMERGENCY
ROOM WAIT TIMES FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS, MAKING
PRESCRIPTION DRUGS MORE
AFFORDABLE, AND GROWING OUR
PHYSICIAN AND NON-PHYSICIAN
WORKFORCE. PROP 35 REPRESENTS
THE MOST IMPORTANT INVESTMENT IN
CALIFORNIA HEALTH CARE AND OUR
STATE'S HISTORY, AND WILL
INCREASE THE ACCESS TO CARE WELL
INTO THE FUTURE. OUR SYSTEM IS
COMPLICATED ENOUGH. PROP 13 WILL
MAKE IT EASIER FOR CALIFORNIANS
SEEKING HELP AND SUPPORT DOCTORS
LIKE ME WHO WANT TO PROVIDE
EQUITABLE CARE FOR OUR
COMMUNITIES. I WANT TO THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME, AND I WANT TO
TAKE ONE MORE MINUTE AND THANK
YOU, ASSEMBLY MEMBER, FOR YOUR
BECOMING EMPOWERED TO TAKE OVER
YOUR CARE WITH RESPECT TO YOUR
DIABETES. IT'S A VERY INSPIRING
STORY AND THANK YOU FOR SHARING
THAT. THANK YOU, THANK YOU
DOCTOR. THAT'S THREE MINUTES.
WE'RE RIGHT ON TRACK, MISS HICKS.
GREAT. THANK YOU, THANK YOU FOR
HAVING ME. AND AS I STATED, I'M
JODY HICKS. I'M PRESIDENT AND
CEO OF PLANNED PARENTHOOD
AFFILIATES OF CALIFORNIA,
REPRESENTING SEVEN AFFILIATES
THAT RUN OVER 100 HEALTH CARE
CENTERS THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA.
BUT I'M ALSO THE CO-CHAIR OF
THIS COALITION, AND I JUST WANT
TO TALK A LITTLE BIT ABOUT THAT
EFFORT, WHICH IS GETTING THIS
GROUP OF FOLKS TOGETHER THAT
NORMALLY DON'T ALWAYS GET ALONG.
WE NORMALLY KIND OF FIGHT WITH
EACH OTHER, AND WE NORMALLY DO
BUSINESS HOW WE ALL DO IT, HOW
YOU'RE ALL USED TO US DOING IT,
WHICH IS EVERYBODY ADVOCATING
FOR OUR OWN ORGANIZATION AND
WHAT WE WANT. AND THE THINGS
THAT WE WANT AND NEED AND WHAT
WE DID IS GET TOGETHER AND
REALLY HAVE A CONVERSATION THAT
TOOK OVER A YEAR AND IT WAS
QUITE HAD A LOT OF TENSIONS, TO,
TO PUT IT NICELY ON, ON HAVING A
CONVERSATION OF WHAT IT WOULD
LOOK LIKE IF WE ACTUALLY MADE
THIS HISTORIC INVESTMENT AND,
AND REALLY HAVE A
TRANSFORMATIONAL OPPORTUNITY FOR
PATIENTS ON MEDI-CAL. AND WHAT
THAT MEANT IS WE ALL HAD TO PUT
THE PATIENT AS A NORTH STAR AND
REALLY LOOK AT IF WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT THE SAFETY NET, WHAT WAS
NEEDED, WHAT COULD BE AN
INVESTMENT. AND THAT'S REALLY
WHAT WE DID AND HOW WE CAME TO
WHAT THIS INITIATIVE IS TODAY,
WE ALSO CAME TOGETHER VERY
QUICKLY AND IT WAS VERY CLOSE TO
THE PANDEMIC ENDING. AND THAT
WAS REALLY FRESH IN ALL OF OUR
MINDS, IS CERTAINLY WAS FOR ME,
WHICH IS A TIME WHEN WE REALLY
ALL WITNESSED HOW CERTAIN
COMMUNITIES WERE
DISPROPORTIONATELY AFFECTED
THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. AND WE SAW THOSE
INEQUITIES. AND I THINK IT'S
IMPOSSIBLE TO STEP AWAY FROM THE
FACT THAT IF WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
EQUITY IN A HEALTH CARE DELIVERY
SYSTEM, WE HAVE TO ADMIT THAT IF
YOU HAVE AN ECONOMIC INCENTIVE
TO TAKE A CERTAIN TYPE OF
PATIENT OVER ANOTHER, THEN WE
ARE CREATING INEQUITIES THAT WE
WITNESSED DURING THE PANDEMIC.
WE SAW THE DATA AND THOSE
INVESTMENTS AND WHAT WE DECIDE
TO DO AFTER THE AFTER THE FACT
IS REALLY WHAT HOW WE SPEAK TO
OUR VALUES AND OUR PRIORITIES IN
CALIFORNIA TO HEALTH CARE. IT
WAS IMPORTANT AS A COALITION,
AND THAT'S WHAT WE'RE ASKING
VOTERS TO LOOK AT IN THIS
INITIATIVE. THE OTHER THING I
JUST WANT TO SAY IS TALK A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT WHAT THIS
INITIATIVE DOES AND WHAT IT
DOESN'T DO. NOW FOR PLANNED
PARENTHOOD, I WANT TO SAY THANK
YOU, WE WERE INCLUDED AND
INVESTED IN THIS BUDGET. WE HAVE
CONTINUED TO BE AND I APPRECIATE
EVERYONE UP HERE FOR FAITH AND
INVESTMENTS THAT HAVE HAPPENED
FOR PLANNED PARENTHOOD. AND WE
HAD WITH MY BOARD A VERY ROBUST
CONVERSATION ABOUT WHAT THAT
MEANT FOR THIS INITIATIVE, THIS
BIG INVESTMENT THAT WE'RE TRYING
TO DO. AND MY FOLKS, THOSE SEVEN
CEOS THAT ARE OPERATING HEALTH
CENTERS IN THE MOST VULNERABLE
TO THE MOST VULNERABLE PATIENTS
IN COMMUNITIES THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA WERE VERY CLEAR THAT
WHILE WE KNOW THAT AT PLANNED
PARENTHOOD, WE PROVIDE
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH CARE, MANY
OF OUR HEALTH CENTERS ALSO
PROVIDE PRIMARY CARE. WE'VE BEEN
ABLE TO DO THINGS LIKE PRENATAL
CARE AND HAVE A WARM HANDOFF. WE
ALSO NEED THE ENTIRETY OF THE
HEALTH CARE DELIVERY SYSTEM TO
WORK. SO AS WE PROVIDE MORE
MAMMOGRAMS, WE NEED TO BE ABLE
TO SEND WHEN WE FIND SOMETHING
WRONG, SEND THOSE PATIENTS TO
SOMEONE WHO CAN FURTHER THAT
CARE, THE ENTIRETY OF THE HEALTH
CARE DELIVERY SYSTEM HAS TO WORK
IN ORDER TO TREAT THE WHOLE
PATIENT AND IN ORDER FOR ALL OF
US TO BE ABLE TO DO THE JOBS
THAT EVERYBODY UP HERE, ALL THE
PROVIDERS AND REPRESENTING
PROVIDER GROUPS ARE UP HERE
INTENDED TO DO. IT'S REALLY,
FULFILL THE PROMISE THAT YOU ALL
HAVE MADE WHEN YOU'VE EXPANDED
ELIGIBILITY AND GIVEN PEOPLE,
ACCESS TO A MEDI-CAL CARD THAT
THEY ACTUALLY HAVE ACCESS TO,
SEE PROVIDERS ALL THE WAY
THROUGH, NOT JUST IN ONE ASPECT,
BUT FOR EVERY PART OF THEIR
HEALTH CARE NEEDS. AND THAT THAT
WAS VERY, VERY IMPORTANT TO OUR
FOLKS. BUT THEN I ALSO SAY, JUST
FOR PLANNED PARENTHOOD, HAVING
PREDICTABLE AND SUSTAINABLE
FUNDING YEAR AFTER YEAR. SO NOT
JUST IN THIS BUDGET, BUT IN THE
BUDGET AFTER AND THE YEAR AFTER,
HAVING THAT PREDICTABLE AND
SUSTAINABLE FUNDING IS
TRANSFORMATIONAL. AND JUST
SPEAKING FOR US IN A CLIMATE
THAT IS CERTAINLY UNPREDICTABLE
RIGHT NOW, IT COULDN'T BE MORE
UNPREDICTABLE THAN WHAT WE ARE
LIVING THROUGH RIGHT NOW. AND I
THINK ABOUT THAT WITH PATIENTS.
WE HAD A PATIENT THAT CAME TO US
AFTER HAVING VISITED FOUR
STATES, FOUR STATES, TRYING TO
GET CARE. THEY STARTED IN ONE
STATE. THE LAW CHANGED LITERALLY
WENT TO ANOTHER STATE. THE LAW
CHANGED THE DAY THAT THEY GOT
THERE. BY THE TIME THEY COULD
GET AN APPOINTMENT IN ANOTHER
STATE, THEY WERE PAST 15 WEEKS.
BY THE TIME THEY GOT TO
CALIFORNIA, WE WERE THE STATE
THAT COULD PROVIDE THEM CARE.
AND THE REASON THAT WE WERE ABLE
TO DO THAT IS BECAUSE WE HAVE
INVESTMENTS SUCH THAT WE CAN
STAY OPEN NOW ON A SATURDAY WHEN
SOMEBODY IS ABLE TO TRAVEL, THAT
WE CAN STAY OPEN A COUPLE HOURS
LONGER DURING THE EVENING, THAT
WE CAN DO INNOVATIVE THINGS IN
COMMUNITIES, LIKE HAVE SCHOOL
BASED HEALTH CENTERS WHERE
PEOPLE IN VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES
ARE YOUTH ARE ABLE TO GO RIGHT
AT THEIR SCHOOL AND GET CARE.
ALL OF THOSE THINGS CHANGE
PEOPLE'S LIVES AND CHANGE THE
TRAJECTORY AND THE OUTCOME OF
WHAT THEY CAN EXPERIENCE AND WHO
THEY CAN BECOME. THAT PERSON
GETTING CARE IN CALIFORNIA. AND
WE SHOULD ALL APPLAUD THAT. BUT
THAT CHANGED THE OUTCOME OF HER
VERY FUTURE. AND THAT'S BECAUSE
WE PRIORITIZED AND INVESTED WHAT
THIS INITIATIVE DOESN'T DO IS IT
DOESN'T FIX EVERYTHING. IT
REALLY CANNOT. WHAT WE TRIED TO
DO IS ALSO LEAVE AN AMOUNT OF
FLEXIBLE FUNDING IN FOR THE
GENERAL FUND FOR YOU AS
LEGISLATORS TO ALSO, THERE'S $2
BILLION A YEAR FOR THE FIRST
COUPLE OF YEARS. THEN IT MOVES
TO 700 MILLION PLUS. THAT CAN
PLUS UP DEPENDING ON, THE MCO
TAX AND HOW MUCH IT EXPANDS. BUT
THAT WAS INTENDED FOR SOME OTHER
THINGS THAT WE KNOW ARE ALSO
IMPORTANT. NOTHING IN THE
INITIATIVE SAYS YOU CANNOT FUND
OTHER THINGS THAT WE ALL AGREE
ARE IMPORTANT THAT WE WILL
COMMIT TO. ALSO ADVOCATING FOR,
AND THOSE CAN BE DONE IN THE
NEXT BUDGET YEAR AND THE BUDGET
YEAR AFTER THAT, AND I'LL CLOSE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH,
MA'AM. WE ARE NOW AT THE TEN
MINUTE MARK. SO WE HAVE THREE OF
YOU LEFT. DO YOUR BEST. THANK
YOU MA'AM. ALL RIGHT. SO ERIN
KELLY, EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
CHILDREN'S SPECIALTY CARE
COALITION, WHICH IS A NONPROFIT
ADVOCACY ASSOCIATION THAT
REPRESENTS 19 PEDIATRIC
SPECIALTY MEDICAL GROUPS THAT
ARE CLOSELY ALIGNED WITH
CHILDREN'S HOSPITALS IN THE
STATE. KSK'S MISSION IS TO
ENSURE THAT CHILDREN AND YOUTH
WITH COMPLEX HEALTH CARE NEEDS
HAVE TIMELY ACCESS TO EQUITABLE
HEALTH CARE, PEDIATRIC
SUBSPECIALISTS ARE A CRITICAL
SAFETY NET PROVIDERS WHO SEE
UPWARDS OF 75% OF MEDI-CAL
VOLUME. THE DEMAND FOR COMPLEX
CARE IS ON THE RISE. GIVEN THE
TREMENDOUS ADVANCES IN PEDIATRIC
CARE THAT HAVE RESULTED IN AN
INCREASED NUMBER OF CHILDREN
LIVING LONGER. HOWEVER, ACCESS
TO CARE HAS BEEN RAPIDLY,
RAPIDLY DETERIORATING IN THIS
STATE, WITH ONE THIRD OF
CHILDREN WITH SPECIAL HEALTH
CARE NEEDS IN CALIFORNIA WAITING
OVER THREE MONTHS FOR A NEW
SPECIALTY CARE APPOINTMENT. AND
FOR CERTAIN SPECIALTIES,
FAMILIES ARE WAITING OVER A
YEAR. AS YOU KNOW, MEDI-CAL
SERVES NEARLY 50% OF THE
CHILDREN AND 50% OF ALL THE LIVE
BIRTHS IN THE STATE. HOWEVER,
REIMBURSEMENT FOR PEDIATRIC
SERVICES IS NOTABLY LESS THAN
MEDICARE, AND FEE FOR SERVICE
RATES HAVE LARGELY REMAINED
STAGNANT FOR NEARLY 20 YEARS.
THE EFFECT OF THIS SUSTAINED LOW
REIMBURSEMENT IS JEOPARDIZING
ACCESS AND CREATING INEQUITABLE
CARE FOR THE CHILDREN IN OUR
STATE. AT THE SAME TIME, THERE
ARE EQUALLY CONCERNING TRENDS AS
IT RELATES TO THE PIPELINE
ENTERING THIS WORKFORCE WITH A
SIGNIFICANT DECLINE IN MEDICAL
STUDENTS CHOOSING PEDIATRICS
YEAR TO YEAR AND EVEN GREATER
DECLINES WITH THE NUMBER OF
MEDICAL STUDENTS PURSUING
PEDIATRIC SPECIALIZATION, A
GROWING NUMBER OF PEDIATRIC
SUBSPECIALTIES HAVE LESS THAN
50% FILL RATES FOR FELLOWSHIPS.
NATIONALLY, THE ECONOMICS OF
BEING A PEDIATRICIAN, LET ALONE
OF BEING A PEDIATRIC
SUBSPECIALIST WHO UNDERGO 3 TO 5
YEARS MORE YEARS OF TRAINING,
SIMPLY DON'T ADD UP ANYMORE, AND
IN 2023, A STUDY WAS
COMMISSIONED BY THE NATIONAL
ACADEMIES OF SCIENCES,
ENGINEERING AND MEDICINE ON THE
PEDIATRIC SPECIALTY CARE
WORKFORCE, WHICH CULMINATED IN A
COMPREHENSIVE REPORT. ONE OF THE
KEY RECOMMENDATIONS WAS TO BRING
MEDICAID RATES AT OR ABOVE
MEDICARE RATES ACROSS ALL
PEDIATRIC CODES, AND THE REPORT
ALSO UNDERSCORED THE NEED FOR
CRITICAL INVESTMENTS IN GRADUATE
GRADUATE MEDICAL EDUCATION AND
LOAN REPAYMENT PROGRAMS TO
INCENTIVIZE MEDICAL STUDENTS TO
PURSUE PEDIATRICS AND PEDIATRIC
SPECIALIZATION. PROP 35
REPRESENTS A HISTORIC
OPPORTUNITY TO BRING STABILITY
TO THIS AILING NETWORK THAT
SERVES THE STATE'S MOST
MEDICALLY FRAGILE POPULATION. WE
FEAR THAT WITHOUT THE PASSAGE OF
PROP 35, MEDI-CAL PROVIDER RATES
WILL REMAIN VULNERABLE TO CUTS
EACH YEAR, AND MEDICAL GROUPS
WILL NOT HAVE THE CERTAINTY AND
THE PREDICTABILITY TO MAKE
MEANINGFUL AND SUSTAINABLE
INVESTMENTS NEEDED TO IMPROVE
ACCESS WITHIN THE MEDI-CAL
PROGRAM FOR CHILDREN IN NEED OF
SPECIALTY CARE. ADDITIONALLY,
PROP 35 PROVIDES NEEDED
INVESTMENTS TO ADDRESS THE
WORKFORCE PIPELINE WITH
DEDICATED FUNDING FOR GRADUATE
MEDICAL EDUCATION AND LOAN
REPAYMENT. I WANT TO CLOSE WITH
A COUPLE OF FINAL POINTS. ONE IS
TO DRAW A DISTINCTION THAT THE
230 MILLION IN TOTAL FUNDS
ALLOCATED IN THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET FOR THE NOT FOR PROFIT,
STANDALONE CHILDREN'S HOSPITALS
WILL PROVIDE MUCH NEEDED
INVESTMENTS FOR THE FACILITY
SIDE OF THOSE HOSPITALS, BUT
THOSE FUNDS WILL NOT PROVIDE
SUPPORT TO THE PHYSICIAN NETWORK
THAT SERVES THESE CRITICALLY ILL
CHILDREN AND IS EXPERIENCING ITS
OWN ACUTE CRISIS. SECONDLY, I
WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE UP FRONT
THAT CCSC AND OTHER MEMBERS OF
PROP 35 HAVE BEEN SUPPORTIVE OF
THE 0 TO 5 CONTINUOUS COVERAGE,
AND WE'VE BEEN URGING THE
DEPARTMENT TO SEEK FEDERAL
APPROVAL. CHILDREN NEED
CONTINUOUS COVERAGE, BUT THEY
ALSO NEED THE STABILITY AND
PREDICTABILITY OF MEANINGFUL
ACCESS TO HEALTH CARE SERVICES.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK TODAY. THANK YOU. WE'RE AT
ABOUT 14 MINUTES, SO WE'VE GOT
ABOUT SIX LEFT. TRY TO DO YOUR
BEST, BUT I APPRECIATE YOU BEING
HERE AND LOOK FORWARD TO THE
TESTIMONY. PLEASE PROCEED. THANK
YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRS AND
MEMBERS. MY NAME IS DOCTOR
RAKESH PATEL. I'M A PRACTICING
FAMILY PHYSICIAN AND CEO OF
NEIGHBORHOOD HEALTHCARE, A
COMMUNITY HEALTH CENTER THAT
SERVES 100,000 PATIENTS IN SAN
DIEGO AND RIVERSIDE COUNTY. WE
ALSO ARE A PACE ORGANIZATION AS
WELL. I'VE BEEN IN THIS SPACE
FOR OVER 22 YEARS. I DID MY
RESIDENCY AT TRAINING AT A
COMMUNITY HEALTH CENTER AND
MOONLIT AT THE HEALTH CENTER
THAT I AM AT, AND I'VE BEEN
THERE EVER SINCE. SO THIS THIS
SPACE IS NEAR AND DEAR TO MY
HEART. COMMUNITY HEALTH CENTERS
PROVIDE CARE TO 1 IN 3 MEDI-CAL
BENEFICIARIES, 1 IN 5
CALIFORNIANS, 88% OF OUR
PATIENTS ARE COVERED BY PUBLICLY
HEALTH FUNDED CARE, AND THE REST
ARE UNINSURED. THE MOST
IMPORTANT PART IS WE NEVER TURN
A PATIENT AWAY. SINCE 2015,
HEALTH CENTERS HAVE EXPERIENCED
A 27% DECLINE IN PER PATIENT
SPENDING. AND JUST THIS YEAR,
WITH EXPANSION OF HEALTH FOR
ALL, WHICH WAS A, YOU KNOW, AN
AMAZING PROGRAM, WE SAW MASSIVE
INCREASES IN THE NUMBER OF
PATIENTS WE SERVE. ALL OF THESE
THINGS COMBINED HAVE LED TO A
HEALTH CARE CRISIS WITHIN OUR
HEALTH CENTERS. OUR ABILITY TO
TIMELY SERVE OUR PATIENTS IS
BEING STRETCHED TO THE BREAKING
POINT, AND WE INCREASINGLY RUN
INTO ISSUES CONNECTING OUR
PATIENTS WITH THE SPECIALTY,
SPECIALTY CARE THEY SO
DESPERATELY NEED. RECENTLY, I
EXPERIENCED A HEALTH ISSUE
MYSELF. ONE MORNING, I WOKE UP
AFTER MOVING SOME BOXES WITH
SOME SEVERE BACK PAIN AND I
REALIZED I'M NOT. I CAN'T EVEN
STAND. I WAS KIND OF STUCK, YES,
DOCTORS DO GET SICK. IT WAS
TERRIBLE AND I KNEW IMMEDIATELY
THAT I NEEDED TO GET TAKEN CARE
OF, AND I WENT TO AN URGENT
CARE. FROM THERE. I WAS ABLE TO
SEE A SPECIALIST GET AN MRI, AND
WITHIN A FEW DAYS I KIND OF KNEW
WHAT WAS GOING ON AND HAD A
TREATMENT PLAN. AS I REFLECTED
ON MY JOURNEY AND THOUGHT ABOUT
WHAT WOULD HAPPEN WITH MY
PATIENTS, THE DISPARITIES WERE
QUITE PARAMOUNT FOR ME. FOR OUR
PATIENTS, JUST GETTING THAT
FIRST VISIT COULD HAVE BEEN 2 TO
4 WEEKS AT BEST. YOU KNOW, THEY
COULD HAVE TRIED TO WALK IN.
MANY HAVE NO ACCESS TO AN URGENT
CARE. MOST LIKELY THE PATIENT
WOULD HAVE GONE TO AN EMERGENCY
ROOM UNNECESSARILY. AND THEN THE
SPECIALTY CARE THAT WE KEEP
TALKING ABOUT, IT'S SO HARD TO
ACCESS THAT IT WOULD HAVE BEEN
MONTHS. JUST RECENTLY, WE WERE
TRYING TO REFER A YOUNG WOMAN
FOR GYNECOLOGICAL SERVICES AT A
SPECIALTY CENTER. THEY SAID THE
NEXT APPOINTMENT IS NEXT YEAR
AND WE CAN'T BOOK THAT DATE
RIGHT NOW, WHEN IT COMES TO
RADIOLOGY, IT WAS EASY FOR ME TO
GET AN MRI WITH MY COMMERCIAL
INSURANCE. GETTING AN MRI ON
MEDI-CAL RIGHT NOW IS EXTREMELY
DIFFICULT. WE ARE SEEING
PROVIDERS NO LONGER ACCEPTING
OUR PATIENTS BECAUSE OF THE
REIMBURSEMENT RATES. PART OF WHY
I CHOOSE TO WORK IN HEALTH
CENTERS IS TO TRY TO ADDRESS
THESE DISPARITIES. MY PATIENTS
SHOULD NOT HAVE TO SPEND MONTHS
IN PAIN WHILE THEY WAIT TO SEE
SPECIALISTS THAT THEY NEED, AND
THEY NEED TO GET THE TREATMENT
THEY DESERVE. THAT'S WHY I
STRONGLY SUPPORT PROPOSITION 35.
IT'S A CRUCIAL TOOL IN
ADDRESSING THESE ISSUES AND
SUSTAINING AND SUPPLEMENTING
EXISTING RESOURCES. THAT MEANS
THAT OUR PATIENTS WILL RECEIVE
TREATMENT SOONER, HAVE IMPROVED
ACCESS TO TREATMENTS, AND RESULT
IN BETTER OUTCOMES. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH, DOCTOR. NEXT PLEASE. SIR
CHAIR ROSS, MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE, IT'S A PRIVILEGE TO
BE HERE AGAIN. MY NAME IS PAUL
LORENZ. I'M THE CHIEF EXECUTIVE
OFFICER FOR SANTA CLARA VALLEY
HEALTHCARE. I DO WANT TO POINT
OUT THAT OUR COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS IN SANTA CLARA VOTED
TO SUPPORT THE INITIATIVE. SANTA
CLARA VALLEY HEALTHCARE IS THE
LARGEST PUBLIC HEALTH CARE
SYSTEM IN NORTHERN CALIFORNIA.
WE SERVE A DIVERSE POPULATION OF
1.9 MILLION RESIDENTS, AND THE
REGIONAL BAY AREA. WE DO SO
THROUGH A ROBUST NETWORK OF
PRIMARY CARE AND SPECIALTY
CLINICS TO OFFER BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH SERVICES AND OPERATE
THREE HOSPITALS. 86% OF OUR
PATIENT POPULATION IS ON A
GOVERNMENT SPONSORED PROGRAM.
58% OF OUR PATIENTS ARE ON
MEDI-CAL. THE LEGISLATURE IS
QUITE FAMILIAR WITH THE CURRENT
FINANCIAL STRUGGLES OF HOSPITALS
AROUND THE STATE, ESPECIALLY FOR
RURAL AND COMMUNITY HOSPITALS.
OVER THE PAST SEVERAL YEARS,
CALIFORNIA HAS EXPERIENCED AN
UNPRECEDENTED NUMBER OF
HOSPITALS CLOSING OR REDUCING
SERVICES OR LIMITING ACCESS TO
CARE. YOU MAY BE LESS FAMILIAR
WITH THE SPECIFIC FINANCIAL
STRUGGLES OF THE STATE'S PUBLIC
HEALTH CARE SYSTEMS, SUCH AS
SANTA CLARA VALLEY HEALTHCARE.
LAST FISCAL YEAR, THE COUNTY
FACED A $250 MILLION DEFICIT.
COLLECTIVELY, THE STATE'S 21
PUBLIC HOSPITAL SYSTEMS ARE
FACING A 3 TO $4 BILLION
STRUCTURAL DEFICIT. WE ARE
GRATEFUL FOR THE LEGISLATURE'S
RECENT EFFORTS TO SUPPORT
HOSPITALS FINANCIALLY, SUCH AS
VIA THE DISTRESSED HOSPITAL LOAN
PROGRAM, AND WE'RE ALSO GRATEFUL
TO THE STATE FOR SUPPORTING OUR
EFFORTS TO INCREASE OUR FEDERAL
FUNDING. HOWEVER UNFORTUNATELY,
THESE EFFORTS ARE SIMPLY NOT
SUFFICIENT GIVEN THE MAGNITUDE
OF THE PROBLEM WE FACE TOGETHER.
PROPOSITION 35 FUNDING WILL
PROVIDE A DEDICATED, ONGOING
STREAM OF MONEY TO STABILIZE
HOSPITAL FINANCING AND PROVIDE A
REIMBURSEMENT AND SUPPORT PUBLIC
HEALTH CARE SYSTEMS LIKE MINE
AND YOURS, WHICH CARE FOR THE
MOST VULNERABLE RESIDENTS IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. PUBLIC
HEALTH CARE SYSTEMS, INCLUDING
SANTA CLARA, ARE EXPERIENCED A
SIGNIFICANT, SIGNIFICANT GROWTH
IN DEMAND FOR SERVICES AND ARE
HIGHLY IMPACTED. WHILE THERE ARE
MANY FACTORS, IT IS PRIMARILY
DUE TO FEWER COMMUNITY HEALTH
CARE PROVIDERS WILLING TO ACCEPT
MEDI-CAL AS A PAYER. THIS IS NOT
ONLY LEADING TO FINANCIAL AND
OPERATIONAL DISTRESS FOR PUBLIC
SYSTEMS, AS WELL AS THOSE
PROVIDERS WILLING TO ENABLE TO
SERVE THE MEDI-CAL POPULATION.
BUT THERE ARE FURTHER PROBLEMS
AHEAD OF US. WE KNOW THAT THIS
IS CONTRIBUTING TO HEALTH CARE
INEQUITY AND DISPARITIES IN
HEALTH CARE. PROPOSITION 35 WILL
HELP MAINTAIN AND EXPAND ACCESS
TO CARE BEYOND THE HOSPITAL
WALLS, ENSURING THAT DOCTORS,
CLINICS, AND OTHER COMMUNITY
PROVIDERS CAN CONTINUE TO
PROVIDE VITAL OUTPATIENT CARE.
THE MEDI-CAL NETWORK OF CARE
MUST BE STABILIZED. IT'S NOT
JUST ABOUT PUBLIC HOSPITAL
SYSTEMS AND HEALTH CARE SYSTEM.
IT IS ABOUT HOSPITALS AND HEALTH
CARE PROVIDERS PROVIDING CARE TO
ALL OF OUR RESIDENTS IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. WE BELIEVE
THE INCREASE IN PROVIDER
PAYMENTS UNDER PROPOSITION 35
WILL GO A LONG WAY TOWARDS
ENSURING ACCESSIBLE HEALTH CARE
FOR ALL RESIDENTS. FOR ALL
CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. I HAVE TO
SAY THIS IN ADDITION TO SOME
EXCEPTIONAL TESTIMONY, YOU ALL
GET THE GOLD STAR FOR TIME 20
MINUTES. QUESTIONS, COLLEAGUES.
QUESTIONS, COMMENTS. SENATOR
MENGIBAR, YOU'RE UP FIRST. I
JUST WANT TO CLARIFY, BECAUSE IF
I WOULD HAVE JUST WALKED INTO
THIS INFORMATIONAL HEARING, I
WOULD ASSUME THAT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA IS NOT INVESTING IN
ANY KIND OF MEDI-CAL RATE
INCREASES. I WOULD ALSO ASSUME
THAT IF PROP 35 DIDN'T PASS, WE
WOULDN'T HAVE ANYTHING IN PLACE
TO PROVIDE THESE PROVIDER RATES.
BUT I JUST WANT TO MAKE IT CLEAR
WE DO. I MEAN, WE PASSED IN THE
BUDGET THE MCO TAX TO PROVIDE,
MEDI-CAL REIMBURSEMENT RATES TO
INCREASE FOR PROVIDERS AND SO
FORTH. I JUST WANT TO MAKE
CLEAR, BECAUSE IT JUST SOUNDS
LIKE WE'RE NOT DOING THAT, I
THINK IT'S VERY IMPORTANT THAT
WE CONTINUE TO DO THAT. IT'S
PHENOMENAL. AND YOU KNOW, IF
PROP 35 DIDN'T PASS THE FIGHT TO
ENSURE THAT THE MCO TAX STILL
GOES TO, PROVIDER RATES ALL
ACROSS AND SO FORTH. SO I JUST
WANTED TO MAKE THAT CLEAR. MY
ACTUAL QUESTION IS I'D LIKE TO
HEAR FROM SOMEONE, MAYBE JODIE,
YOU SPOKE ABOUT COALITION WHO
MADE UP THIS COALITION, WHO CAME
TO THE TABLE TO DETERMINE HOW
THIS WAS GOING TO BE SPENT.
WELL, I, I DON'T THINK THERE WAS
ANY ONE PERSON THAT SAID ANYBODY
COULDN'T BE PART OF THE
COALITION. I THINK THIS IS A
COALITION OF FOLKS THAT
GENERALLY WORK TOGETHER ON
DIFFERENT ASPECTS OF HOW WE DO
BUDGET. SO IT WAS HOSPITALS,
PHYSICIANS, SPECIALTY GROUPS.
PLANNED PARENTHOOD WAS AT THE
TABLE, ACTUALLY A VERY SIMILAR
COALITION WHEN WE DID PROP 56
AND WE WENT TO THE BALLOT TO FOR
MEDI-CAL RATES. I DO. SO I DON'T
THINK THERE WAS AN EXCLUSION IN
TERMS OF THIS INITIATIVE. IT WAS
VERY SIMILAR. WE SORT OF GOT THE
SAME CORE GROUP OF FOLKS
TOGETHER THAT WE WORKED ON WITH
PROP 56. I DO WANT TO JUST
ADDRESS YOUR FIRST STATEMENT
JUST A LITTLE BIT AND SAY, I, I
DON'T I KNOW THIS HAS GOTTEN A
LITTLE BIT CONTENTIOUS OVER THE
YEARS. WE'VE BEEN WORKING ON IT
IN TERMS OF IT'S NOT SOMETHING
THAT'S AGAINST THE LEGISLATURE
OR AGAINST BUDGETING. I THINK IF
YOU LOOK AT ACTUALLY HOW IT'S
WRITTEN, IT'S WRITTEN EXACTLY,
LIKE THE BUDGET THAT WAS PASSED
IN THE 2023, 24 BUDGET IN AN
ATTEMPT, AS WE WORKED THAT OUT
TO SORT OF HAVE THAT LANDING
INTO HOW IT WOULD BE IMPLEMENTED,
THAT BUDGET CHANGED IN THIS,
THIS LAST YEAR. SO IT DOESN'T
MIRROR IT EXACTLY ANYMORE. BUT
IT DID IN THAT FIRST BUDGET. AND
I THINK, THE ATTEMPT WOULD BE
THAT THIS BECOMES SUSTAINABLE
FUNDING INTO THE FUTURE,
REGARDLESS OF THE MAKEUP OF THE
LEGISLATURE. THE PRIORITIES OF
THE LEGISLATURE. AND THAT PART
OF IT WAS IMPORTANT FOR
ORGANIZATIONS TO BE ABLE TO
COUNT YEAR AFTER YEAR, THAT
THEY'LL BE ABLE TO MAKE CHANGES
TO EXPAND SERVICES REGARDLESS OF
A FUTURE BUDGETING PROCESS.
YEAH. THANK YOU, CAN I GET
CLARIFICATION IN LA DOCUMENT AND
THE CHART ON PAGE TWO FOR
COMMUNITY HEALTH WORKERS AND I
AND THEN I READ THE PROPOSITION.
IT JUST WANT TO MAKE SURE I'M
NOT READING THIS INCORRECTLY.
THE CHART HAS COMMUNITY HEALTH
WORKERS WITH THE LITTLE FOOTNOTE
THAT SAYS THAT THE FUNDING IS
DEPENDING ON HOW MUCH MONEY IS
RAISED BY THE HEALTH PLAN TAX.
BUT IN THE PROPOSITION IT SAYS
ABOUT 32 MILLION, I BELIEVE IS
GOING TO BE USED FOR COMMUNITY
HEALTH WORKERS. SO IT'S THE
FUNDING AND THE PROPOSITION
DEPENDENT, OR IS IT A GUARANTEED.
JASON SEYARTO, LEO, CAN YOU HEAR
ME? YES. GREAT, SO THE MEASURE
DOES PROVIDE FUNDING FOR
COMMUNITY HEALTH WORKERS, BUT
IT'S IT THERE IS A SET AMOUNT OF
FUNDING, BUT BEFORE THAT AMOUNT
IS TRIGGERED, IT HAS TO RAISE A
CERTAIN AMOUNT OF FUNDING. SO I
DON'T HAVE THE EXACT AMOUNT. I
THINK IT'S 4.3 BILLION, THAT'S
AND THOSE ARE THOSE AMOUNTS
WITHIN THAT 4.3 BILLION ARE, ARE
ARE ALLOCATED BASED ON A
PROPORTION. IF THAT AMOUNT IS
EXCEEDED IN THE TAX THEN THERE
ARE ADDITIONAL ALLOCATIONS. AND
DEPENDING ON HOW MUCH THAT THAT
COULD TRIGGER THE 30 THAT THAT
AMOUNT FOR COMMUNITY HEALTH
WORKERS. SO IT'S NOT
AUTOMATICALLY GUARANTEED FROM
THE GET GO. IT'S WE HAVE TO MEET
THE 4.2 BILLION AND THEN
ADDITIONAL INVESTMENTS LIKE
COMMUNITY HEALTH WORKERS ARE
GOING TO GET THE $32 MILLION IT
SORT OF TRIGGERED, DEPENDING ON
HOW MUCH MONEY IS RAISED. IT'S
NOT A IT'S NOT JUST A STRAIGHT
PROPORTION. WHAT ARE THE CHANCES
THAT WE WOULD MEET THAT
THRESHOLD? THAT'S NOT SOMETHING
THAT WE INCLUDED IN OUR
ANALYSIS. IT'S REALLY HARD TO
PROJECT THE MCO TAX. IT'S
CHANGED A LOT OVER THE YEARS,
THIS YEAR'S MCO TAX IS MUCH
LARGER THAN IT HAS BEEN IN
PREVIOUS YEARS. SO, YOU KNOW,
THERE'S I THINK THERE'S A LOT OF
UNCERTAINTY ABOUT WHETHER THAT
THE SORT OF SAME SIZE TAX WOULD,
WOULD EXIST IN SORT OF
PERPETUITY. IT ALSO DEPENDS A
LOT ON FEDERAL RULES WHICH CAN
WHICH CAN CHANGE OVER TIME. SO
IS THAT THE ONLY ITEM THAT HAS A
TRIGGER CLAUSE? WHAT OTHER
ITEMS? I APOLOGIZE, I DON'T HAVE
THE LIST IN FRONT OF ME. WE CAN
I CAN CIRCLE BACK WITH YOU IF
YOU. THAT WOULD BE HELPFUL. BUT
THERE ARE OTHER THERE ARE OTHER
TRIGGERS IN THERE. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. SENATOR. DOCTOR WEBER.
THANK YOU, SENATOR ROTH, REALLY
WANT TO ALSO THANK THIS PANEL,
FOR COMING AND ADDING YOUR
EXPERTISE IN THIS AREA. AND YOUR
LIFE EXPERIENCES FOR THE
PROVIDERS WHO ARE ON THE PANEL
AS WELL, ALSO WANT TO THANK THE
COALITION FOR GETTING TOGETHER
AND REALLY PUTTING PATIENTS
FIRST, I THINK AS YOU MENTIONED,
SOMETIMES YOU'RE YOU ALWAYS ARE,
YOU KNOW, YOU'RE AT OPPOSITE
ENDS OF THE ROOM, BUT WE'RE ABLE
TO COME TOGETHER AND CREATE THIS
VERY IMPORTANT, KIND OF LIKE
ONCE IN A LIFETIME AGREEMENT BY
PUTTING PATIENTS FIRST. AND ONE
OF THE THINGS THAT YOU
MENTIONED, JODIE, THAT REALLY
STUCK OUT TO ME IS FULFILLING
THE PROMISE, BECAUSE AS I SAID,
WITH THE PREVIOUS PANEL AND I'VE
SAID MANY, MANY TIMES, PROVIDING
INSURANCE TO EVERYONE, BUT NOT
PROVIDING ACCESS TO CARE, WE'RE
NOT DOING ANYTHING. AND ACTUALLY
WE ARE NOT FULFILLING THAT
PROMISE. AND SO WHAT WE'RE
DISCUSSING TODAY, WHAT WE WERE
JUST TRYING TO FIGURE OUT WITH
THE MCO TAX, IS A WAY IN WHICH
WE CAN FULFILL THAT PROMISE, I
ALSO WANT TO THANK THOSE WHO
CAME TO THE TABLE TO REALIZE
THAT, WHEN THINKING OF THE
PATIENT FIRST, YOU CAN'T BE
SELFISH BECAUSE YOU HAVE TO
RECOGNIZE THAT YOU MAY GET
SOMETHING. BUT IF LIKE YOU SAID,
IF YOU CAN'T REFER YOUR PATIENT
TO THE PROPER RADIOLOGIST OR THE
BREAST ONCOLOGIST OR THE MEDICAL
ONCOLOGIST, ONCE YOU FOUND
SOMETHING, THEN WE'RE NOT REALLY
DOING ANYTHING. I REMEMBER WHEN
I CAME BACK AND I WAS, I WAS
LOOKING TO SEE WHERE I WAS GOING
TO PRACTICE IN SAN DIEGO. I WAS
TALKING WITH A GROUP OUT OF
CHULA VISTA THAT PRETTY MUCH
DEALT WITH MEDI-CAL PATIENTS,
AND THEY COULD NOT FIND, YOU
KNOW, GYNECOLOGIC ONCOLOGIST TO
REFER THE PATIENTS TO BECAUSE
NOBODY WOULD COME DOWN IN THAT
AREA IF THE PATIENTS COULDN'T GO
TO LA JOLLA, THEY WOULD NOT SEE
THEM. AND SO THEY LITERALLY HAD
PATIENTS WALKING AROUND WITH
UTERINE CANCER, BECAUSE THEY
COULD NOT ACCESS THE GYNAE ONC,
BECAUSE OF THEIR KIND OF
INSURANCE. SO THANK YOU SO MUCH.
MY FIRST QUESTION IS, YOU KNOW,
JODI, YOU MENTIONED SOMETHING
AND IT'S IN THE INITIATIVE. BUT
IF YOU COULD JUST ELABORATE WHEN
YOU TALKED ABOUT THE ABILITY TO
FUND OTHER THINGS THAT THE
LEGISLATURE WOULD HAVE, THE
ABILITY TO FUND OTHER THINGS,
EVERYONE MAY NOT HAVE READ THE
INITIATIVE. SO IF YOU CAN JUST
ELABORATE ON THAT A LITTLE BIT,
PLEASE. YES. SO IT WAS IMPORTANT
TO LOOK AT THE SAFETY NET AND
ENSURE THAT THERE WAS A PORTION
THAT WAS GETTING FUNDED WITH
PREDICTABILITY AND STABILITY AS
WE TALKED ABOUT, WE ALSO WANTED
TO ENSURE THAT ESPECIALLY AS I
MENTIONED, COMING OUT FROM A
PANDEMIC, THINGS HAPPEN YEAR
AFTER YEAR THAT MIGHT BE NEW,
MIGHT NEED FUNDING. AND SO
HAVING AN ALLOTTED AMOUNT THAT
WAS ALSO PREDICTABLE AND STABLE
FOR THE LEGISLATURE. SO THERE
HAVE BEEN LAPSES WHERE THE MCO
TAX HAS NOT BEEN, EXTENDED. THIS
ENSURES THAT IT'S EXTENDED
AUTOMATICALLY. AND WITH THAT
THERE'S A DEDICATED AMOUNT THAT
GOES INTO THE GENERAL FUND. AND
JUST TO ADDRESS, THE COMMUNITY
HEALTH WORKER AND SOME OF THAT
THIRD TRANCHE, PART OF THAT WAS
BECAUSE AS WE WERE WRITING IT AT
THE TIME THAT WE WERE, AND
AGAIN, I'M GOING TO ACKNOWLEDGE
THIS ISN'T A FIX OF AN ENTIRE
HEALTH CARE DELIVERY SYSTEM
THAT, QUITE FRANKLY, HAS BEEN
UNDERFUNDED HISTORICALLY. IT'S I
THINK WE ALL CAN ADMIT, BUT IT
WAS TRYING TO ENSURE THAT
THERE'S A DEDICATED AMOUNT AND
WE HAD TO SHUFFLE THINGS AROUND
A LITTLE BIT IN ORDER TO DO
THAT. SO FOR THE FIRST COUPLE OF
YEARS, THERE'S 2 BILLION THAT,
AND CHEN, PLEASE JUMP IN IF I'M
GETTING TECHNICAL THINGS WRONG,
BUT THERE'S 2 BILLION THAT GOES
IN. THAT WAS TO MATCH THE BUDGET
AT THAT TIME, AT THAT SNAPSHOT
THAT WE WERE WRITING IT, 2
BILLION DEDICATED TO GO INTO
WHAT IS THE GENERAL FUND.
THERE'S SOME 700 MILLION AFTER
THAT THAT GETS PLUSSED UP,
DEPENDING ON THE SIZE OF THE MCO
TAX. AND THAT'S INCLUDED
INCLUDED SOME OF THOSE
ADDITIONAL THINGS TO GET FUNDED,
LIKE COMMUNITY HEALTH CARE
WORKERS AND, SOME WORKFORCE
DOLLARS, THINGS LIKE THAT, NOT
BECAUSE THEY WEREN'T AS
IMPORTANT. PART OF IT IS WE,
VOTERS, COALITION MEMBERS, DON'T
CONTROL THE AMOUNT OF THAT TAX.
IT IS DONE BY THE
ADMINISTRATION. AND SO, WANTED
TO HAVE SOME SORT OF INCENTIVE
PIECES IN THERE OR A WAY TO GROW
THAT LIKE IT IS THIS YEAR, IF WE
CONTINUE TO DO THAT TAX AS WE
DID THIS YEAR, ALL OF THOSE
THINGS WOULD BE FUNDED, IF IT'S
TAX, YOU KNOW, IF THE MCO TAX IS
MUCH SMALLER, SOME OF THOSE
THINGS WOULDN'T GET FUNDED.
THERE'S AN ADDITIONAL AMOUNT
THAT WILL GO BACK INTO THE
GENERAL FUND AFTER THAT. 700
MILLION IS SORT OF, YOU KNOW, AN
INCENTIVE OF HOW WE CAN GROW AND
INVEST AT THE LARGEST EXTENT
POSSIBLE. THE COMMUNITY HEALTH
CARE WORKER PIECE WAS REALLY
INTERESTING BECAUSE, AGAIN, THIS
DOESN'T PREVENT THE LEGISLATURE
FROM DOING OTHER THINGS AND
OTHER THINGS THAT ARE
PRIORITIES. ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT WE FOUND WITH THE COMMUNITY
HEALTH CARE WORKERS, THAT WAS A
REALLY IMPORTANT PIECE FOR
PLANNED PARENTHOOD AND THE
CLINICS, ALSO THE HEALTH PLANS
WERE ADVOCATING FOR THAT PIECE
QUITE A BIT BECAUSE IT DOES KEEP
COSTS DOWN, THE WAY THAT WE HAVE
TRIED TO INVEST IN COMMUNITY
HEALTH WORKERS IS UNDER A
MEDI-CAL BENEFIT. AND THEN THIS
YEAR'S BUDGET PROPOSES TO
INCREASE THAT AMOUNT QUITE A
BIT. TO MEDICARE RATES. MIGHT BE
GOOD FOR SOME CLINICS. WE DON'T
DISCOURAGE THAT FROM HAPPENING.
WHAT WE DID IN THIS INITIATIVE,
THOUGH, AND WHAT WE HAVE FOUND
IS THE WAY WE USE COMMUNITY
HEALTH CARE WORKERS. IT'S NOT A
MEDI-CAL BENEFIT IN THE
TRADITIONAL SENSE, BECAUSE WE
SEND THEM OUT INTO THE COMMUNITY
TO TRY AND GET ALL OF THE
PATIENTS AND BRING BACK, AND
THEY'RE NOT ALL MEDI-CAL
PATIENTS. OFTENTIMES, SOME OF
THEM ARE YOUNG PEOPLE ON THEIR
PARENTS INSURANCE THAT ARE
AFRAID TO USE IT. SO WE MIGHT
HAVE TO HELP THEM WITH HOW TO
FILE THE PAPERWORK SO THAT THEIR
PARENTS DON'T FIND OUT, OR THEY
MIGHT BE SOMEBODY THAT DOESN'T
IS A CASH PAYING PATIENT. BUT
THE POINT IS TO GO OUT IN THE
COMMUNITY AND SORT OF HELP
EVERYONE IN THE COMMUNITY. AND
SOME OF THOSE ARE MEDI-CAL
BENEFICIARIES. BUT IF WE'RE ONLY
USING THEM AS A MEDI-CAL
BENEFIT, THEN WE CAN'T USE THOSE
DOLLAR AMOUNTS. AND AS PLANNED
PARENTHOOD, WE HAVEN'T BEEN ABLE
TO TAKE ADVANTAGE OF THAT. SO
THIS IS REALLY TRYING TO HAVE A
DIFFERENT, MORE INNOVATIVE SORT
OF POT OF DOLLARS THAT CLINICS
CAN USE THAT MAYBE FOR CBO'S,
YOU KNOW, IN THE COMMUNITY TO BE
ABLE TO UTILIZE THOSE DOLLARS.
BUT IT'S REALLY IF WE AND THAT
WAS PART OF THIS COALITION, IF
YOU TAKE A STEP BACK, YOU KNEW
YOU WERE HAVING A DEDICATED AND
SUSTAINABLE FUNDING. WHAT WOULD
YOU IMAGINE THAT YOU WOULD USE
DOLLARS FOR TO REALLY EXPAND
ACCESS? SO FOR SOME PRIMARY
CARE, IT MIGHT BE TAKING MORE
PATIENTS FOR CLINICS LIKE OURS
THAT WERE 85% MEDI-CAL ALREADY.
HOW CAN WE EXPAND WHAT WE'RE
ALREADY DOING IN THE COMMUNITY
AND WHAT WOULD WE USE? AND SOME
OF THOSE LIKE, YOU KNOW, LOAN
REPAYMENT FOR ALLIED HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS WAS ONE WAY. IT
WAS SORT OF ALL THINGS ON THE
TABLE. WE HAD THIS BIG
WHITEBOARD THAT WEEK AFTER WEEK.
WE WROTE ON AND SCRATCHED THINGS
OFF, AND THAT WAS HOW WE CAME TO
WHAT WE HAVE TODAY. SO IT
ESSENTIALLY ALLOWS FOR
FLEXIBILITY DEPENDING ON WHAT
THAT PARTICULAR SYSTEM OR AREA
WOULD NEED. EXACTLY. AND I WAS
ACTUALLY IMPRESSED WHEN I WAS
READING THROUGH IT AND IT WAS
SAYING, OKAY, WELL, IF IT
EXCEEDS IF THIS FUND EXCEEDS
THIS AMOUNT, THEN WE'RE
AUTOMATICALLY GOING TO DEPOSIT
INTO, YOU KNOW, GIVE MORE TO
ANOTHER FUND LIKE THE EMERGENCY
DEPARTMENT AND HOSPITAL SERVICES
ACCOUNT. SO, I THOUGHT IT WAS,
YOU KNOW, VERY, VERY CREATIVE.
AND I DO ALSO WANT TO POINT OUT,
AS YOU MENTIONED, THIS PLAN IS
DIFFERENT THAN WHAT WE HAVE IN
OUR MCO TAX BECAUSE IT IS
PERMANENT. IT'S NOT SOMETHING
THAT IS SCHEDULED TO END IN A
COUPLE OF YEARS. IT'S NOT
SOMETHING WHERE PEOPLE HAVE TO
WONDER, WILL WE HAVE THE FUNDING
COME BACK TO THE LEGISLATURE
AND, AND, AND FIGHT FOR MORE
FUNDING DEPENDING ON WHO'S HERE
AND WHO'S IN THE GOVERNOR'S
SEAT. SO IT IS, LONG TERM
BECAUSE WE KNOW THAT PEOPLE WILL
NEED HEALTH LONG TERM. IT'S NOT
LIKE HEALTH CARE WILL END IN A
COUPLE OF YEARS, WE WANTED TO
ASK A QUESTION TO ERIN KELLY.
YOU ALL DID A STUDY OR PUBLISHED
A STUDY DEALING WITH PEDIATRIC
SPECIALTY WAIT TIMES. WHICH I
THOUGHT WAS QUITE INTERESTING.
AND SO, YOU KNOW, IF A, IF A
CHILD WITH DIABETES NEEDS TO SEE
THEIR ENDOCRINOLOGIST, THEIR
WAIT TIME, THE MEDIAN WAIT TIME
IS LIKE ABOUT 40 DAYS, BUT IT
COULD BE AS LONG AS 180, OR IF
SOMEONE NEEDS TO SEE A MEDICAL
PEDIATRIC GENETICIST, THE
AVERAGE IS AROUND 140 DAYS. BUT
I THINK WHAT WAS STRIKING TO ME
WAS ALSO, YOU DID A CORRELATION
BETWEEN 2019 AND 2022. AND WHAT
YOU SAW IS FOR SOMETHING LIKE
CHILDREN OR PEDIATRIC
DEVELOPMENTAL BEHAVIOR,
PEDIATRICS IN 2019, THE AVERAGE
WAIT TIME WAS 60 DAYS. AND THEN
IT JUMPED TO OVER 100 DAYS IN
2022. SO ESSENTIALLY WE'RE
GETTING WORSE. HOW DO YOU THINK
THAT THIS PROPOSITION WOULD HELP
WITH SOME OF THESE WAIT TIME
NUMBERS? BECAUSE I ASKED THE
FIRST PANEL AND THEY HAD NO IDEA
HOW LONG SOMEONE ON THE MEDI-CAL
SYSTEM WOULD HAVE TO WAIT, HOW
DO YOU THINK THAT THIS
PROPOSITION WOULD ASSIST WITH
SOME OF THOSE WITH OUR MOST
VULNERABLE PATIENTS, OUR
PEDIATRIC PATIENTS THAT ARE
REQUIRED TO SEE SOME OF THESE
SUBSPECIALIST? YEAH. SO THANK
YOU FOR HIGHLIGHTING THOSE
CONCERNING TRENDS. YEAH. SO IT'S
GOING TO BRING KIND OF MORE
MEANINGFUL INVESTMENTS INTO
THESE SPECIALTY MEDICAL GROUPS.
SO THEY WILL BETTER BE ABLE TO
RECRUIT AND RETAIN THEIR
PHYSICIAN WORKFORCE. AND SO BE
ABLE TO POTENTIALLY HIRE AN
ADDITIONAL SPECIALIST, IT IS
VERY HARD TO RECRUIT PEDIATRIC
SUBSPECIALISTS HERE TO
CALIFORNIA BECAUSE OF THE COST
OF LIVING, BECAUSE OF THE LOW
MEDI-CAL RATES. AND SO BRINGING
THOSE RATES TO PARITY WITH
MEDICARE WILL OBVIOUSLY BE AN
INCENTIVE TO COME HERE. AND
ANOTHER THING I ECHOED IN MY
REMARKS, WHICH IS ALSO PART OF
PROP 35, IS SOME SIGNIFICANT
INVESTMENTS IN GRADUATE MEDICAL
EDUCATION, AS WELL AS LOAN
REPAYMENT, WHICH I THINK WILL
HELP INCENTIVIZE MEDICAL
STUDENTS TO PURSUE PEDIATRIC
SUBSPECIALIZATION HERE IN
CALIFORNIA AND THEN STAY HERE
AND PRACTICE HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
SO THANK YOU. THANK YOU, DOCTOR
WEBBER, SENATOR CUEVAS, THANK
YOU, MR. CHAIR, AND THANK YOU TO
THE PANEL FOR THIS INFORMATIVE
DISCUSSION. AND I, I WANT TO
JUST MENTION TO DOCTOR PATEL, I
UNDERSTAND THAT YOU ARE STILL
WORKING IN THE COMMUNITY THAT
YOU INITIALLY WENT TO SERVE,
FOCUSING ON UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES. I WANT TO
APPRECIATE AND CONGRATULATE YOU
ON THAT. NOT TO PLUG MY OWN BILL,
BUT I HAVE A BILL TO REALLY
ACCELERATE LICENSURE FOR HEALTH
CARE PROVIDERS WHO COME BACK TO
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES. SO I
JUST WANT TO SAY HOW IMPORTANT
THAT WAS. AND ALSO THE
INFORMATION SHARED THAT 86% OF
SANTA CLARA COUNTY RESIDENTS ARE
ON SOME SORT OF SUBSIDIZED
SUPPORT CARE. MEDI-CAL. CAN YOU
GIVE ME THAT STAT? AGAIN, IF I
MAY CLARIFY SO OF THE PATIENTS,
THE SANTA CLARA VALLEY HEALTH
CARE SYSTEM SERVES, 86% ARE ON A
GOVERNMENT SUBSIDIZED PROGRAM
PROGRAM, OF WHICH 58% ARE ON
MEDI-CAL. SO YOU KNOW, I SAY
THAT TO SAY THIS CONVERSATION IS
ABOUT A SYSTEM THAT IS BROKEN
AND WE ARE CONTINUING TO WORK
TO, TO ADDRESS THE HARM, TO
ADDRESS THE LACK OF CARE, YOU
KNOW, THANK GOD FOR OBAMACARE.
BUT WE HAVE SO MUCH FURTHER TO
GO. AND I REALLY APPRECIATE THIS
CONVERSATION AND THIS UNUSUAL
GROUP OF SUSPECTS WHO ARE COMING
TOGETHER TO HELP US THINK
THROUGH SOLUTIONS, MY QUESTION
HAS MORE TO DO ABOUT TWO THINGS
WITHIN THE INITIATIVE. IS THERE
A TRACKING AND EVALUATIVE
ELEMENT TO IT? BECAUSE AT THE
END OF THE DAY, WHAT WE'RE
TRYING TO DO IS ADDRESS OUR
HEALTH CARE CRISIS, AND WE WANT
TO SEE HOW MANY MORE FAMILIES
ARE GETTING CARE. AND ALSO KIND
OF THE RIPPLE EFFECTS IN TERMS
OF THE SUPPORT SERVICES, THE
TRAINING, ALL OF THE ALL OF THE
DIFFERENT ASPECTS OF CARE THAT
ARE LISTED IN THIS INITIATIVE ON
PAGE TWO OF THE REPORT THAT MY
GOOD COLLEAGUE FROM SANTA, SAN
FERNANDO VALLEY MENTIONED, HOW
DO WE KNOW THIS IS WORKING AND
HOW DO WE KNOW IF ENOUGH IS
ENOUGH? IT SEEMS AS EVERY TIME
WE GET TO A POINT WHERE WE THINK
WE HAVE ENOUGH, WE REALIZE THAT
WE DON'T, RIGHT? THERE'S A
DEEPER CRISIS. AND I AND I'M
JUST CURIOUS, JUST WHAT IS THAT?
IS THERE ANYTHING EMBEDDED IN
THIS TO EVALUATE AND MEASURE,
HOW THIS HOW THIS PROGRAM, WILL
WORK AND KIND OF LONG TERM
FORECAST. AND THEN THE SECOND
THING, I THINK IT WAS TOUCHED ON
AND I MIGHT HAVE MISSED IT IN
THE EARLIER PANEL, IS THIS ISSUE
OF THE FEDERAL IMPLICATIONS. SO
LET'S SAY THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA, AS OUR VOTERS OFTEN
DO THE RIGHT THING TO ENSURE
THAT OUR COMMUNITIES ARE TAKEN
CARE OF AND SUPPORTED. AND
CERTAINLY, HEALTH CARE IS ONE OF
THOSE ISSUES THAT TOUCHED SO
MANY OF OUR FAMILIES, YOU KNOW,
WHAT IS THE WAY THAT WE CAN,
MAKE SURE WE DON'T GET
UNDERMINED BY THE FEDERAL
PROCESS? SO JUST CURIOUS, YOU
KNOW, WHAT ARE OUR THOUGHTS ON
ON THOSE TWO POINTS? ONE ON THE
PANEL, I'LL GIVE IT TO JODY AND
ANYONE CAN ANSWER THAT. YEAH,
I'LL TAKE THE FIRST ONE AND THEN
I'LL LET YOU TALK ABOUT THE
AUDIT PIECE, BECAUSE I DON'T
WANT TO GET THAT WRONG, LIKELY,
I MEAN, ONE OF THE THINGS THAT I
SAY JUST IN GENERAL AND THEN,
JEN, PLEASE PICK THIS UP ON THE
FROM THE FEDERAL ASPECT IS, YOU
KNOW, PLANNED PARENTHOOD, IF WE
SORT OF PAUSED BASED ON WHAT WE
WERE WORRIED ABOUT AT THE
FEDERAL LEVEL, WE CERTAINLY
WOULDN'T STILL BE DOING SERVICES
IN THE WAY THAT WE ARE, WE DID,
THOUGH, HAVE AND BUILD IN AN OFF
RAMP FOR IF SOMETHING HAPPENS AT
THE FEDERAL LEVEL, THAT WE HAVE
AN OFF RAMP THAT WE'RE NOT
LEAVING CALIFORNIA ON THE HOOK
FOR. WHAT IS A, YOU KNOW, HAS TO
BE SORT OF HOW WE WORK TOGETHER
AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL TO GET THE
MATCHING FUNDS AND GET APPROVAL
FROM CMS. SO WE DID BUILD THAT
IN FOR SOME ASSURANCES. BUT
ALSO, WE'RE IN THIS VERY STRANGE
TIME IN HISTORY WHERE OUR THE
TWO OUTCOMES AT THE FEDERAL
LEVEL ARE SO VASTLY DIFFERENT ON
WHAT CAN HAPPEN, OUR MEDI-CAL
SYSTEM IS MOST DEFINITELY AT
RISK, DEPENDING ON OUTCOMES. AT
THE FEDERAL LEVEL FOR VARIOUS
PIECES, VARIOUS POSITIONS IN
VARIOUS TIMES. RIGHT. I BELIEVE
THAT ANY DAY AND I, AND I SAY
THIS FROM A PLANNED PARENTHOOD
HAT THAT ANY DAY THAT WE CAN
GIVE SOMEBODY CARE IS A DAY TO
BE CELEBRATED. AND THE MORE THAT
WE INVEST AND ENTWINE AND DO
EVERYTHING WE CAN DO IN OUR
MEDI-CAL SYSTEM, THE HARDER IT
IS TO UNWIND FOR SOMEONE ELSE TO
UNWIND. SO THE HARDER IT IS FOR
A DIFFERENT LEGISLATURE TO
UNWIND THOSE INVESTMENTS, THE
HARDER IT IS FOR SOMEBODY AT THE
FEDERAL LEVEL TO UNWIND, AND THE
HARDER IT IS TO UNWIND, IS
ANOTHER DAY THAT SOMEONE'S ABLE
TO GET CARE. AND THAT'S A GOOD
DAY. SO I THINK WE HAVE TO BUILD
IN THOSE OFF RAMPS BECAUSE WE
CAN'T BE IRRESPONSIBLE. BUT WE
ALSO HAVE TO INVEST AND WE ALSO
HAVE TO DO EVERYTHING THAT WE
CAN DO TODAY. SO SOMEBODY IS
GETTING CARE TODAY SO THAT IT'S
HARDER FOR SOMEONE TO TAKE THAT
AWAY. AND I THINK WE SAW THAT
WITH THE AFFORDABLE CARE ACT,
NOW THAT IT'S IN EVERYBODY'S,
YOU KNOW, MINDSET, IT'S VERY
HARD TO UNWIND. AND I THINK
PEOPLE UNDERESTIMATED THAT FACT.
I THINK THAT'S TRUE FOR OUR
MEDI-CAL SYSTEM AS WELL. AND IF
WE CAN SHOW THAT WE'RE MOVING
THE NEEDLE HERE IN CALIFORNIA
BECAUSE OF THE INVESTMENTS THAT
WE'VE MADE FOR HALF OF THE
CHILDREN BORN FOR A THIRD OR
MORE, I THINK IT'S MORE NOW OF
OUR PATIENTS, THE HARDER THAT IS
TO ROLL BACK, AND THAT'S WHAT
WE'RE TRYING TO DO WITH THIS
INITIATIVE. YES. AND SO THANK
YOU FOR THE QUESTION. THERE'S
THREE, KIND OF DIFFERENT WAYS IN
WHICH THE INITIATIVE HAS SOME
ACCOUNTABILITY AND TRANSPARENCY
INTO THE SPENDING. SO THE FIRST
IS THE CONTROLLER IS REQUIRED TO
DO AN AUDIT OF THE ACTUAL KIND
OF DOLLARS IN, DOLLARS OUT EVERY
FOUR YEARS, AND WE PROVIDE FOR
THAT CONTROLLER COST. THE
DEPARTMENT, THE DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH CARE SERVICES HAS A,
ANNUAL REPORT THAT THEY HAVE TO
ISSUE IN PUBLICLY POST AND SHARE
TO DEMONSTRATE THAT ALL OF THE
DIFFERENT SUBACCOUNTS AND
FUNDING METHODOLOGIES ARE BOTH
BEING MET. AND IN THE WAY IN
WHICH THEY'RE BEING MET. AND
THEN LASTLY, THERE'S A,
STATUTORILY CREATED STAKEHOLDER
GROUP IN WHICH THE DEPARTMENT
NEEDS TO BE WORKING AS THEY ARE
DEVELOPING AND OR CHANGING ANY
KIND OF FUNDING METHODOLOGY. AND
THAT WAS REALLY TO KIND OF,
CREATE A MORE KIND OF
COLLABORATIVE AND INPUT BODY
THAT YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT, WHICH
IS IF SOMETHING CHANGES IN A
DELIVERY SYSTEM OR THERE IS A, A
CHANGE IN A PROVIDER PATTERN OR
BEHAVIOR. CAN WE CHANGE THOSE
METHODOLOGIES? AND SO THERE'S
REALLY KIND OF THREE WAYS. ONE
IS A VERY HARD FISCAL AMOUNT.
ONE IS A COMBINATION OF A FISCAL
AND PROGRAMMATIC AMOUNT. AND
THEN ONE IS THE STAKEHOLDER
PROCESS, WHICH IS A VERY MUCH
MORE ON THE GROUND PROGRAMMATIC
ELEMENT. OKAY. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU ALL VERY MUCH. APPRECIATE
YOUR TESTIMONY. WE STILL HAVE
TWO MORE PANELS PLUS PUBLIC
COMMENT. AND THIS IS HEARING
NUMBER ONE, FOR THOSE OF YOU
SITTING ON THE DAIS. AND THEN WE
HAVE HEARING NUMBER TWO. SO,
LET'S TAKE OUR THIRD PANEL. THIS
THESE ARE THE OPPONENTS TO
PROPOSITION 35, THIS PANEL WE'RE
GOING TO ALLOW ABOUT FIVE
MINUTES SINCE I THINK THERE'S
ONE PERSON PLUS QUESTIONS. SO
COME ON DOWN. IDENTIFY YOURSELF
FOR THE RECORD PLEASE, AND
PROCEED WHEN READY. GOOD
AFTERNOON, HONORABLE MEMBERS OF
THE ASSEMBLY AND SENATE HEALTH
COMMITTEES. MY NAME IS MYRA
ALVAREZ. I AM PRESIDENT OF THE
CHILDREN'S PARTNERSHIP. WE ARE A
STATEWIDE ADVOCACY ORGANIZATION
FOCUSED ON ADVANCING CHILD
HEALTH EQUITY. AND WE'RE
REPRESENTING THE INTERESTS OF
CHILDREN AND FAMILIES HERE TODAY
AS AN ORGANIZATION COMMITTED TO
STRENGTHENING CALIFORNIA'S
HEALTH CARE SYSTEM AS AN
ESSENTIAL PART OF ADVANCING
CHILD HEALTH EQUITY, THE
CHILDREN'S PARTNERSHIP HAS
HISTORICALLY WORKED ALONGSIDE
MANY OF THE PROPONENTS THAT
SPOKE TODAY, AND WE ARE PROUD TO
HAVE SUPPORTED AND ADVOCATED FOR
THE MCO TAX FUNDING AS WELL AS
FOR DIRECTING THAT FUNDING FOR
MEDI-CAL PROVIDER RATE
INCREASES. THERE IS NO QUESTION
THAT CALIFORNIA PAYS FAR TOO
LITTLE TO PROVIDERS
PARTICIPATING IN MEDI-CAL. IT
HINDERS ACCESS FOR THE MILLIONS
OF CALIFORNIANS WHO RELY ON THE
PROGRAM, AND A
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTS
CHILDREN OF COLOR, WHO ARE MORE
LIKELY TO DEPEND ON THE PROGRAM
FOR COVERAGE. THE DIFFERENCE
DRIVING OUR OPPOSITION TO
PROPOSITION 35 IS THE
RESTRICTION IMPOSED BY THE
PROPOSITION ON HOW THE FUNDS CAN
BE USED. THE CAPS ON THE TAX AND
WHO THE DECISION MAKERS ARE IN
MAKING THOSE DETERMINATIONS.
FIRST, PROP 35 REDIRECTS
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS THAT
CURRENTLY SUPPORT MEDI-CAL AND
THE STATE'S GENERAL FUND TO A
HANDFUL OF SPECIFIC PROVIDER
RATE INCREASES. DOING SO
THREATENS FUTURE PROGRAM
ELIGIBILITY EXPANSIONS AND
OPTIONAL BENEFITS. THE STATE
LIKELY WOULD HAVE TO USE MORE
MONEY FROM THE GENERAL FUND TO
COVER CORE MEDI-CAL EXPENSES,
AND EXPANSION EXPENSES IN FUTURE
YEARS, AS WE ANTICIPATE
DIFFICULT BUDGET YEARS AHEAD.
THIS HIT TO THE GENERAL FUND TO
THE TUNE OF BILLIONS WILL BE
PAINFUL. SECOND, PROP 35
ESTABLISHES AN UPPER LIMIT ON
THE TAX RATE FOR COMMERCIAL
HEALTH PLANS, INSTEAD RELYING ON
REVENUE FROM MEDI-CAL HEALTH
PLANS, RISKING A DRAMATIC
REDUCTION IN REVENUE. THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT HAS INDICATED
AN INTENTION TO CHANGE THE RULES
SUCH THAT CALIFORNIA, AS WELL AS
OTHER STATES, WOULD BE REQUIRED
TO EVENLY DISTRIBUTE THE TAX
BETWEEN MEDI-CAL AND COMMERCIAL
PLANS. IF THIS OCCURS AS
EXPECTED, THE PROPOSITIONS
COMMERCIAL TAX CAP WILL LEAVE
OUR STATE NO CHOICE BUT TO
DRAMATICALLY LOWER ITS MEDI-CAL
TAX RATE OVER TIME. AGAIN, THIS
WOULD LEAD TO SIGNIFICANT
DECREASE IN REVENUE FROM THE MCO
TAX, FURTHER UNDERMINING THE
STATE'S YOUR ABILITY TO SUPPORT
EFFORTS TO IMPROVE CHILDREN'S
HEALTH AND HEALTH EQUITY. MORE
BROADLY. THIRD, THE ALLOCATION
OF FUNDING UNDER PROPOSITION 35
IS DECIDED BY A GROUP OF
SELECTED PROVIDER ORGANIZATIONS
WITH LITTLE VOICE FROM THE
COMMUNITY, FROM THE LEGISLATURE,
FROM MEDI-CAL ENROLLEES OR OTHER
ESSENTIAL PROVIDER GROUPS,
INCLUDING COMMUNITY HEALTH
WORKERS. OVERALL, WHILE INTENDED
TO INCREASE MEDI-CAL ACCESS,
PROPOSITION 35 INSTEAD SEVERELY
JEOPARDIZES FUNDING FOR THE
PROGRAM BY RESTRICTING STATE
FUNDING SOURCES FOR MEDI-CAL.
THIS IS ESPECIALLY APPARENT IN
PROGRAMS AND INVESTMENTS ON THE
LINE. THIS YEAR, OUR
ORGANIZATION AND MANY, MANY
PARTNERS ARE GRATEFUL THAT THE
FINAL 2024 TO 25 BUDGET INCLUDED
FUNDING TO IMPLEMENT MULTI-YEAR,
CONTINUOUS MEDI-CAL COVERAGE FOR
THE 1.2 MILLION YOUNG CHILDREN,
0 TO 5 THAT DEPEND ON MEDI-CAL.
STABLE COVERAGE IS ESPECIALLY
PARAMOUNT DURING THESE FIRST FEW
YEARS OF MAJOR BRAIN
DEVELOPMENT, SO THAT KIDS GET
THEIR WELL-CHILD VISITS AND
DEVELOPMENTAL SCREENINGS,
STREAMLINING ENROLLMENT. CHIPS
AWAY AT THOSE SYSTEMIC BARRIERS.
THE CURRENT MEDI-CAL UNWINDING
PROCESS, EVEN WITH DC'S
INCREDIBLE EFFORTS, SHOW US WHAT
HAPPENS. 350 000 CHILDREN IN OUR
STATE HAVE LOST COVERAGE,
INCLUDING 90,000 OF THEM
CHILDREN 0 TO 5. THE POLICY IS
LONG OVERDUE, AND UNFORTUNATELY,
IT WOULD BE RENDERED INOPERATIVE
IF PROPOSITION 35 PASSES THIS
NOVEMBER. AGAIN, THE CHILDREN'S
PARTNERSHIP STRONGLY SUPPORTS
THE MCO TAX AND INVESTMENTS IN
PROVIDER RATES. HOWEVER, FOR THE
REASONS OUTLINED TODAY, WE
OPPOSE PROP 35 AND URGE
SUPPORTERS OF CHILDREN'S HEALTH
EQUITY TO VOTE NO IN NOVEMBER.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
PRESENTATION, COLLEAGUES. ANY
QUESTIONS, COMMENTS, CONCERNS?
SENATOR MENGIBAR, I KNEW I COULD
COUNT ON YOU. WELL, MR. CHAIR,
IT'S BECAUSE I WORKED SO HARD
FOR THE PAST YEAR AND A HALF ON
THIS TOPIC. SO I HAVE A LOT OF
OPINIONS ON THIS THAT I THINK
ARE NO NOTHING COMING FROM LEFT
FIELD. I'VE SAID THIS VARIOUS
TIMES, AND I AGREE WITH THE
PERSON HERE WHO WAS STANDING
ALONE, WHO WAS BOLD ENOUGH TO
COME UP AGAINST A VERY TIGHT
KNIT COALITION. AND THE QUESTION
I ASKED IN THE PREVIOUS PANEL
WAS WHO WAS MADE UP OF THAT
COALITION? BECAUSE YOU'RE RIGHT,
I DIDN'T SEE ANYONE WHO WAS A
PATIENT. I DIDN'T SEE ANYONE WHO
WAS AN ADVOCATE, ALL I SAW WERE
PROVIDERS, REPRESENTATIVES OF,
HOSPITALS OR CLINICS. AND I
WANTED TO HEAR FROM PEOPLE WHO
ARE GOING TO BENEFIT FROM THESE
PROGRAMS. AND I MADE THE COMMENT
BEFORE ABOUT ELECTED OFFICIALS
BEING PART OF THIS PROCESS.
THAT'S WHAT WE WERE PLACED HERE,
AND WE WERE PLACED TO REPRESENT
PEOPLE WHO DON'T HAVE THE JUICE,
PERHAPS TO BE PART OF THOSE BIG
COALITIONS. AND IT WAS OUR
RESPONSIBILITY THROUGHOUT THE
PAST EIGHT MONTHS OR SO OR
SEVEN, TO INCLUDE THOSE VOICES
IN THE BUDGET PROCESS AND THAT'S
WHAT WE DID, BECAUSE THEY
WEREN'T ABLE TO BE PART OF THAT
TIGHT KNIT GROUP. AND I'M
DISAPPOINTED. AND I THINK EVERY
LEGISLATOR SHOULD BE
DISAPPOINTED THAT THEY PUT THEIR
HARD WORKING SWEAT AND BLOOD AND
TEARS INTO THIS BUDGET PROCESS
JUST SO IT CAN BE UNDONE COME
NOVEMBER, AND I AGREE WITH THIS
ADVOCATE IN ASKING HOW WE VOTE
LATER ON. BUT, BECAUSE I KNOW
IT'S NOT A MAGIC PILL, I KNOW
IT'S NOT GOING TO SOLVE
EVERYTHING. THE MCO TAX OR PROP
35, IT'S NOT GOING TO SOLVE
EVERYTHING. BUT WHAT WE DID ON
THE BUDGET PROCESS WAS INCLUSIVE
OF SO MANY MORE PEOPLE. AND WHAT
PROP 35 IS DOING IS BEING
EXCLUSIVE. THEY'RE EXCLUDING
PEOPLE VERSUS INVITING MORE
PEOPLE TO BENEFIT FROM AN
AMAZING ABILITY TO PULL DOWN
FUNDS THAT DON'T AFFECT THE
GENERAL FUND. THANK YOU.
SENATOR. ANY OTHER DOCTOR? WEBER
THANK YOU. SENATOR ROTH, THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR COMING UP AND
PROVIDING YOUR, YOUR PERSPECTIVE
OF THIS PROPOSITION, IT IS A
CHALLENGING ISSUE. AND, YOU
KNOW, I AS HEALTH BUDGET CHAIR
ON THE ASSEMBLY SIDE, WAS, YOU
KNOW, WORKING TO HELP PUSH THIS
INITIATIVE FORWARD. THE MCO TAX.
AND THEN THINGS CHANGED. AND
AND, AND WE HAD TO REDIRECT, BUT
I THINK MAYBE I LOOK AT IT
DIFFERENTLY BECAUSE I'M A
PROVIDER AND I'M ON THE GROUND
AND I SEE WHAT IS HAPPENING.
MAYBE BECAUSE I HAVE PEOPLE
COMING TO TALK WITH ME ABOUT THE
FACT THAT THEY JUST DON'T HAVE
ACCESS. SO MY QUESTION TO YOU,
IN YOUR OPPOSITION,
UNDERSTANDING THAT WHAT WE WHAT
WE PASSED WAS NICE, BUT THERE
IS, WE DID NOT KEEP OUR PROMISE
TO INCREASE THE PROVIDER RATES
AS INITIALLY DISCUSSED IN THE
JANUARY 2024 BUDGET, OR THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL, AND THERE
IS AN END DATE OF 2026. IT IS
YOUR STANCE THAT IT'S BETTER TO
HAVE A DEADLINE RATHER THAN TO
HAVE SOMETHING THAT IS PERMANENT
AND ONGOING FOR OUR CALIFORNIA
RESIDENTS. BUT MORE
SPECIFICALLY, YOU KNOW, YOU'RE
WITH THE CHILDREN'S PARTNERSHIP,
SO YOU FOCUS ON CHILDREN. I'M A
PEDIATRIC ADOLESCENT
GYNECOLOGIST, SO I'M AT THE
CHILDREN'S HOSPITAL AS WELL,
THAT IS YOUR STANCE THAT WE
SHOULD JUST SCRAP THAT AND JUST
AND FOCUS ON WHAT THE
LEGISLATURE PASSED. I'M A LITTLE
CONFUSED. IF YOU CAN HELP ME
UNDERSTAND. ABSOLUTELY I THINK
REGARDLESS OF THE PASSAGE OF
PROPOSITION 35, THE MCO TAX HAS
TO HAVE FEDERAL APPROVAL. SO
IT'S PERMANENT UNTIL WE GET
APPROVAL BY THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT. THAT'S STILL A
PROCESS THAT HAS TO CONTINUE
REGARDLESS OF THE PASSAGE OF THE
PROPOSITION, AS FAR AS
UTILIZATION OF THE MCO TAX TO
GENERATE ADDITIONAL REVENUE,
THAT IS UP TO THE LEGISLATURE,
THE GOVERNOR, THE PUBLIC TO
DECIDE TOGETHER. RIGHT. I THINK
THIS PROPOSITION SAYS THE
IMPORTANCE OF KEEPING IT
PERMANENT, ACTUALLY SUPPORT THAT
IN GENERAL, THE CHILDREN'S
PARTNERSHIP WANTS THIS TAX
REVENUE SOURCE. IT'S IMPORTANT
TO ENSURE THAT HEALTH PLANS ARE
PARTICIPATING AND PROVIDING
THEIR FAIR SHARE FOR A HEALTH
CARE SYSTEM THAT WE ALL
PARTICIPATE IN. I DON'T, SO I
DON'T DISAGREE ABOUT THE
SPECIFICITY OF MAKING THIS
PERMANENT. WHAT WE ARE CONCERNED
WITH IS WHAT IS AT STAKE, WHAT
ARE THE BILLIONS OF DOLLARS THAT
WILL BE LOST AS A RESULT OF
LOCKING IN THESE RATES OF LOSING
THAT FLEXIBILITY, OF DECIDING
HOW THE REVENUE WILL BE USED IN
THE FUTURE, GIVEN THE
UNCERTAINTIES THAT ARE IN FRONT
OF US. AGAIN, WE ARE PARTNERS
WITH MANY OF THE ACTUALLY MANY
OF THE ORGANIZATIONS THAT ARE
PROPONENTS, AND WE WILL CONTINUE
TO BE, BECAUSE THIS IS NOT THE
ONLY CHALLENGE IN OUR HEALTH
CARE SYSTEM. AGAIN, THE MEDI-CAL
PAYMENT RATE IS ONE OF THE
LOWEST IN THE COUNTRY FOR THE
FOURTH LARGEST ECONOMY IN THE
WORLD. IT'S UNACCEPTABLE, AND WE
WILL CONTINUE TO BE AT THE TABLE
IN THE FUTURE. IF THOSE
OPPORTUNITIES ARE AVAILABLE TO
THE CHILDREN'S PARTNERSHIP TO
IDENTIFY WHAT THOSE SOLUTIONS
COULD LOOK LIKE. BUT FOR NOW, WE
DO NOT BELIEVE PROPOSITION 35 IS
IT, SO YOU HAVE JUST BROUGHT
SOMETHING OUT THAT I THINK IS
EVEN MORE ALARMING THAT WE
HAVEN'T HEARD OUR MEDI-CAL RATES
ARE THE FOURTH LOWEST IN THE
COUNTRY. NO NO NO NO NO, WE'RE
IN THE BOTTOM HALF. IT RANGES.
WE'VE BEEN 47TH. WE'VE BEEN
23RD. I JUST SAID FOR A FOURTH
LARGEST ECONOMY IN THE WORLD TO
BE PAYING, WE'RE AT THE BOTTOM.
WE'RE AT THE BOTTOM. EVEN THOUGH
WE ARE THE FOURTH LARGEST
ECONOMY AND OUR COST OF LIVING
HERE IS EXTREMELY HIGH. SO WHAT
IS YOUR RESPONSE TO A COUPLE OF
THINGS? ONE, THE STUDIES WILL
LOOK AT THE CHILDREN'S HOSPITALS
FOR CHILDREN'S SPECIALISTS THAT
SHOW THAT AS TIME HAS GONE ON,
PROVIDER ACCESS HAS WORSENED.
RIGHT. WHICH IS PROBABLY A
RESULT OF THE INABILITY OF US TO
RECRUIT AND RETAIN, CHILDREN'S
SPECIALISTS, AND HOW HOW DO YOU
YOU KNOW, AND SO CLEARLY, WE
NEED AN INCREASE IN OUR, OUR
RATES. BUT HOW DO YOU RESPOND TO
THE, THE NOTION THAT WAS
DISCUSSED, THAT TALKED ABOUT THE
FACT THAT THERE IS FLEXIBILITY
IN THIS PARTICULAR PROPOSITION
FOR THE LEGISLATURE TO DETERMINE
WHAT THEY'RE GOING TO DO WITH
FUNDS, YOU KNOW, LATER ON THAT
IT'S NOT NECESSARILY ALL OF THE
MONEY IS GOING HERE OR THERE,
BUT THERE IS SIGNIFICANT
FLEXIBILITY, WHICH I BELIEVE
JODIE HICKS DISCUSSED. AND I
ASKED HER TO ELABORATE ON HOW DO
YOU RESPOND TO THAT? I THINK
WHAT I RESPOND, HOW DO I RESPOND
TO THE FLEXIBILITY QUESTION?
YES. AND THAT THERE WILL BE
FUNDING THAT THE LEGISLATURE
WILL BE ABLE TO APPROPRIATE, YOU
KNOW, BASED ON, HOW MUCH MONEY
IS COMING IN. AND THEN SHE ALSO
DISCUSSED ABOUT THE FLEXIBILITY
THAT PEOPLE WILL BE ABLE TO
DETERMINE, OKAY, IN OUR AREA AND
OUR HOSPITAL, WE NEED TO DO THIS
WITH THE FUNDS THAT WE GET, OR
WE NEED TO DO THAT OR PLANNED
PARENTHOOD COULD DETERMINE THAT
THEY'RE GOING TO DO THIS OR DO
THAT. SO I MEAN, BECAUSE YOU ARE
TALKING ABOUT FIXED, IT'S FIXED.
AND THE LACK OF FLEXIBILITY, AND
THAT'S ONE OF YOUR CONCERNS. SO
HOW DO YOUR ARGUMENTS SQUARE
WITH WHAT WE JUST HEARD IN THE
PREVIOUS PANEL? SURE.
ABSOLUTELY. TO THE FIRST POINT
ABOUT THE TRENDS, THE DISTURBING
TRENDS IN ACCESS. WE ARE RIGHT
THERE WITH YOU, INCREDIBLY
CONCERNED ABOUT THE TRENDS IN
ACCESS, PARTICULARLY FOR
PEDIATRIC SPECIALISTS, BUT MORE
BROADLY, EVEN FOR GENERAL
PEDIATRICIAN CARE. AND, ALL OF
THE CHALLENGES IN ACCESSING CARE
MORE BROADLY, ONE IS WE'RE
ENCOURAGED BY THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA'S LEADERSHIP AND
TRYING TO IMPROVE ITS MEDI-CAL
DELIVERY SYSTEM THROUGH CALAIM,
THROUGH COMMUNITY HEALTH
WORKERS, THROUGH DOULAS, YOU
NAME IT. THERE'S A NUMBER OF
INITIATIVES THAT OUR STATE CAN
BE PROUD OF AND POINT TO THAT WE
WANT TO GIVE CREDIT TO,
ADDITIONALLY, WE SUPPORT
PROVIDER RATE INCREASES FOR THE
MCO TAX. WE ABSOLUTELY DO THAT.
I WANT TO EMPHASIZE THAT'S NOT
WHAT'S GETTING DEBATED HERE.
FROM THE CHILDREN'S PARTNERSHIP
PERSPECTIVE. IT'S THE LACK OF
FLEXIBILITY IN THE FUTURE. YES,
THERE IS THAT TRIGGER POINT
ABOVE 4.9 BILLION, A CERTAIN
AMOUNT OF MONEY. THAT'S NOT
GUARANTEED. WE'RE MAKING
ASSUMPTIONS BASED ON HOW MUCH
REVENUE WILL BE GENERATED WHEN
WE ACTUALLY DON'T KNOW IF THAT'S
THE AMOUNT OF REVENUE THAT WILL
BE GENERATED. AGAIN, AS WAS
STATED EARLIER, THE AMOUNT OF
REVENUE THIS YEAR IS ACTUALLY
HIGHER THAN IT'S EVER BEEN
BEFORE. AGAIN, IN THE FUTURE,
THAT MAY CHANGE. SO WHAT IS ON
THE LINE IS THAT UNCERTAINTY.
AND THAT'S NEVER COMFORTABLE
WHEN WE'RE DEALING WITH PEOPLE'S
LIVES, WHAT IS CERTAIN IS THAT
WE WILL BE AT THE TABLE NEXT
YEAR AND THE YEAR AFTER, AND ANY
OTHER YEAR THAT OUR PROVIDER
GROUPS WANT TO COLLABORATE TO
IDENTIFY A SHARED SOLUTION.
THAT'S NOT UNCERTAIN. WE JUST DO
NOT BELIEVE THAT AS PROPOSITION
35 IS ALLOCATED, WE SHOULD MOVE
IT FORWARD. THANK YOU. AND I DO
WANT TO POINT OUT THAT ONE OF
THE UNFORTUNATE THINGS ABOUT OUR
MCO TAX IS THE UNCERTAINTY,
BECAUSE IT DOES END RIGHT. AND
SO EVEN THOUGH WE HAVE TO GO
BACK TO THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
TO GET MORE MONEY, THE FACT THAT
OUR CURRENT MCO TAX ENDS, NOT
ONLY DO WE HAVE TO GO BACK TO
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT, BUT WE
HAVE TO HAVE THOSE CONVERSATIONS
AGAIN. RIGHT? AND I THINK ONE OF
THE ISSUES IS THAT FOR 20 PLUS
YEARS, THERE HAS BEEN THAT
CONVERSATION ABOUT PROVIDER RATE
INCREASE, AND WE HAVE NOT SEEN
PROVIDER RATE INCREASES, WHICH
IS WHY THE ORIGINAL MCO TAX WAS
SUCH A MONUMENTAL THING, BUT,
YOU KNOW, I AGREE WITH YOU ABOUT
UNCERTAINTY. AND THAT'S ONE OF
THE THINGS THAT I SEE WITH OUR
VERSION OF THE MCO TAX, ALTHOUGH
BETTER THAN WHAT WE'VE HAD, IS
THAT IN 2026, WHAT IS GOING TO
HAPPEN AT THAT POINT? WE HAVE TO
START ALL OVER ONCE AGAIN. BUT I
REALLY APPRECIATE YOU COMING UP
AND SPEAKING, AND I AM SURE THAT
THERE ARE MORE BUT DIDN'T COME.
BUT I REALLY WANT TO APPRECIATE
YOU AND HEARING YOUR OPINION.
IT'S EXTREMELY IMPORTANT. THANK
YOU, THANK YOU, THANK YOU DOCTOR
BARBER, AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY. THANK YOU. WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE ON TO OUR FOURTH
PANEL. AND THE FOURTH PANEL
CONSISTS OF SOME OTHER
STAKEHOLDERS WHO WILL BE
PROVIDING THEIR PERSPECTIVES, WE
COULD HAVE THREE. WE'RE GOING TO
LIMIT THIS TO 15 MINUTES OR
LESS. PLUS SOME QUESTIONS I'M
SURE, BECAUSE WE STILL HAVE
PUBLIC COMMENT TO GET THROUGH
ABOUT 30 MINUTES OF THAT. MR.
CHAIR, YOU'RE NOT ENJOYING THE
WEBER SHOW HERE. I'M ENJOYING
EVERY SECOND OF IT. AND THEN WE
HAVE HEARING NUMBER TWO. SO
LET'S DO THIS. LET ME ASK YOU TO
IDENTIFY YOURSELVES TO MY LEFT.
YOUR RIGHT. MA'AM, THAT WOULD BE
YOU. AND THEN YOU CAN FLIP A
COIN AND PROCEED WHEN READY.
THANK YOU. MY NAME IS KAY LEE
WITH THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
FOR ADULT DAY SERVICES. GOOD TO
HAVE YOU HERE. THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR HAVING ME. KAREN SAVAGE SÐNG
NGUYEN EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA PAN ETHNIC HEALTH
NETWORK. THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR
AND MEMBERS. RAND MARTIN HERE ON
BEHALF OF AVIANA HEALTHCARE.
GOOD TO SEE YOU. OKAY. WHO'S
FIRST? I HAVE THE HONOR OF
STARTING HERE. SO THANK YOU SO
MUCH AGAIN FOR HAVING US, EXCUSE
ME, I HAVE TODDLERS AND THEY
BRING HOME GERMS EVERY WEEK. SO,
WE AT KHN, WE REPRESENT
CONSUMERS WITH A FOCUS ON THE
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES AND
FAMILIES WITH LOW INCOMES WHO
RELY UPON MEDI-CAL. WE HAVE
ALWAYS SUPPORTED MCO TAXES AND
INVESTMENTS IN THE MEDI-CAL
PROGRAM. WE HAVE NO FINANCIAL
STAKE IN THE OUTCOME OF
PROPOSITION 35. AND WHILE WE
CURRENTLY HAVE NO POSITION ON
THE INITIATIVE, WE DO WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT SOME SERIOUS CONCERNS
ABOUT ITS IMPACT ON COMMUNITIES
ALREADY IMPACTED BY HEALTH
DISPARITIES. I DO WANT TO SAY
THAT WE RESPECT MANY OF THE
PROPONENTS THAT SPOKE TODAY. ALL
OF THE PROPONENTS THAT SPOKE
TODAY ARE COMMUNITY CLINICS.
PLANNED PARENTHOOD AND OTHERS
ARE CRITICAL PARTICIPANTS IN
MEDI-CAL. THEY ARE KEY TO
SERVING OUR MOST VULNERABLE
CALIFORNIANS AND THE STATE HAS
YET TO INVEST IN THEM AS WE
MUST. WE AGREE THAT PROVIDER
PARTICIPATION IN MEDI-CAL IS A
SIGNIFICANT BARRIER TO ADEQUATE
ACCESS TO CARE. WE ARE
CONCERNED, HOWEVER, THAT
PROPOSITION 35 WILL MAKE THIS
PROBLEM WORSE. NOT BETTER, BY
JEOPARDIZING BILLIONS OF DOLLARS
IN FEDERAL FUNDING RESTRICTING
FLEXIBILITY THE LEGISLATURE
NEEDS TO MAKE MEDI-CAL MOST
EFFECTIVE AND IMPLEMENTING
ARBITRARY FUNDING FORMULAS THAT
FAVOR MULTI-BILLION DOLLAR
CORPORATIONS OVER COMMUNITY
BASED CARE. FIRST, AND MOST
IMPORTANTLY, THE PROPOSITION
CAPS THE COMMERCIAL TAX RATE IN
LAW, WHICH IS LIKELY TO
DRAMATICALLY REDUCE THE REVENUE
CALIFORNIA CAN GENERATE THROUGH
THIS TAX IN THE FUTURE, WHEN THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT CHANGES THE
REGULATIONS AS THEY HAVE
PROMISED IN WRITING TO THE STATE
TO DO CURRENTLY, CALIFORNIA
TAXES MEDI-CAL PLANS AT A RATE
THAT IS OVER 100 TIMES HIGHER
THAN THE RATE FOR NON-MEDICAL
PLANS. WHILE THIS HAS BEEN
ADVANTAGEOUS TO CALIFORNIA, THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT UNDER
ADMINISTRATIONS OF BOTH
POLITICAL PARTIES HAS STATED
THAT CALIFORNIA'S APPROACH IS
INCONSISTENT WITH THE INTENT OF
THE LAW, WHICH REQUIRES THAT THE
TAX BE REDISTRIBUTIVE IN NATURE,
WHICH MEANS SHIFTING MONEY FROM
THE COMMERCIAL INSURANCE MARKET
TO SUPPORT MEDICAID IN THEIR
APPROVAL OF THE CURRENT TAX, CMS
WROTE THAT THEY, QUOTE, INTEND
TO DEVELOP AND PROPOSE NEW
REGULATORY REQUIREMENTS THROUGH
THE NOTICE AND COMMENT
RULEMAKING PROCESS. TO ADDRESS
THIS ISSUE. PROPOSITION 35
ELIMINATES YOUR ABILITY TO
ADJUST CALIFORNIA'S TAX TO
COMPLY WITH THESE FUTURE
CHANGES. INSTEAD, WE WOULD
FORFEIT BILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN
FEDERAL FUNDING. IT IS NO
SURPRISE, THEREFORE, THAT ONE OF
THE COUNTRY'S LARGEST HEALTH
INSURERS IS A FUNDER OF THIS
INITIATIVE. AFTER RAKING IN OVER
$2 BILLION IN PROFITS IN JUST
THE FIRST HALF OF THIS YEAR, THE
LEGISLATURE SHOULD RETAIN YOUR
ABILITY TO SET AN APPROPRIATE
AND PERMISSIBLE TAX RATE FOR ALL
HEALTH PLANS. SECOND, THE
PROPOSITION CREATES SIGNIFICANT
RISK TO MEDI-CAL ELIGIBILITY AND
BENEFITS, AS WELL AS OTHER
SAFETY NET PROGRAMS, BY
PERMANENTLY LOCKING UP THE VAST
MAJORITY OF TAX REVENUE IN
PROVIDER RATE INCREASES, THE
LEGISLATURE MUST HAVE THE
ABILITY TO ANALYZE AND BALANCE
THE EVOLVING NEEDS OF THE
MEDI-CAL PROGRAM AND TO FUND
OTHER SAFETY NET PROGRAMS
APPROPRIATELY. HEALTH EQUITY IS
NOT ONLY ABOUT ACCESS TO HEALTH
CARE WITHOUT STATE INVESTMENT IN
HOUSING, INCOME SUPPORT, AND
FOOD ASSISTANCE, MEDI-CAL
MEMBERS CAN'T BE HEALTHY NO
MATTER HOW MANY DOCTORS THEY CAN
SEE. PROPOSITION 35 WOULD LIMIT
THE DOLLARS AVAILABLE FOR
MEDI-CAL AND OTHER PURPOSES NOT
SPECIFIED IN THE INITIATIVE TO A
FRACTION OF WHAT WAS AVAILABLE
TO THE LEGISLATURE TO BALANCE
THE BUDGET THIS YEAR, IT IS
IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT REVENUE
FROM THE CURRENT TAX IS MUCH
HIGHER THAN PREVIOUS VERSIONS OF
THE TAX, AND CANNOT BE ASSUMED
TO REPRESENT THE FUTURE. IF
PROPOSITION 35 HAD BEEN IN
EFFECT FOR THE PREVIOUS MCO TAX,
FOR EXAMPLE, YOU WOULD HAVE HAD
LESS THAN $140 MILLION TO MAKE
BUDGET DECISIONS THIS YEAR,
RATHER THAN THE $7.5 BILLION
THAT YOU DID HAVE. THIRD, AND
FINALLY, THE ALLOCATIONS IN THE
PROPOSITION APPEAR TO BE
ARBITRARY AND DO NOT CORRESPOND
TO THE AREAS OF MOST ACUTE NEED.
FOR EXAMPLE, THE BUDGET THAT YOU
APPROVED EARLIER THIS YEAR
INVESTS IN NON-SPECIALTY MENTAL
HEALTH PROVIDER RATES FOR THE
DURATION OF THE APPROVED TAX.
BECAUSE WE ALL SEE THE DIRE LACK
OF MENTAL HEALTH CARE AROUND US.
PROPOSITION 35, ON THE OTHER
HAND, DOES NOT INVEST IN THESE
RATES BEYOND 2026, WITH THE
EXCEPTION OF PSYCHIATRISTS AND
TARGETS FUNDS IN WHAT THEY CALL
THE IMPROVING MENTAL HEALTH
ACCOUNT PRIMARILY TO FACILITIES
WITHOUT ANY REFERENCE TO
COMMUNITY BASED PROVIDERS. LESS
THAN 10% OF THE FUNDING IN THE
INITIATIVE WOULD GO TO COMMUNITY
CLINICS, WHO NEED FAR MORE,
GIVEN THE NUMBER OF MEDI-CAL
PATIENTS THAT THEY SERVE AND THE
FUNDING FOR DESIGNATED PUBLIC
HOSPITALS WHO SEE A
DISPROPORTIONATE SHARE OF
MEDI-CAL PATIENTS IS ARBITRARILY
CAPPED. UNLIKE THE VAST MAJORITY
OF THE ALLOCATIONS, INCLUDING
THOSE FOR PRIVATE PROVIDERS SUCH
AS PRIVATE AMBULANCE PROVIDERS,
THE SINGLE LARGEST FUNDER
CURRENTLY OF PROPOSITION 35 IS
GLOBAL MEDICAL RESPONSE, WHICH
IS OWNED BY THE PRIVATE EQUITY
GIANT KKR AND IS INFAMOUS FOR
PRICE GOUGING AND SURPRISE
MEDICAL BILLING. HOW CALIFORNIA
SPENDS OUR MEDI-CAL DOLLARS
SHOULD BE DETERMINED SOLELY BY
THE NEEDS OF PATIENTS, NOT
INFLUENCED BY THE PROFIT
MOTIVATIONS OF OUT-OF-STATE
BILLIONAIRES. IN CONCLUSION, WE
SUPPORT A TRULY PERMANENT MCO
TAX, AND WE SUPPORT INVESTMENTS
IN AREAS LIKE CLINIC PAYMENTS,
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH, PRIMARY
CARE, AND SPECIALTY CARE. BUT WE
CANNOT SUPPORT PROPOSITION 35,
AND WE URGE VOTERS TO CAREFULLY
CONSIDER WHETHER IT DOES MORE
HARM THAN GOOD. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. NEXT, PLEASE.
THANK YOU. MANY THANKS TO THE
CHAIR AND THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS
AND YOUR STAFF FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK TODAY.
AGAIN, MY NAME IS KAY LEE,
PRESIDENT FOR THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF ADULT DAY
SERVICES. KADS IS A MEMBERSHIP
ASSOCIATION REPRESENTING
PROVIDERS OF COMMUNITY BASED
ADULT SERVICES FOR SEA BASS. SEA
BASS IS A MEDI-CAL BENEFIT
SERVING HIGH RISK POPULATIONS
UNDER CONTRACT WITH MEDI-CAL
MANAGED CARE PLANS. WHILE THE
CADS BOARD DOES NOT OFFICIALLY
HAVE A POSITION ON PROPOSITION
35, WE APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TODAY TO HELP
ILLUSTRATE THE COMPLEXITIES AND
TRADE OFFS OF THE PROPOSITION
AND THE BUDGET PACKAGE AS IT
IMPACTS OUR PROVIDER COMMUNITY
AND THE PEOPLE THAT WE SERVE. IN
ADDITION TO SERVING AS THE CADS
PRESIDENT, I'M ALSO A PROVIDER
WITH LOCATIONS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE IN ORANGE COUNTY, LOS
ANGELES COUNTY, AS WELL AS SAN
MATEO COUNTY, A STATEWIDE.
AROUND 40,000 CALIFORNIANS WITH
CHRONIC HEALTH OR BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH CONDITIONS REPRESENTING
THE FULL CULTURAL DIVERSITY OF
OUR STATE, RECEIVE CARE FROM SEA
BASED PROGRAMS EACH YEAR. WE
THEREFORE CONSIDER OURSELVES TO
BE IMPORTANT PARTNERS WITH THE
PRIMARY CARE PROVIDERS AND
MANAGED CARE PLANS AS WE SERVE
WITHIN THE COMMUNITIES WITH THE
MOST VULNERABLE POPULATIONS, WE
THEREFORE UNDERSTAND AND FULLY
SUPPORT THE NEED FOR A
WELL-FUNDED PRIMARY CARE SYSTEM,
AND WE UNDERSTAND THAT THE
PROPOSITION IS STRUCTURED TO
BENEFIT PROVIDERS AS THEY SERVE
AS THE BACKBONE OF OUR HEALTH
CARE SYSTEM, ESPECIALLY
PHYSICIANS, HOSPITALS AND
CLINICS. HOWEVER, WE DO WANT TO
BRING TO ATTENTION AND TO LIGHT
THE FACT THAT THE PROVIDERS, SEA
BASED PROVIDERS WHO ARE
INITIALLY INCLUDED IN THE FINAL
BUDGET PACKAGE WERE ARE
CURRENTLY AFFECTED WITH THE WAY
THE PROPOSITION IS CURRENTLY
STRUCTURED, THE RATE INCREASE
THAT WAS INCLUDED IN THE IN THE
BUDGET WOULD BE ELIMINATED IF
PROPOSITION 35 IS TO BE APPROVED.
WE ARE GRATEFUL TO ALL OF YOU
FOR THE INCLUSION OF SEA BASS IN
THE FINAL BUDGET, AND ESPECIALLY
FOR THE SUPPORT OF SENATOR
MENGIBAR AND HER UNDERSTANDING
FOR THE DIRE NEED FOR RATING
RATE RELIEF AND HER SUPPORT AS
CHAIR FOR SENATE SUB THREE SEA
BASS CENTERS HELP MEDI-CAL AVOID
UNNECESSARY AND VERY COSTLY
SERVICES. HOWEVER, MANY SEA BASS
PROVIDERS ARE PAID THE DCS
PUBLISHED DAILY RATE OF $76.27
FOR A ROBUST PACKAGE OF
PROFESSIONAL AND SOCIAL
SERVICES, INCLUDING
TRANSPORTATION, NUTRITION,
NURSING AND SOCIAL SERVICES.
THIS BASE RATE HAS NOT BEEN
MEANINGFULLY INCREASED IN MORE
THAN 15 YEARS AND FALLEN FAR
BELOW THE RATE OF INFLATION,
KATZ HAS CALCULATED THAT JUST TO
CATCH UP WITH INFLATION TO HELP
SUPPORT PROVIDERS FROM
CONTINUING TO RUN SEVERE
DEFICITS, WOULD REQUIRE A 122
PER DAY RATE, WHICH IS CLOSE TO
WHICH CURRENTLY STANDS AT $50,
BEHIND THE DAILY RATE WE HAVE
SEEN. ALARMINGLY SEA BASS
PROVIDERS CLOSE THROUGHOUT THE
STATE IN JUST THE PAST FIVE
YEARS, 18 CENTERS HAVE CLOSED
OUT OF THE 300 CENTERS
STATEWIDE, AND MANY OF THESE
CLOSURES HAVE BEEN IN RURAL
AREAS WHERE CENTERS ARE FEW AND
FAR IN BETWEEN, IF EXISTING AT
ALL. BUT THE NEED CONTINUES TO
BE HIGH AND GROWING. AS A
PROVIDER, I CAN SHARE FIRSTHAND
HOW MANY OF MY COLLEAGUES
STRUGGLE TO MAINTAIN SERVICES AT
THE CURRENT RATE. WE WERE
EXCITED AND RELIEVED TO LEARN
THAT THE RATE INCREASE IN THE
BUDGET PACKAGE WAS INCLUDED. AND
ALTHOUGH IT'S A SMALL STEP
TOWARD THE GOAL TO REACH THE
RATES OF INFLATION THAT HAVE
BEEN EXPERIENCED OVER THE PAST
TWO DECADES, IT WAS CRITICALLY
NEEDED. AND FOR MANY SEA BASS
PROVIDERS, IT WOULD MEAN THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN CLOSING THE
DOORS AND CONTINUING TO REMAIN
OPEN IN THE COMING YEARS.
HOWEVER WITH THE RATE AS IT
CURRENTLY STANDS BEING TIED TO
PROPOSITION 35, OUR NETWORK IS
HAVING A DIFFICULT TIME KNOWING
WHAT TO THINK AND HOW TO PLAN
FOR THE FUTURE IN THE COMING
MONTHS AND YEARS. WE ARE A
SYSTEM IN LIMBO AS WELL AS
JEOPARDY. I WORRY THAT PROVIDERS
LIKE MYSELF AND MY COLLEAGUES
WILL HAVE TO REDUCE SERVICES OR
CONTINUE TO CLOSE AT THE RATE
THAT WE ARE IN THE PAST FEW
YEARS, AS WE AWAIT THE RESULTS
OF PROPOSITION 35, AND ASSUMING
THE PROPOSITION DOES PASS, WE
WILL THEN HAVE TO START OVER
AGAIN AND CONTINUE TO ADVOCATE
FOR A RATE INCREASE SO THAT OUR
PROVIDERS CAN CONTINUE TO
PROVIDE SERVICES FOR THESE
VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES,
REGARDLESS OF WHAT HAPPENS WITH
THE PROPOSITION, WE WILL
CONTINUE TO SERVE THE
COMMUNITIES THAT THAT WE HAVE
DONE SO HISTORICALLY AND
CONTINUE TO OPEN THE DOORS AS
AND WE INVITE ALL OF YOUR
COLLEAGUES AND YOURSELVES TO
COME VISIT OUR CENTERS AND TO
SEE FIRSTHAND THE SERVICES, AND
THAT WE PROVIDE FOR OUR
PARTICIPANTS, AS WE CALL THEM.
AND FOR THEIR FAMILIES. SEA BASS
IS A SMALL BUT VERY CRITICAL
COMPONENT OF THE SYSTEM OF CARE
FOR OUR CHRONICALLY ILL ADULTS
ON MEDI-CAL AND EVERY CLOSURE
THAT WE SEE IS A TRUE LOSS FOR
THE COMMUNITY. AND THANK YOU
AGAIN FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK ON ON THIS. AND I'M HAPPY
TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS. THANK
YOU. MA'AM. MR. MARTIN, YOU'RE
GOING TO CLOSE IT OUT HERE.
GENERAL ROTH. THANK YOU. RAND
MARTIN, AGAIN ON BEHALF OF AVIAN
HEALTH CARE, AVIAN IS ONE OF THE
LARGEST PROVIDERS OF PRIVATE
DUTY NURSING IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA, PRIVATE DUTY
NURSING, OR PD, RN IS A MEDI-CAL
BENEFIT FOR CHILDREN WITH
COMPLEX MEDICAL CONDITIONS AND
THEIR FAMILIES THAT HELPS ENSURE
THAT THOSE CHILDREN ARE
MEDICALLY CARED FOR IN THEIR
HOME AND IN THEIR COMMUNITY,
WHICH IS MORE EFFECTIVE AND FAR
MORE DESIRABLE FOR THE FAMILIES
AND FOR THE CHILD THAN LONG TERM
INSTITUTIONAL CARE. MOREOVER, IT
SAVES THE STATE MONEY BECAUSE
NURSING CARE AT HOME IS LESS
EXPENSIVE THAN HOSPITAL CARE. PD
RN HAS BEEN THREATENED NOT ONLY
BY ONGOING NURSING SHORTAGES,
BUT ALSO BY THE WHOLLY
INADEQUATE MEDI-CAL RATES THAT
HAVE MADE IT NEARLY IMPOSSIBLE
FOR PD RN PROVIDERS TO SECURE
AND RETAIN ENOUGH NURSES TO MEET
THE DEMANDS FOR CONTINUOUS
SKILLED NURSING IN THE HOME. THE
CONSEQUENCE OF THIS, PD AND
NURSING SHORTAGE HAVE BEEN THE
INABILITY TO PROVIDE THE HOURS
OF AUTHORIZED SKILLED NURSING
CARE NECESSARY TO KEEP A CHILD
AT HOME, OR TO MOVE CHILDREN
FROM WAITING LISTS INTO PD, AND
AS A RESULT, THEY EXPERIENCE
UNNECESSARY HOSPITAL DISCHARGE
DELAYS, MUCH LONGER HOSPITAL
STAYS, AND MORE FREQUENT
HOSPITAL ADMISSIONS AND
READMISSIONS. EARLIER THIS YEAR,
AN ALICIA, THE SACRAMENTO MOM OF
MILA, A CHILD WITH CEREBRAL
PALSY AND EPILEPSY, TOLD HER
POIGNANT STORY TO THE
LEGISLATURE ABOUT HER AND HER
HUSBAND'S COMMITMENT TO ENSURE
THAT THEIR DAUGHTER, THAT THE
WAY THE DAUGHTER WAS BORN THAT
THEY WOULD MAKE SURE THAT SHE
LIVED A FULL AND HAPPY LIFE
REGARDLESS OF WHAT SHE COULD OR
COULD NOT DO. SHE ALSO SPOKE
ABOUT THE PROFOUND DIFFICULTIES
SHE AND HER HUSBAND HAVE HAD IN
LIVING UP TO THAT PROMISE. SHE
TALKED OF THEIR ONGOING WAIT FOR
PD AND SERVICES. NONE OF WHICH
HAVE BEEN FULFILLED AS OF THIS
DATE. OF THE NURSING LEVEL. CARE
THAT SHE NOT A NURSE, MUST
PROVIDE EVERY DAY FOR HER
DAUGHTER WITH A TRACHEOSTOMY, A
VENTILATOR AND FEEDING TUBES.
SHE TALKED OF MILLER'S
REGRESSIVE AND REGRESSION AND
FREQUENT READMISSIONS TO THE
HOSPITAL. SHE SPOKE CANDIDLY
ABOUT THE SYSTEM FAILING MILA
AND HER FAMILY EXPERIENCES, LIKE
THOSE OF AN. ALICIA AND MILA
CONTRIBUTED TO THE EVENTUAL
DECISION BY THE LEGISLATURE AND
THE GOVERNOR TO APPROVE A
MEDI-CAL RATE INCREASE FOR PD
AND SERVICES BEGINNING IN 2026.
WHILE WE HAD HOPED FOR IMMEDIATE
RELIEF FOR OUR FAMILIES AND
CAREGIVERS, WE ARE DEEPLY
GRATEFUL THAT THE STATE
RECOGNIZED THE NEED AND THE
VALUE OF PD AND LOOK FORWARD TO
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES IN 2026.
HOWEVER, OUR FAMILIES AND
CAREGIVERS ARE NOT LOOKING
FORWARD TO NAVIGATING A POST
PROPOSITION 35 WORLD. NOT ONLY
DOES THIS INITIATIVE NOT INCLUDE
PRIVATE DUTY NURSING AS A
FUNDING RECIPIENT UNDER THE MCO
TAX, IT WOULD ALSO ELIMINATE THE
2026 MEDI-CAL INCREASE BEGINNING
IN 2027. MOMS LIKE ALICIA ARE
DEEPLY CONCERNED THAT AFTER
YEARS OF WAITING, THEY FINALLY
WILL GET SERVICES IN 2026, ONLY
TO FIND THOSE SERVICES ARE NO
LONGER AVAILABLE IN 2027. WE AND
OUR FAMILIES AND OUR CAREGIVERS
ARE COMMITTED TO WORKING TO
ENSURE THAT THE PROMISE OF 2026
IS SUSTAINED NEXT YEAR.
UNFORTUNATELY, WE AND OUR
FAMILIES AND CAREGIVERS HAVE NO
CHOICE BUT TO FIND A WAY TO
ENSURE THAT THE SERVICES THE
CHILDREN RECEIVE IN 2026 ARE NOT
TAKEN AWAY IN 2027. THAT IS AN
UNFORTUNATE AND UNNECESSARY
CHALLENGE THAT AWAITS US UNDER
PROPOSITION 35. WE APPRECIATE
YOUR TIME TODAY. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU, MR. MARTIN.
COLLEAGUES, ANY QUESTIONS BEFORE
WE PROCEED WITH PUBLIC COMMENT,
I SEE NO HANDS SLIDING UP IN THE
AIR. THANK YOU ALL VERY MUCH FOR
COMING AND PRESENTING. THANK
YOU. WE'RE NOW GOING TO PROCEED
TO THE PUBLIC COMMENT PORTION OF
THE HEARING. AS I INDICATED AT
THE BEGINNING, WE'VE ALLOCATED A
TOTAL OF 30 MINUTES FOR THIS
PUBLIC TESTIMONY. I'M LOOKING AT
THE NUMBER OF FOLKS IN THE ROOM.
WE'LL SEE HOW MANY LINE UP.
WE'LL PROBABLY LIMIT EACH TO ONE
MINUTE. IF I CAN GIVE YOU MORE,
I WILL. PLEASE PROCEED. GOOD
AFTERNOON. LINDA HèA WITH
WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY. ALTHOUGH WE HAVE NO
OFFICIAL POSITION ON PROP 35, WE
DID WANT TO PROVIDE COMMENTS AS
AN ANTI-POVERTY, RACIAL JUSTICE
ORGANIZATION THAT WORKS ACROSS
DIFFERENT ISSUE AREAS. WE
APPRECIATE THAT PROP 35 RIGHTLY
MAKES INVESTMENTS IN MEDI-CAL,
BUT HAVE SERIOUS CONCERNS THAT
THE BALLOT BOX BUDGETING TIES
THE HANDS OF FUTURE BUDGETS AND
WILL RESULT IN CUTS TO SAFETY
NET PROGRAMS IN DIFFICULT BUDGET
YEARS. RECALLING THAT IT TOOK
YEARS TO RESTORE SOME OF THE
2008 CUTS, WE APPRECIATE THAT
THIS YEAR'S BUDGET PROTECTED THE
SAFETY NET IN LARGE PART DUE TO
THE REDIRECTION OF THE MCO TAX
FUNDS TO THE GENERAL FUND,
WHETHER USING THE LAW OR
FINANCES. LARGER MULTI-BILLION
DOLLAR GENERAL FUND ESTIMATE. WE
DO WORRY THAT PROP 35 TAKES AWAY
A FUNDING SOURCE THAT NOT ONLY
IMPACTS FUTURE BUDGET, BUT ALSO
THE CURRENT BUDGET, INCLUDING
PREVENTING CONTINUOUS COVERAGE
FOR MEDI-CAL CHILDREN. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MA'AM. NEXT,
PLEASE SIR. GOOD AFTERNOON,
CHARLIE DONLON WITH STONE
ADVOCACY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ORTHOPEDIC
ASSOCIATION, WE SUPPORT PROP 35.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SIR. NEXT
PLEASE. GOOD AFTERNOON COREY
AYALA REPRESENTING THE PEDIATRIC
HEALTHCARE COALITION, CONSISTING
OF 22 CENTERS THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA WHO TAKE CARE OF
SEVERELY DISABLED AND MEDICALLY
FRAGILE CHILDREN. PDCS ARE A
RECIPIENT OF A RATE INCREASE IN
THE RECENTLY PASSED BUDGET,
WHICH WILL ENABLE US TO HIRE
MORE NURSES TO CARE FOR THE
CHILDREN THAT ARE ELIGIBLE FOR
OUR SERVICES, OUR SERVICE, OUR
CENTERS ARE SEVERELY IMPACTED
WITH WAITLISTS, WHICH MEAN THAT
THESE CHILDREN NEED TO BE CARED
FOR AT HOME OR IN SKILLED
NURSING FACILITIES. WE DON'T YET
HAVE A POSITION ON PROPOSITION
35, BUT FELT YOU NEEDED TO KNOW
THAT THESE CHILDREN WILL BE
SEVERELY IMPACTED SHOULD THE
PROPOSITION PASS. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH, MA'AM. NEXT, PLEASE. GOOD
AFTERNOON, MR. CHAIR AND
MEMBERS. CONNIE DELGADO, ON
BEHALF OF THE DISTRICT HOSPITAL
LEADERSHIP FORUM, THESE ARE THE
33 DISTRICT AND MUNICIPAL
HOSPITALS, 18 OF THEM ARE
CRITICAL ACCESS HOSPITALS AND
TWO THIRDS ARE RURAL, AND THE
LATEST INFORMATION THAT WE HAD
THESE HOSPITALS SAW OVER 900,000
EMERGENCY DEPARTMENT VISITS.
THEY OPERATE ON THE MOST
NARROWEST OF MARGINS, AND WE
APPRECIATE ALL OF YOUR EFFORTS
IN THE PAST. WE DO SUPPORT PROP
35 AND ITS EFFORTS TO INCREASE
FUNDING TO PROVIDERS SO THAT
THEY CAN CONTINUE TO PROVIDE
SERVICES WHEN AND WHERE
CALIFORNIA PATIENTS NEED IT.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. MA'AM.
NEXT PLEASE. GOOD AFTERNOON
REBECCA ALCANTAR, ON BEHALF OF
ALTAMED HEALTH SERVICES, IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF PROPOSITION
35, WE ARE COMMUNITY HEALTH
CENTERS ARE THE SAFETY NET, YOU
KNOW, BACKBONE OF THE SAFETY NET
SYSTEM HERE IN CALIFORNIA. AND
WE REALLY NEED THAT SECURE
FUNDING STREAM TO MAKE HEALTH
FOR ALL A REALITY, SO REALLY
LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING TO
WORK WITH ALL THE STAKEHOLDERS.
THANK YOU, MA'AM. THANKS FOR
JOINING US. YES. NEXT, PLEASE.
GOOD AFTERNOON. BRIANNA PITMAN
SPENCER WITH THE CALIFORNIA
DENTAL ASSOCIATION, WHO IS A
SUPPORTER AND OF PROPOSITION 35,
PART OF THE COALITION. THE
REASON THAT WE'RE PART OF THAT
COALITION IS, AS JODI TALKED
ABOUT, THE NEED TO INVEST. AND I
KNOW IT'S BEEN SAID HERE, WE
NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT PATIENTS
HAVE ACCESS. AND THERE'S JUST AS
MUCH OF AN ACCESS PROBLEM IN
DENTAL AS THERE IS EVERYWHERE
ELSE IN THE MEDI-CAL SYSTEM.
LESS THAN 50% OF ALL MEDI-CAL
KIDS SAW A DENTIST IN THE LAST
YEAR, AND THAT'S ACTUALLY UP.
THAT'S THE GOOD NEWS. WE'VE
ACTUALLY MADE PROGRESS. SO
THAT'S A YOU KNOW, WE NEED TO
KEEP BUILDING ON THAT, WE KNOW
THAT PROVIDER RATES WERE
INCREASES WORK. THAT'S WHAT WE
SAW IN PROPOSITION 56. THAT'S
WHY WE HAVE A GROWING NUMBER OF
KIDS WHO HAVE SEEN A DENTIST IN
MEDI-CAL, THE PROPOSITION 56
INVESTMENTS. THEY'VE WORKED,
THEY'VE BROUGHT MORE DENTISTS
INTO THE PROGRAM. WE NOW HAVE
40% OF DENTISTS IN CALIFORNIA
TAKING MEDI-CAL, WHICH IS,
AGAIN, A HUGE HIGH WATER MARK.
THE PLACES THAT THE PROPOSITION
56 AND CAL-AIM HAVE NOT FOCUSED
ON. THEY DID A REALLY GOOD JOB
ON PREVENTION AND KIDS SERVICES.
WE HAVEN'T SEEN THAT SAME TYPE
OF INVESTMENT FOR ADULTS,
PATIENTS WITH SPECIAL NEEDS AND
PARTICULARLY SPECIALTY SERVICES.
I KNOW THAT WAS TALKED ABOUT
EARLIER. THOSE ARE THE PLACES
THAT WE REALLY NEED TO MAKE SURE
PEOPLE HAVE ACCESS. IT'S GREAT
TO GET YOUR TEETH CLEANED. IT'S
GREAT TO DO PREVENTION, BUT YOU
NEED TO BE ABLE TO GET THAT
RESTORATION. AND SO THAT'S, IN
PROPOSITION 35, THAT'S WHERE
THOSE RATES WOULD BE FOCUSED.
AGAIN, THERE ARE SOME
FLEXIBILITY THERE. AND THAT'S
WHY CDA IS SUPPORTIVE OF
PROPOSITION 35. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MA'AM. NEXT PLEASE. GOOD
AFTERNOON. MY NAME IS HECTOR.
I'M SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF THE
INLAND COALITION FOR IMMIGRANT
JUSTICE. WHILE WE DON'T HAVE AN
OFFICIAL POSITION ON THE
PROPOSITION, WE ARE PLEASED TO
KNOW THAT THE GOVERNOR AND
LEGISLATURE ARE REVIEWING
CALIFORNIA'S BENCHMARK PLAN AND
COMMEND THE EFFORTS TO ENSURE
EQUITABLE ACCESS TO HEALTHCARE
SERVICES FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS.
WE'RE HERE TO PROPOSE THAT THE
SORRY HEAR THE PROPOSED THAT
HEALTH INSURANCE COVER THE COST
OF IMMIGRATION PHYSICALS,
FEDERALLY MANDATED STEP, AND THE
NATURALIZATION PROCESS THAT CAN
POSE A SIGNIFICANT FINANCIAL
BURDEN ON MANY IMMIGRANTS
SEEKING TO ADJUST THEIR STATUS.
THESE IMMIGRATION PHYSICALS CAN
RANGE FROM $200 TO OVER $1,000
PER EXAM, WHICH IS A SIGNIFICANT
EXPENSE, AND THE RATES VARY
THROUGHOUT THE STATE BECAUSE
THERE ARE NOT, THEY'RE NOT
REGULATED BY USCIS. AND SO AND
THE RATE FOR, FOR THESE
IMMIGRATION PHYSICALS CAN
INCREASE DEPENDING ON WHETHER
APPLICANTS REQUIRE VACCINES, LAB
TESTS OR TREATMENTS IN ORDER TO
MEET ELIGIBILITY REQUIREMENTS.
AND WHILE THE STATE HAS TAKEN
SIGNIFICANT EFFORTS AND
VICTORIES IN EXPANDING MEDI-CAL,
MEDI-CAL ACCESS TO UNDOCUMENTED
RESIDENTS HERE, ALL INCOME
ELIGIBLE RESIDENTS AND THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION HAS EXPANDED ACA
COVERAGE FOR DREAMERS, THESE.
THIS EXPANDED COVERAGE DOES NOT
COVER THESE PHYSICALS BECAUSE
THEY HAVE A BUREAUCRATIC
PURPOSE. INSTEAD OF A MEDICAL
PURPOSE, AND THEY GO THROUGH A
SPECIAL PROCESS WITH DESIGNATED
CIVIL SURGEONS. AND WE BELIEVE
THAT AN EMPHASIS ON THIS, WHILE
IT'S NOT COMPLETELY RELATED TO
THE PROPOSITION, EMPHASIS ON
THIS FURTHER, IT FURTHER, BUILDS
ON THIS COMMITTEE'S EFFORTS AND
THE LEGISLATURE'S EFFORTS TO
EXPAND EQUITABLE ACCESS TO
HEALTHCARE AND TAKE PREVENTATIVE
STEPS FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS HERE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. YOU ALL
ARE. GOOD EVENING. MY NAME IS
TAISHA WATTS HERE ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA ACADEMY OF FAMILY
PHYSICIANS, REPRESENTING 10,000
FAMILY PHYSICIANS, RESIDENTS AND
MEDICAL STUDENTS, WE ARE IN
SUPPORT OF PROPOSITION 35. AS
YOU ALL KNOW, THE PRIMARY CARE
HAS HISTORICALLY BEEN
UNDERFUNDED. AND IT'S TIME THAT
WE CONTINUE TO MAKE INVESTMENTS
SO THAT WE CAN CONTINUE TO
PROVIDE PROVIDE WHOLE PERSON
CARE TO THE ENTIRE FAMILY AND
TAKE PREVENTATIVE MEASURES
RATHER THAN WAITING FOR PEOPLE
TO BE SICK. SO WE WANT TO ENSURE
THAT WE ARE INVESTING AND
CONTINUING TO INVEST IN MEDI-CAL
AND PRIMARY CARE PROVIDER RATES.
SO WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF PROP 35.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. YOU MAY
GET THE RECORD. YES, MA'AM.
TANISHA HERRING, ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA HAWAII NAACP, IS
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF PROPOSITION
35. THANK YOU. OH, WOW. YOU GET
THE RECORD? YES, MA'AM. CHAIR
GONZALEZ ON BEHALF OF THE
ASSOCIATION OF NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA ONCOLOGISTS,
OTHERWISE KNOWN AS AN C , AS
WELL AS THE MEDICAL ONCOLOGY
ASSOCIATION OF SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA, OTHERWISE KNOWN AS
MOSK. WE ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF PROP 35. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
FOR JOINING US. YES SIR. MR.
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS, JOHN
VALENCIA, REPRESENTING THE
LATINX PHYSICIANS OF CALIFORNIA,
AN ORGANIZATION OF FRONTLINE
PROVIDERS IN THE SAFETY NET
ARENA, TAKING CARE OF MEDI-CAL
PATIENTS THERE IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF PROPOSITION 35. HOW DO YOU
DO? YOU DID GREAT. THANK YOU FOR
JOINING US. APPRECIATE YOUR
TESTIMONY. YES MA'AM. GOOD
AFTERNOON. LINDSEY FREITAS WITH
THE CALIFORNIA PRIMARY CARE
ASSOCIATION. WE REPRESENT 186
COMMUNITY CLINICS THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA AND EVERY SINGLE
COUNTY WE SERVE. ONE THIRD OF
THE MEDI-CAL POPULATION. THEY'VE
ASKED ME TO LIST EVERY SINGLE
ONE OF THOSE, BUT I'M NOT GOING
TO DO THAT FOR YOU GUYS. BUT
EVERYONE'S VERY SUPPORTIVE OF
THIS BECAUSE WE KNOW THAT THIS
IS GOING TO IMPACT OUR PATIENTS,
AND THIS IS GOING TO IMPROVE
CARE FOR OUR PATIENTS. AND
THAT'S WHY WE'RE HERE. AND
NOTHING THAT HAS BEEN MENTIONED
HERE TODAY IS NOT POSSIBLE FOR
US TO CONTINUE TO FIGHT FOR IN
FUTURE BALLOTS, AND WE'RE
EXCITED TO DO THAT. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. ANY OTHER PUBLIC
COMMENTS? YES MR. CHAIR, MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE, RANDALL HAGER,
REPRESENTING THE PSYCHIATRIC
PHYSICIANS ALLIANCE OF
CALIFORNIA. WE'RE IN STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. ANY OTHER
PUBLIC COMMENT? SEEING NONE, I'M
GOING TO GO AHEAD AND CLOSE
TODAY'S HEARING. I CERTAINLY
WANT TO THANK THE LA Ó STAFF
AND THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
FOR COMING DOWN AND PRESENTING
THEIR ANALYSIS. AND I ALSO WANT
TO THANK ALL OF THE OTHER
WITNESSES WHO WERE KIND ENOUGH
TO JOIN US ON OUR PANELS TO
PROVIDE INFORMATION ON THIS
VERY, VERY IMPORTANT
PROPOSITION. WITH THAT, THIS
FIRST HEARING ON PROPOSITION 35
IS ADJOURNED. WE'RE GOING TO
TAKE ABOUT THREE MINUTES AND
CHANGE OUT THE TEAM HERE, AND
WE'LL START HEARING NUMBER TWO.
OH YOU'RE GREAT. THANK YOU.
WELL GOOD AFTERNOON. THE SENATE
AND ASSEMBLY COMMITTEES ON
HEALTH WILL COME TO ORDER WITH
REGARD TO THE HEARING ON
PROPOSITION 34, SPENDING A
PRESCRIPTION DRUG REVENUES BY
CERTAIN HEALTH CARE PROVIDERS.
WE ARE GOING TO HAVE THREE
PANELS. BUT SINCE WE HAVE THREE
PANELISTS, I'VE ASKED THEM TO
ALL JOIN US UP AT THE FRONT AND
WE WILL ALL TAKE TESTIMONY IN
ORDER. BUT AS WE GO FORWARD, LA
PERHAPS YOU COULD PROVIDE SOME
OVERSIGHT ON PROPOSITION 34.
GOOD AFTERNOON. COMMITTEE. JASON
SANTORO, CEO I'LL BE WORKING
FROM THIS HANDOUT. THAT SHOULD
BE IN YOUR PACKET MATERIALS ON
PROPOSITION 34, SIMILAR TO THE
HANDOUT I HAD ON PROPOSITION 35.
IT HAS THE SAME FORMAT. IT
TOUCHES ON OUR ROLE IN THE ON
THE INITIATIVE PROCESS AND ALSO
PROVIDES BACKGROUND. DESCRIBES
PROPOSITION 34 AND PROVIDES OUR
FISCAL ANALYSIS. IF YOU TURN TO
PAGE ONE, PAGE ONE SUMMARIZES
OUR ROLE IN THE BALLOT MEASURE
PROCESS. YOU JUST HEARD, OUR
ROLE IN FOR PROPOSITION 35. IT'S
THE SAME PAGE JUST AGAIN, WANT
TO EMPHASIZE THAT, YOU KNOW, OUR
ROLE HERE IS, IS TO PROVIDE AN
INDEPENDENT FISCAL ANALYSIS, BUT
NOT TO WEIGH IN ON THE POLICY
MERITS OF BALLOT MEASURES.
TURNING TO PAGE TWO, WE PROVIDE
SOME BACKGROUND, AND THERE ARE
THREE KEY BACKGROUND ASPECTS WE
WANT TO TOUCH ON. THE FIRST IS
HOW MEDI-CAL PAYS FOR
PRESCRIPTION DRUGS. SO AS AS THE
MANY OF THE COMMITTEE KNOW,
MEDI-CAL IS A PROGRAM THAT
COVERS THE COST OF HEALTH CARE
FOR LOW INCOME PEOPLE, AND THAT
INCLUDES THE COST OF
PRESCRIPTION DRUGS. PRIOR TO
2019, MEDI-CAL HAD A HAD A
COUPLE OF DIFFERENT WAYS OF
PAYING FOR PRESCRIPTION DRUGS,
IN 2019, THE STATE ADOPTED A
SINGLE APPROACH THAT'S NOW
CALLED MEDI-CAL RX, AND THIS
APPROACH LIKELY SAVES THE STATE
MONEY BECAUSE MEDI-CAL IS PAYING
FOR DRUGS AT MORE DISCOUNTED
PRICES, MEDI-CAL IS CURRENTLY
NOT ENACTED IN STATE LAW, BUT IT
IS THE APPROACH THAT MEDI-CAL
USES TO PAY FOR PRESCRIPTION
DRUGS. SECOND KEY BACKGROUND
ISSUE I WANT TO TOUCH ON IS THE
FEDERAL DRUG DISCOUNT PROGRAM.
IT'S ALSO KNOWN AS THE 340 B
PROGRAM, AND UNDER THIS PROGRAM,
DRUGMAKERS PROVIDE DISCOUNTS ON
THEIR DRUGS TO QUALIFYING
PROVIDERS, ELIGIBLE PROVIDERS,
AND THEY TEND TO BE HOSPITALS OR
CLINICS. THEY ARE PUBLIC OR
PRIVATE OR PRIVATE NON-PROFITS
THAT FOCUS ON SERVING LOW INCOME
PEOPLE. Ã PROVIDERS TEND TO
EARN NET REVENUE AS A RESULT OF
THIS PROGRAM, AND THEY DO SO BY
CHARGING PAYERS OF HEALTHCARE,
SUCH AS PRIVATE INSURANCE OR
GOVERNMENT PAYERS MORE THAN THE
COST OF DRUGS. THERE ARE SOME
EXCEPTIONS TO THIS. FOR EXAMPLE,
THIS TENDS NOT TO HAPPEN IN THE
MEDI-CAL PROGRAM BECAUSE, STATE
LAW BANS PROVIDERS FROM CHARGING
MEDI-CAL MORE THAN THE COST OF
ACQUIRING THE DRUG. THIS PROGRAM
IS INTENDED TO ALLOW ELIGIBLE
PROVIDERS TO EXPAND SERVICES AND
SERVE MORE LOW INCOME PEOPLE
USING THEIR NET REVENUE. FEDERAL
AND STATE LAW, HOWEVER, DO NOT
DIRECTLY RESTRICT HOW PROVIDERS
SPEND THEIR REVENUE FROM THE
PROGRAM, AND THE THIRD KEY
BACKGROUND POINT I WANT TO
EMPHASIZE IS THAT IS AROUND
LICENSING IN CALIFORNIA. SO
CALIFORNIA LAW REQUIRES HEALTH
CARE ENTITIES TO BE LICENSED TO
PROVIDE SERVICES, AND TO REMAIN
LICENSED, THEY HAVE TO FOLLOW
CERTAIN RULES. AND WHEN THEY DO
NOT FOLLOW THESE RULES, THEY CAN
FACE PENALTIES. THESE PENALTIES
CAN RANGE FROM FACING FINES ALL
THE WAY TO, LOSING OR LOSING
LICENSURE. TURNING TO PAGE
THREE. WE PROVIDE AN OVERVIEW OF
PROPOSITION 34. THERE ARE THREE
KEY PARTS OF PROPOSITION 34. I
WANT TO TOUCH ON. THE FIRST PART
IS THAT IT WOULD RESTRICT HOW
CERTAIN ENTITIES SPEND THEIR
REVENUE FROM FEDERAL DISCOUNTS.
SO UNDER THIS REQUIREMENT,
AFFECTED ENTITIES WOULD NEED TO
SPEND AT LEAST 98% OF THEIR NET
FEDERAL DISCOUNT REVENUE EARNED
IN CALIFORNIA ON HEALTH CARE
SERVICES PROVIDED DIRECTLY TO
PATIENTS. NOW, AS THE AS THE
FIGURE ON THE BOTTOM OF PAGE
THREE SHOWS, THIS DOESN'T APPLY
TO EVERY PROVIDER. IT APPLIES TO
PROVIDERS THAT MEET CERTAIN
CONDITIONS, THESE CONDITIONS ARE
SUMMARIZED HERE. THEY INCLUDE.
IN ADDITION TO BEING LICENSED
AND PARTICIPATING IN THE FEDERAL
DRUG DISCOUNT PROGRAM, ALSO
HAVING ALSO SPENDING CERTAIN
AMOUNTS ON PURPOSES OTHER THAN
DIRECT PATIENT CARE AND OWNING
OR OPERATING HOUSING UNITS WITH
A CERTAIN NUMBER OF VIOLATIONS,
TO ENFORCE THESE REQUIREMENTS,
THE ENTITIES WOULD BE REQUIRED
TO REPORT INFORMATION TO THE
STATE, THE STATE WOULD CHARGE
FEES TO AFFECTED ENTITIES TO
HELP COVER ITS ENFORCEMENT COSTS.
TURNING TO PAGE FOUR, THE SECOND
KEY PART OF THE PROPOSAL. I'D
LIKE TO TOUCH ON IS WHAT HAPPENS
IF AN AFFECTED ENTITY IS
VIOLATES THE NEW RULES. UNDER
THE MEASURE, THERE WOULD BE FOUR
PENALTIES, AND THESE PENALTIES
RANGE FROM LOSING LICENSURE AND
ALSO LOSING TAX EXEMPT STATUS
JUST AS TWO EXAMPLES. AGAIN, ALL
FOUR PENALTIES WOULD APPLY, FOR
VIOLATING THE MEASURES
REQUIREMENTS. THESE PENALTIES
ALSO WOULD APPLY IF AFFECTED
ENTITIES ENGAGE IN CONDUCT THAT
IS UNPROFESSIONAL, DISHONEST, OR
HARMFUL TO PUBLIC HEALTH OR
SAFETY. THE THIRD KEY ASPECT I
WANT TO TOUCH ON IN THE PROPOSAL
IS IT ALSO ADDS MEDI-CAL TO
STATE LAW, BECAUSE MEDI-CAL IS
ALREADY IN EFFECT, THIS DOESN'T
CHANGE HOW THINGS CURRENTLY WORK
IN THE MEDI-CAL PROGRAM, BUT
ADDS THIS PROVISION TO STATE LAW.
TURNING TO PAGE FIVE. WE PROVIDE
OUR FISCAL ANALYSIS, THE FIRST
POINT WE WANT TO EMPHASIZE IS
WHEN THINKING ABOUT THE FISCAL
EFFECTS OF THIS MEASURE, THE
EFFECTS LIKE THE EFFECTS WOULD
BE LIMITED AND THEY WOULD BE
LIMITED BECAUSE LIKELY FEW
ENTITIES WOULD MEET THE
CONDITIONS DESCRIBED IN THE
FIGURE ON PAGE THREE, THE EXACT
NUMBER OF ENTITIES IS NOT KNOWN
BECAUSE THE STATE HAS NOT
UNDERGONE THE PROCESS TO
DETERMINE ELIGIBILITY. THAT
WOULD THAT WOULD SORT OF HAPPEN
AFTER THE WHERE THE MEASURE TO
BE ENACTED, BUT BECAUSE FEW
ENTITIES LIKELY WOULD BE
AFFECTED BY THIS, THE IMPACT
WOULD ON A STATE WIDE BASIS
WOULD BE LIMITED, THE MEASURE
WOULD RESULT IN A COST TO THE
STATE TO ENFORCE THE NEW
REQUIREMENTS, LIKELY IN THE
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS ANNUALLY.
THESE COSTS WOULD BE COVERED BY
THE STATE BY CHARGING FEES ON
AFFECTED ENTITIES. AND THEN THE
MEASURE COULD HAVE OTHER FISCAL
EFFECTS. THESE EFFECTS ARE
UNCERTAIN AND DEPEND IN PART ON
HOW IT WOULD CHANGE PROVIDER
BEHAVIOR. FOR EXAMPLE, SOME
PROVIDERS TO COMPLY WITH THE NEW
RULES MIGHT INCREASE SPENDING ON
DIRECT PATIENT CARE IF THAT
RESULTS IN MORE SPENDING TO
MEDI-CAL PATIENTS, IT COULD
RESULT IN SAVINGS TO THE TO THE
MEDI-CAL PROGRAM. BUT IT WOULD
DEPEND ON WHAT SERVICES ARE
PROVIDED. AFFECTED ENTITIES
WOULD ALSO HAVE TO PAY FEES AND
REPORT TO THE STATE ANNUALLY.
SOME ENTITIES MIGHT CHANGE THEIR
OPERATIONS TO AVOID THESE NEW
REQUIREMENTS. FOR EXAMPLE, THEY
COULD STOP PARTICIPATING IN THE
FEDERAL DISCOUNT PROGRAM IF THAT
RESULTS IN LESS FEDERAL
DISCOUNTS TO THE MEDI-CAL
PROGRAM, THEN THERE COULD BE
STATE COSTS, AND THEN SOME
ENTITIES THAT ARE AFFECTED BY
THE MEASURE, COULD VIOLATE THE
RESTRICTIONS. AND IF THAT WERE
TO HAPPEN, THERE COULD BE A
NUMBER OF EFFECTS THAT COULD
AFFECT STATE TAX REVENUES, STATE
SPENDING ON THE MEDI-CAL PROGRAM
OR SPENDING AND OTHER OTHER
PROGRAMS. THIS FISCAL EFFECT
WOULD DEPEND ON WHICH AFFECTED
ENTITIES FACE PENALTIES. THANK
YOU. LET ME START OFF. DIRECT
PATIENT CARE. HOW IS THAT
DEFINED? IS IT DEFINED BROADLY?
DOES IT INCLUDE COST OF
FACILITIES? COST OF EQUIPMENT?
ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS? IF YOU ARE
REQUIRED TO PUT 98% OF YOUR NET
FEDERAL DRUG DISCOUNT TOWARD
DIRECT PATIENT CARE AND IT'S NOT
DEFINED BROADLY, THAT DOESN'T
SEEM TO ALLOW A LOT FOR
ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS AND OTHER I
DON'T HAVE THE STATUTORY
DEFINITION RIGHT IN FRONT OF ME.
IT IS A, YOU KNOW, THE TEXT OF
THE LANGUAGE ISN'T ISN'T AS
SPECIFIC AS YOU DESCRIBE IT. IT
DESCRIBES, MEDICAL CARE AND
OTHER TYPES OF CARE, BUT IT
ISN'T IT DOESN'T IT ISN'T AS
DIRECT AS YOU AS YOU SPECIFY IN
TERMS OF FACILITIES THAT THAT'S
NOT SORT OF SPECIFIED IN THE
MEASURE. FOR EXAMPLE, IF YOU
CAN'T USE SOME OF THE NET, THE
GAP THAT YOU THE SPREAD THAT YOU,
YOU KNOW, ACHIEVE BY
PARTICIPATING IN THE FEDERAL
DRUG DISCOUNT PROGRAM TO SUPPORT
THE FACILITIES IN WHICH THE
PATIENT CARE IS PROVIDED, SORT
OF COULD BE PROBLEMATIC. IT'S
NOT DEFINED WITH SPECIFICITY.
WOULD YOU WOULD YOU AGREE THAT
THE MEASURE DOESN'T, THE
LANGUAGE DOESN'T SORT OF HAVE
THAT SPECIFICITY IN THE TEXT. SO
THAT WOULD BE SOMETHING THAT
WOULD SORT OF NEED TO BE
DETERMINED, YOU KNOW, ONCE THE
MEASURE IS SORT OF ENACTED, CAN
THE LEGISLATURE THEN, CLARIFY
THAT THROUGH OUR ACTIONS? OR IS
THE INITIATIVE RESTRICTIVE IN
THAT REGARD? I'M JUST YOU DON'T
KNOW. THAT'S FINE. THIS IS NOT
KNOW YOUR BIBLE. I'M JUST TRYING
TO. YEAH THAT'S SOMETHING THAT
WOULD NEED TO BE SORT OF WORKED
OUT ONCE THE MEASURE IS ENACTED,
THE MEASURE DOES TASK STATE
AGENCIES WITH IN SORT OF
ENFORCING THE MEASURE. SO AGAIN
THIS WOULD SORT OF NEED TO BE
WORKED OUT ONCE THE ONCE THE
SORT OF MEASURE IS ENACTED. CAN
YOU TELL ME ON THE RESTRICTIONS
THE FOUR RESTRICTIONS, HOW DID
THE MULTIFAMILY HOUSING UNIT
LANGUAGE GET INSERTED IN A IN AN
INITIATIVE THAT DEALS WITH
PATIENT CARE? YEAH, THAT WOULD
BE A GOOD QUESTION FOR, OTHER
PANELISTS. OKAY. WELL THAT WOULD
BE HELPFUL. THEY CAN TEE THAT UP
WHEN WE GET TO THEM. AND THEN,
SO COUNTY HOSPITALS, MY
RECOLLECTION IS THEY PARTICIPATE
IN THIS FEDERAL DRUG DISCOUNT
PROGRAM AND USE THE DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN WHAT THEY PAY FOR THE
DISCOUNTED DRUGS AND WHAT THEY
CAN CHARGE TO COMMERCIAL PAYERS,
FOR EXAMPLE, TO HELP SUPPORT
MEDICAID, MEDI-CAL SERVICES THAT
THEY PROVIDE. THIS STATEMENT ON
PAGE FIVE WHERE IT SAYS STATE
WOULD RECOVER COSTS BY CHARGING
FEES ON AFFECTED ENTITIES. THE
RECOVERY, THE COST RECOVERY AND
THE FEES CHARGED ARE THOSE ONLY
CHARGED TO ENTITIES THAT VIOLATE
THE RULES. OR DOES EVERYBODY
HAVE TO PAY PAY TO PLAY, IT
WOULD BE IT WOULD BE CHARGED ON
ENTITIES THAT ARE THAT ARE
AFFECTED BY THE MEASURE. SO THE
MEASURE, YOU KNOW, IS NOT ON ALL
340 B PROVIDERS. IT IS ON THOSE
THAT SORT OF MEET THE CONDITIONS
ON THE FIGURE. OH I SEE THREE.
SO THEY'D HAVE TO RUN
MULTI-FAMILY HOUSING UNITS IN
ORDER TO HAVE TO PAY A FEE.
THEY'D HAVE TO MEET THE
CONDITIONS. AND THEN LASTLY THIS
INITIATIVE HAS SOME RATHER
STRANGE TO ME. ANYWAY
ENFORCEMENT. PROVISIONS. WE
COULD START WITH THE CONTROLLER
AND THE CONTROLLER'S ABILITY TO,
HIRE INDEPENDENT COUNSEL. THAT
SEEMS ODD TO ME. CAN YOU PROVIDE
ANY INSIGHT AS TO HOW THAT GOT
INTO THIS PARTICULAR INITIATIVE?
THAT ALSO WOULD BE A GOOD
QUESTION FOR OTHER PANELISTS.
OKAY, GOOD. WELL, LET ME TURN IT
OVER TO MY COLLEAGUES THEN.
COLLEAGUES, ANY QUESTIONS? I'M
NOT SEEING ANY HANDS FLY UP IN
THE AIR. SO, SIR LET'S TALK
LET'S TALK TO YOU, MR. ANIDO.
DID I PRONOUNCE THAT CORRECTLY?
OH, THERE WE GO. PERFECT. SO YOU
HEARD SOME OF MY QUESTIONS, BUT
I'LL LET YOU GO THROUGH YOUR
PRESENTATION FIRST. I'LL GO
QUICKLY AND BE HAPPY TO HELP
WITH THOSE QUESTIONS. SO GOOD
AFTERNOON, MR. CHAIR AND
MEMBERS. MY NAME IS KURT ONETTO,
AND I'M COUNSEL TO PROTECT
PATIENTS NOW, WHICH IS A BROAD
COALITION AND SUPPORT OF
PROPOSITION 34. OUR COALITION
COUNTS AMONG ITS MEMBERS THE ALS
ASSOCIATION, THE CALIFORNIA
CHRONIC CARE ASSOCIATION
COALITION, CALIFORNIA
PROFESSIONAL FIREFIGHTERS,
CALIFORNIA SENIOR ALLIANCE, THE
DEFEATING EPILEPSY FOUNDATION,
HEP B, FREE SAN FRANCISCO
SUPPORT, FIBROMYALGIA NETWORK,
AND SEVERAL OTHERS. THE VERY
SIMPLE PURPOSE OF PROPOSITION 34
IS TO REFORM HOW THE 340 B
PROGRAM OPERATES IN CALIFORNIA.
THE THREE £0.40 PROGRAM HAS BEEN
WIDELY CRITICIZED FOR POOR STATE
AND FEDERAL OVERSIGHT. THIS
INCLUDES THE GOVERNMENT
ACCOUNTABILITY OFFICE, THE NEW
YORK TIMES, WALL STREET JOURNAL,
ATLANTIC, THE ATLANTA JOURNAL,
CONSTITUTION, AND OTHERS HAVE
ALL DOCUMENTED THE LARGE AMOUNT
OF SELF-DEALING AND ABUSE IN THE
PROGRAM. MANIPULATION OF THE
PROGRAM ALSO INCREASES COSTS FOR
CALIFORNIA. THIS IS AS LEO
MENTIONED, THIS IS ONE OF THE
MAIN REASONS FOR THE ENACTMENT
OF GOVERNOR NEWSOM'S EXECUTIVE
ORDER CREATING MEDI-CAL RX. OF
COURSE, THAT IS, THAT THAT
PROGRAM SAVES CALIFORNIA
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS ANNUALLY,
HOWEVER, THAT EXECUTIVE ORDER
WAS STRONGLY OPPOSED BY SOME 340
PROVIDERS, AND IT COULD BE
REVERSED BY A FUTURE
ADMINISTRATION. RELATED TO THIS,
THE FIRST REFORM THAT THAT PROP
34 CONTAINS IS TO MAKE PERMANENT
THE GOVERNOR'S EXECUTIVE ORDER,
TO MAKE SURE THAT THOSE
MULTIBILLION DOLLARS IN SAVINGS
CAN BE ACHIEVED IN PERPETUITY.
NEXT, PROPOSITION 34 ADDRESSES
SOME OF THE MOST EGREGIOUS
ABUSES OF THE 340 PROGRAM.
PROPOSITION 34 SEEKS TO ENSURE
THAT CALIFORNIA 340 REVENUES ARE
NOT USED IN A MANNER THAT
ACTUALLY HARMS PUBLIC HEALTH AND
SAFETY. THE CONNECTION BETWEEN
HOUSING AND HEALTH OUTCOMES IS
WELL KNOWN AND HAS BEEN WELL
DOCUMENTED THAT INADEQUATE
SHELTER OR HOUSING CAN RESULT IN
ADVERSE HEALTH OUTCOMES. EVEN
OPPONENTS OF PROPOSITION 34 HAVE
ACKNOWLEDGED THAT SECURE AND
STABLE HOUSING IS VITAL TO
POSITIVE HEALTH OUTCOMES.
THEREFORE, PROPOSITION 34
TARGETS INSTANCES WHERE
SIGNIFICANT THREE FOUR TB
REVENUES HAVE BEEN DIVERTED INTO
SUBSTANDARD HOUSING PROJECTS.
SPECIFICALLY, PROPOSITION 34
IMPOSES ADDITIONAL REQUIREMENTS
ON CALIFORNIA. 340 B PROVIDERS
THAT HAVE DIVERTED VERY LARGE
SUMS OF 340 B REVENUES OVER $100
MILLION IN ANY TEN YEAR PERIOD
TOWARDS PURPOSES UNRELATED TO
DIRECT PATIENT CARE, AND HAVE
DEVOTED REVENUES TO OPERATING
RESIDENTIAL HOUSING IN A MANNER
THAT ACTUALLY JEOPARDIZES PUBLIC
HEALTH AND SAFETY, AS
DEMONSTRATED THROUGH HAVING BEEN
CITED FOR AT LEAST 500 HIGHLY
SEVERE HEALTH AND SAFETY
VIOLATIONS UNDER PROPOSITION 34,
PROVIDERS THAT MEET THESE
REQUIREMENTS WOULD BE REQUIRED
TO SPEND 98% OF THEIR NET
REVENUES ON DIRECT PATIENT CARE,
SO LONG AS THEY MEET THAT
STANDARD, THERE ARE NO
PUNISHMENTS OR PENALTIES IMPOSED
UPON THEM. THE RATIONALE FOR
PROPOSITION 34 IS SIMPLE. THE
340 B PROGRAM IS A PUBLIC
PROGRAM SUPPORTED BY PUBLIC
DOLLARS, AND THOSE DOLLARS
SHOULD BE SPENT ON IMPROVING
PUBLIC HEALTH AS INTENDED BY
CONGRESS, RATHER THAN BEING
DIVERTED TO TWO PURPOSES THAT
ARE NOT ONLY UNRELATED TO
PATIENT CARE, BUT ACTUALLY
JEOPARDIZE PUBLIC HEALTH. AND
BEFORE I END MY REMARKS, IT IS
IMPORTANT TO SET THE RECORD
STRAIGHT IN MY VIEW, ON ONE
SPECIFIC ISSUE RAISED BY
OPPONENTS, SPECIFICALLY THAT
THAT PROPOSITION 34 IS A THREAT
TO WOMEN'S REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH,
PLANNED PARENTHOOD HAS OPINED
THAT PROPOSITION 34 SIMPLY HAS
NO EFFECT IN THIS REGARD, AS
PROOF OF THIS, I HAVE HERE IN
MAY 2024, EMAIL FROM PLANNED
PARENTHOOD TO THE CALIFORNIA
DEMOCRATIC PARTY EXECUTIVE
BOARD, IN WHICH PLANNED
PARENTHOOD STATES, AND I QUOTE,
PLANNED PARENTHOOD AFFILIATES OF
CALIFORNIA, IS NOT OPPOSED TO
THE MEASURE. IN FACT, PPACA IS
NEUTRAL ON THIS INITIATIVE
BECAUSE IT DOES NOT IMPACT OUR
AFFILIATES ABILITY TO PROVIDE
SEXUAL AND REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH
CARE OR INTERFERE WITH OUR
MISSION TO EXPAND ACCESS TO CARE
IN CALIFORNIA. THE EMAIL
CONTINUES THAT THE. FURTHERMORE,
AND I'M QUOTING THE PREMISE MADE
BY OPPONENTS THAT THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY SHOULD OPPOSE THE PROTECT
PATIENTS NOW MEASURE BASED UPON
THE EFFECT IT WILL HAVE ON
PLANNED PARENTHOOD USE OF THE
340 PROGRAM TO ADMINISTER
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH IN
CALIFORNIA IS SIMPLY FALSE, AND
OFFENSIVE. PPACA REMAINS NEUTRAL
TO THE CALIFORNIA PROTECT
PATIENTS NOW ACT. FINALLY, I'LL
POINT OUT THAT OPPONENTS OF
PROPOSITION 34 HAVE FILED SIX
SEPARATE LAWSUITS ATTEMPTING TO
PREVENT THE MEASURE FROM
APPEARING ON THE BALLOT. TWO
LAWSUITS IN THE SUPERIOR COURT,
TWO LAWSUITS IN THE COURT OF
APPEAL, AND TWO LAWSUITS IN THE
CALIFORNIA SUPREME COURT, AND
ALL SIX TIMES THE COURTS
REJECTED OPPONENTS ARGUMENTS. SO
THESE FALSE ALLEGATIONS FROM
OPPONENTS ABOUT THE MERITS OF
PROPOSITION 34 HAVE BEEN
CONSIDERED, AND REJECTED BY
EVERY LEVEL OF OUR STATE
JUDICIARY. THANK YOU, AND I'D BE
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS.
SO THE ONLY TIME THESE
RESTRICTIONS, WHICH SPECIFICALLY
ARE THE 98% RULE, APPLY, WILL BE
IF YOU HAVE A HEALTH CARE
PROVIDER THAT'S PROVIDING HEALTH
CARE IN THE CONTEXT OF A
RESIDENTIAL SETTING, THAT
THEY'RE THAT THEY'RE
PARTICIPANTS IN THE 340 B
PROGRAM AND THEY'RE PROVIDING
RENTAL HOUSING, AND THEY'VE
DIVERTED OVER $100 MILLION IN A
TEN YEAR PERIOD. SO IT'S SORT OF
A SORT OF ALL THREE
REQUIREMENTS. IT'S SORT OF IT'S
RESERVED FOR SORT OF THE MOST
EGREGIOUS TYPE OF CONDUCT THAT
WE'VE SEEN IN THE 340 PROGRAM,
AS DOCUMENTED BY MANY SOURCES.
SO THAT NARROWS THE FIELD. YES.
IT'S NOT IT IS. IT'S LIKELY TO
BE A SMALL GROUP. WE DON'T KNOW
THAT. AND I CAN THINK I CAN
ANSWER IT AS PART OF THAT
QUESTION. YOU KNOW, THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL, THE BOARD OF PHARMACY,
THE DEPARTMENT OF MANAGED HEALTH
CARE AND THE DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH WOULD BE TASKED
WITH IMPLEMENTING THE MEASURE,
THROUGH REGULATIONS AND OTHER
IMPLEMENTING GUIDANCE. THEY
WOULD FLUSH OUT DEFINITIONS AND
THEY WOULD ALSO BE IN CHARGE OF
DETERMINING WHO IS COVERED BY
THE MEASURE. HOW DO THEY DO?
THEY FLIP A COIN? HOW DO THEY
DECIDE WHO DOES WHAT? WELL, 340
B PROVIDERS CAN BE LICENSED BY
ANY ONE OF THOSE THREE ENTITIES,
AND THE MEASURE CALLS FOR THEM
TO SET UP COOPERATIVE GUIDELINES
AMONG THE THREE OF THEM. SO IT'D
BE IT'D BE UNIFIED. BUT SINCE
EACH OF THOSE DEPARTMENTS HAS
SPECIFIC LICENSING AUTHORITY,
AND THEN THE ATTORNEY GENERAL
HAS OVERALL LAW ENFORCEMENT
AUTHORITY, IT CALLS FOR THEM TO
COOPERATIVELY ADOPT GUIDELINES
AND GUIDANCE. AND SINCE YOU
MENTIONED THE ATTORNEY GENERAL
AND THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE,
TALK TO ME ABOUT THE COMPTROLLER
AND THE INDEPENDENT COUNSEL AND
HOW DID WE GET THERE? SO, THE
COMPTROLLER NOT BEING A LAWYER,
I'M NOT QUITE SURE, I THINK. ARE
YOU REFERRING TO THE PART OF THE
MEASURE WHERE THE AUDITOR CAN BE
INVOLVED IN? I THOUGHT I THOUGHT
I READ IN YOUR INITIATIVE THAT
THERE IS A SECTION THAT IF THE
COMPTROLLER DOESN'T FEEL LEGAL,
DEFENSE. HERE WE GO. OH, YEAH,
IN ORDER. SO HERE WE GO. IT'S ON
THE LAST PAGE, 15, 15 OF 15 OR.
YES. YEAH IN SECTION THIS IS
SECTION FOUR, THE MEASURE OF
LEGAL DEFENSE. SECTION HOW DID
WE GET TO THAT AND WHY PICK THE
COMPTROLLER? I WOULD THINK THE
COMPTROLLER IS PRETTY BUSY. SO,
SO THE WAY THIS WORKS, THIS
PROVISION IS NOT REALLY RELATED
TO THE SUBSTANCE OF THE MEASURE.
THIS GROWS OUT OF THE A CONCERN
THAT CAME UP ABOUT 12 YEARS AGO
THAT IF AN INITIATIVE MEASURE IS
PASSED BY THE VOTERS AND THE
STATE ATTORNEY GENERAL DECIDES
NOT TO DEFEND THE MEASURE, THAT
IT CAN BE INVALIDATED ON A
TECHNICALITY FOR LACK OF
DEFENSE. OH, I SEE THIS. IS THIS
IS TO DEFEND THE INITIATIVE,
CORRECT THE INITIATIVE, BE
CHALLENGED. CORRECT? YES, SIR.
NOT TO ENFORCE THE 98. NOT AT
ALL. THE I GOTCHA. THAT'S RIGHT.
I'LL READ BETTER NEXT TIME.
THANK YOU. ALEX, ANY QUESTIONS?
SENATOR MENGIBAR, FIRE AWAY.
THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR, AND I
THINK MAYBE YOU WERE ANSWERING
THIS QUESTION. I APOLOGIZE IF I
DIDN'T GET IT, REGARDING THE WHO
WOULD MEET THE CONDITIONS TO WHO
WOULD FALL UNDER THIS? AND I
GUESS I JUST WANT TO CLARIFY
THAT. I JUST WANT TO CONFIRM
THAT THIS MEASURE ISN'T DIRECTED
AT TO JUST ONE ENTITY. IF YOU
HAVE A LIST OF ENTITIES THAT
WOULD MEET, I GUESS THESE TWO
CONDITIONS HAS SPENT OVER 100
MILLION IN ANY TEN YEAR PERIOD,
AND HAS OPERATED MULTI-FAMILY
HOUSING, REPORTED TO HAVE AT
LEAST 500 HIGH SEVERITY HEALTH.
SO HAPPY TO ANSWER THAT
QUESTION, AS ON THE FACE OF THE
MEASURE, AS YOU CAN SEE, IT'S A
GENERALLY APPLICABLE STATUTE.
THE MATERIAL IS IN THE IN THE
BALLOT GUIDE, OBVIOUSLY, YOU
KNOW, EXPLAIN IT AND FRAME IT AS
A, AS A MEASURE OF GENERAL
APPLICABILITY. WE DON'T KNOW AT
THIS POINT EXACTLY WHICH
ENTITIES WOULD APPLY TO THE
MEASURE AFTER WE PASSED. THE
IMPLEMENTING GUIDELINES WOULD
HAVE TO BE ADOPTED BY THE
REGULATING AGENCIES, AND THEY
WOULD HAVE TO MAKE THOSE
INVESTIGATIONS. SO WE DON'T KNOW
WHAT WE CAN TELL FROM SORT OF
PUBLIC REPORTING. THAT OBVIOUSLY
IS NOT, YOU KNOW, DETERMINATIVE
OR WOULDN'T BE RELIED UPON BY
THE REGULATING AGENCIES. BUT
THERE ARE MULTIPLE ENTITIES THAT
HAVE THAT ARE ENGAGED IN HOUSING
IN CALIFORNIA THAT HAVE SPENT,
YOU KNOW, LARGE SUMS OF MONEY ON
THAT HOUSING AND LARGE SUMS OF
MONEY ON OTHER THINGS UNRELATED
TO PATIENT CARE, LIKE LOBBYING.
ONE PAID ITS CEO IN ONE YEAR,
$35 MILLION. SO NOT ONE YEAR.
THAT ONE EXPENDITURE. THEY GOT
VERY THEY GOT A THIRD OF THE WAY
THERE, TO HITTING THE THRESHOLD.
SO WE DON'T KNOW EXACTLY. BUT
THERE IS THERE ARE MULTIPLE
ENTITIES THAT ARE THREE, FOUR
PROVIDERS THAT ARE ENGAGED IN
HOUSING IN CALIFORNIA, AND THIS
IS ALL, YOU KNOW, BEEN PUBLICLY
REPORTED AND THAT THAT HAVE
THERE IS SOME EVIDENCE THAT
THEY'RE SPENDING LARGE SUMS OF
MONEY, ON THINGS THAT DON'T
COUNT AS PATIENT CARE AND
CIRCLING BACK TO THAT DEFINITION
THAT THE CHAIR ASKED THAT
QUESTION, YOU KNOW, AGAIN, THAT
THERE IS A BROAD DEFINITION.
IT'S FLEXIBLE IN THE MEASURE,
BUT THAT IS SPECIFICALLY LEFT
OPEN FOR FURTHER CLARIFICATION
OR REFINEMENT BY THE REGULATING
AGENCIES. THEY CAN ADOPT
REGULATIONS AND GUIDANCE TO
CLARIFY WHAT COUNTS AS DIRECT
PATIENT CARE FACILITIES, ETC. A
CERTAIN LIST, BECAUSE THE
PROPONENTS MUST HAVE SEEN AN
ISSUE, RIGHT? THAT'S THE WHOLE
POINT OF THIS PROPOSITION. YOU
SEE AN ISSUE AND YOU MUST HAVE A
LIST OF THE TARGETS WHO YOU
THINK ARE THE PROBLEM. SURE.
YEAH. THOSE ENTITIES HAVE BEEN
IDENTIFIED IN THE LITIGATION,
THERE'S, I THINK IN THE END
THERE'S 5 OR 6 THAT ARE
IDENTIFIED IN THE LITIGATION
JUST FROM PUBLIC REPORTS. AGAIN,
THAT IS UNSUBSTANTIATED AND
UNKNOWN, BUT IT'S THERE IS A
SMALL POPULATION OF MULTIPLE
ENTITIES THAT ARE OUT THERE.
DOCTOR WEBBER. I'M ACTUALLY
GOING TO PIGGYBACK ON WHAT HAS
BEEN SAID, BECAUSE I'M REALLY
CONFUSED NOW BECAUSE IT YOU
KNOW, IN THE, MEASURE, I MEAN,
YOU IT'S SPECIFICALLY STATES OUT
THAT UNFORTUNATELY, SOME SAFETY,
HEALTH CARE SAFETY NET HEALTH
CARE PROVIDERS HAVE MANIPULATED
THE PROGRAM TO RECEIVE ENORMOUS
MARKUPS ON THE DISCOUNTED
PRESCRIPTION DRUGS. THEY RECEIVE
AND THEN STICK TAXPAYERS WITH
THE COST INSTEAD OF USING THIS
MASSIVE WINDFALL TO HELP
PATIENTS. THE WORST OFFENDERS
HAVE USED THEIR FORTUNES TO
PURCHASE LUXURY COASTAL
CONDOMINIUMS. WASTE OF HUNDREDS
OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS ON FAILED
POLITICAL CAMPAIGNS PUT ELECTED
POLITICIANS AND PAYROLLS. SO WHO
ARE WE REFERRING? SURE SO I CAN
I CAN GET INTO SOME OF THOSE
EXAMPLES FOR, PRIME EXAMPLE,
FRANKLY, IS CVS. THEY ARE A
MAJOR CONTRACT PHARMACY
AGREEMENT PROVIDER, THEY, THEY
MAKE AGREEMENTS WITH THE
NONPROFITS TO SORT OF ALSO
PROFIT FROM THE PROGRAM IN A WAY
THAT SEEMS TO BE OUTSIDE OF
CONGRESSIONAL INTENT. THEY HAVE
INVESTED HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS IN BUILDING HOUSING IN
CALIFORNIA, THEY THEY PUT A
THERE'S A RHODE ISLAND, YOU
KNOW, STATE LEGISLATOR WHO WAS
CONVICTED FOR TAKING PAYMENTS
FROM THEM. AND THEY SPENT
HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
ON CAMPAIGNS AND LOBBYING. ALSO,
BON SECOURS IS ANOTHER HEALTH
CARE PROVIDER THAT INVESTS IN
HOUSING IN CALIFORNIA. THEY THEY
HAVE SPENT MONEY ON NAMING
RIGHTS FOR PROFESSIONAL SPORTS
STADIUMS AND HAVE BEEN ACCUSED
BY THE NEW YORK TIMES OF
DIVERTING $340 OUT OF MINORITY
NEIGHBORHOODS INTO OTHER
UNRELATED PROJECTS. THOSE ARE
TWO OBVIOUSLY, THERE IS A LOT OF
PRESS, HAS BEEN A LOT OF PRESS
COVERAGE OF THE AIDS HEALTHCARE
FOUNDATION, AND SIMILAR KIND OF
STORIES ABOUT, ABOUT THEIR USE
OF $340. THOSE ARE PROBABLY
THREE OF THE BIGGEST. AND
THERE'S SEVERAL OTHER SMALLER,
THAT PROVIDERS, BASED UPON
PUBLIC REPORTING, WE DON'T
REALLY KNOW OF IN TERMS OF THE
AMOUNT OF MONEY THEY'VE
DIVERTED, BUT THEY ARE INVOLVED
IN HOUSING. AND I YOU KNOW, WE
COULD PROVIDE THAT INFORMATION
TO THE, TO THE LEGISLATURE. IT'S
BEEN PROVIDED, YOU KNOW, TWICE
TO THE SUPERIOR COURT, TWICE TO
THE COURT OF APPEAL AND TWICE TO
THE CALIFORNIA SUPREME COURT, IN
THE LAWSUITS AGAINST THE
MEASURE. AND SO ALL OF THESE
THAT YOU HAVE BASICALLY STATED
ARE SUBSTANTIATED FACTS BECAUSE
USUALLY FROM A LEGISLATIVE
STANDPOINT, YOU KNOW, THERE'S
BEEN A STATE AUDIT THAT'S
REVEALED THAT THERE'S AN ISSUE
OR SOMETHING THAT WE'RE HEARING
ABOUT, ON A MORE FREQUENT
OCCURRING BASIS. BUT I THINK THE
FACT THAT ALL OF US ARE ASKING
BASICALLY THE SAME THING, WHO
ARE THESE PEOPLE THAT HAVE
PROMPTED YOU ALL TO DO THIS
LARGE BALLOT INITIATIVE? THESE
ARE SUBSTANTIATED CLAIMS. THESE
ARE THESE ARE THESE ARE CLAIMS
THAT ARE YOU CAN FIND IN THE
COURT DOCUMENTS AND THEY'RE ALL
BASED UPON PUBLICLY AVAILABLE
SOURCES. NEW YORK TIMES WALL
STREET JOURNAL SUBSTANTIATED
CLAIMS. WELL, THEY ARE PUBLICLY
REPORTED IN REPUTABLE NEWS NEWS
BY NEWS MEDIA. OKAY I MEAN, HOW
IT CAN BE SUBSTANTIATED WOULD
REQUIRE SOMEONE HAS ACTUALLY
GONE OUT, INVESTIGATED, AND
REPORTED THAT THESE FINDINGS ARE
CORRECT. THEY'VE LOOKED THROUGH
BOOKS. THEY'VE THEY'VE THEY HAVE
ACTUALLY STATED THAT THESE
INDIVIDUALS HAVE TAKEN THIS
SOURCE OF MONEY AND USED IT FOR
HOUSING. LIKE, THAT'S WHAT I'M
TALKING ABOUT. YEAH, I'D HAVE
THE DATA. IT'S TRUE. IT'S
SUBSTANTIATED. IT'S NOT
SOMETHING THAT IS SPECULATED. WE
KNOW THIS. IT WAS TRUE ENOUGH TO
GET PUT IN THE NEW YORK TIMES.
NO, I MEAN, THERE'S A LOT OF I
MEAN, THERE'S A LOT OF THINGS
THAT ARE WRITTEN THESE DAYS,
BUT, THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
DOCTOR WEBER. OKAY, MR. BURTON,
IT MUST BE UP TO YOU TO BRING US
HOME. I'M BACK, MR. CHAIR,
AGAIN. RAND MARTIN HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE AIDS HEALTHCARE
FOUNDATION, FOR THOSE WHO DON'T
KNOW, H-F IS THE LARGEST
NONPROFIT PROVIDER OF CARE AND
TREATMENT TO PEOPLE WITH HIV AND
AIDS IN THE WORLD. THEY HAVE
MORE THAN 2 MILLION LIVES IN
CARE IN 46 COUNTRIES AROUND THE
GLOBE, CALIFORNIA, WHICH IS
THEIR HOME. H-F IS ACTUALLY THE
LARGEST NONPROFIT PROVIDER OF
CARE AND TREATMENT TO PEOPLE
WITH HIV AND AIDS, AS WELL AS
THE LARGEST STD PROVIDER OF CARE
AND TREATMENT IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. AJF CREATED ITS
HEALTHY HOUSING FOUNDATION IN
2018 BECAUSE THEY RECOGNIZED
THAT COMPREHENSIVE HEALTH CARE
MUST INCLUDE DECENT HOUSING FOR
THEIR PATIENTS TO ENSURE THAT
TREATMENT IS AS EFFECTIVE AS
POSSIBLE. GIVEN THAT THE
CRITICAL PART OF THEIR MISSION
THEY EMBARKED ON SIDE BY SIDE
PATHS TO CREATE MORE TRULY
AFFORDABLE HOUSING FOR EXTREMELY
LOW INCOME CALIFORNIANS.
CURRENTLY, 1500 UNITS IN THE
CITY OF LOS ANGELES AND TO
ADVOCATE FOR ROBUST TENANT
PROTECTIONS CENTRAL TO THEIR
RENTERS RIGHTS MISSION HAS BEEN
THEIR EFFORT TO REPEAL THE
STATE'S RENT CONTROL LAW, THE
COSTA-HAWKINS RENTAL HOUSING
ACT, LEADING TO LOWER RENTS
ACROSS THE STATE. H-F IS
ATTEMPTING THE REFORMS AGAIN
WITH PROPOSITION 33 ON THE
NOVEMBER 2024 BALLOT. CALIFORNIA
APARTMENT ASSOCIATION HAS SPENT
TENS OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS ON
TRYING TO PROTECT COSTA-HAWKINS
SO THAT THEIR ABILITY TO
CONTINUE TO IMPOSE EXORBITANT
RENTS ON THEIR TENANTS IS NOT
DIMINISHED. SO APPARENTLY, FROM
OUR PERSPECTIVE, TIRED OF
SPENDING ALL THIS MONEY TO
RESIST CHANGES TO COSTA-HAWKINS,
THEY HAVE QUALIFIED PROP 34 IN
ORDER TO GO AFTER AF, PUNISH AF,
AND ONLY AF AND DISTRACT THEM
FROM PROP 33 AND FORCE THEM TO
SPEND RESOURCES AGAINST PROP 34.
NO. ONE SAYS IT BETTER THAN THE
SAN JOSE MERCURY NEWS. JUST LAST
FRIDAY, WHEN THEY STATED PROP 34
IS AN ABUSIVE USE OF THE STATE'S
INITIATIVE SYSTEM TO SILENCE A
POLITICAL OPPONENT, IT WOULD SET
A HORRIBLE PRECEDENT. PRECEDENT
IF IT PASSES AND SURVIVES LEGAL
CHALLENGE. HF DOES PARTICIPATE
IN THE FEDERAL 340 B PROGRAM AND
ALLOWS US TO, AS AN ELIGIBLE
HEALTH CARE PROVIDER, TO GET
LOWER DRUG PRICES AND USE THE
DELTA BETWEEN WHAT WE RECEIVE IN
REIMBURSEMENT AND THE LOWER DRUG
COSTS TO PAY FOR ADDITIONAL
MEDICAL CARE FOR INDIGENT
CALIFORNIANS. WE'VE BEEN VERY
EFFECTIVE IN PROVIDING THAT CARE
BECAUSE WE HAVE THOSE RESOURCES
THAT THE 340 B PROGRAM ALLOWS US
TO HAVE, BE BE ASSURED THAT THAT
PROGRAM IS ALSO AUDITED BY THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT. SO WE HAVE
BEEN THROUGH AUDITS AND WE HAVE
COME OUT GLOWING IN THOSE AUDITS.
AND SO THIS DOES NOT HAPPEN IN A
VACUUM. IT DOES NOT HAPPEN
WITHOUT THE OVERSIGHT OF THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT. FOR, FOR
YEARS, UNFORTUNATELY, CA HAS
PROMOTED THE LIE THAT WE ARE
USING THOSE 340 B FUNDS TO FUND
OUR POLITICAL ACTIVITIES, A
CHARGE THAT CANNOT WITHSTAND
SCRUTINY BECAUSE OF THAT FEDERAL
AUDIT REQUIREMENT. BUT THAT HAS
NOT STOPPED CMA FROM
PERPETUATING PERPETUATING THIS
CANARD. THEY HAVE CRAFTED PROP
34 TO TRY TO PUNISH AF FOR
EXERCISING ITS RIGHT TO FREE
SPEECH, AND TO ENGAGE IN
POLITICAL DISCOURSE. CAA EVEN
OWNED UP TO THIS IN THEIR PRESS
RELEASE ANNOUNCING THIS
INITIATIVE, IN WHICH THEY
EXPLICITLY STATE THAT IT WAS
AIMED AT AF. EXCUSE ME,
REGARDLESS OF THE TRUTH, CA AA
DEFINES THE TARGET OF THE
INITIATIVE IN A WAY THAT IS
INTENDED TO IDENTIFY AF ALONE,
AND THEN DEFINES PATIENT
SERVICES SO NARROWLY THAT MANY
HEALTH CARE SERVICES ARE
PROHIBITED, INCLUDING
ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS. AS THE
CHAIR HAS RIGHTLY POINTED OUT,
IT THEN REQUIRES THAT 98% OF ALL
THOSE FUNDS HAVE TO BE SPENT ON
THE INITIATIVE'S NARROW
DEFINITION OF WHAT DIRECT
SERVICES ARE NOT ONLY AN
IMPOSSIBLE THRESHOLD TO MEET,
BUT A HUGE DISSERVICE TO OUR
PATIENTS BECAUSE WE ARE SO
EFFECTIVE AT USING THOSE FUNDS
TO PROVIDE SERVICES THAT ARE NOT
TYPICALLY PROVIDED UNDER
EXISTING PROGRAMS. AND IT STATES
THAT 98% THAT THAT 98% APPLIES
TO ALL REVENUES GENERATED
NATIONWIDE. SEEKING TO REGULATE
AND POTENTIALLY PUNISH MEDICAL
SERVICES CONDUCTED OUTSIDE THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. IT IS YET
ANOTHER WAY THAT CAA TRUMPETS
THAT PROPOSITION 34 APPLIES ONLY
TO AF. THE CONSEQUENCES FOR AF.
IF THEY SPEND ONE PENNY LESS
THAN 98% INCLUDE LOSING THEIR
TAX EXEMPT NONPROFIT STATUS,
LOSING ALL THEIR CLINIC,
PHARMACY, HEALTH CARE SERVICE
PLAN LICENSES, LOSING ALL OF
THEIR STATE AND LOCAL CONTRACTS,
AND PROHIBITING AF AND ITS
OFFICERS FROM SECURING ANY SUCH
LICENSES AGAIN FOR THE NEXT 20
YEARS, ALL OF WHICH WOULD PUT AF
OUT OF BUSINESS, LEAVING IT
16,000 PATIENTS AND CLIENTS IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA SUDDENLY
SCRAMBLING FOR SERVICES. IF THIS
INITIATIVE IS NOT STOPPED, THE
ESSENTIAL QUESTION TO THE
UNIVERSE BEYOND AF IS WHO'S NEXT?
ACLU PLANNED PARENTHOOD IS SOME
MONEYED INTEREST, SOME MONEYED,
AN ADVERSARY TO THOSE
ORGANIZATIONS GOING TO SEE THIS
AS A ROADMAP FORWARD, TO ALLOW
THEM TO GO AFTER THOSE, THOSE
ORGANIZATIONS THROUGH THE
THROUGH THE INITIATIVE PROCESS.
ANY SUCH ADVOCATE, REGARDLESS OF
THE TYPE OF SERVICES THEY
PROVIDE, IS AT RISK OF A SIMILAR
INITIATIVE ATTACKING THAT
ORGANIZATION. AND THREATENING
ITS VERY EXISTENCE. THIS
INITIATIVE WILL SET A VERY
DANGEROUS PRECEDENT IF IT GOES
FORWARD. WHETHER IT PASSES OR
NOT. THERE IS NO QUESTION THAT
ANOTHER PRINCIPLED AND
PROGRESSIVE ORGANIZATION WILL
COME UNDER A COMPARABLE ATTACK.
WE APPRECIATE YOUR TIME TODAY.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU, MR. MARTIN.
I THINK, YOU MADE YOU MADE A
POINT THAT I WAS TRYING TO ASK
QUESTIONS ABOUT. I THINK THIS
DEFINITION OF DIRECT PATIENT
CARE AND THE CONSEQUENCES OF
FAILING TO MEET IT ARE PRETTY,
CAN BE PRETTY CATASTROPHIC, I
WOULD HOPE THAT WITH FOUR
AGENCIES HAVING AUTHORITY OVER
VARIOUS PLAYERS IN THIS SANDBOX,
THAT THEY CAN GET IT, GET IT
TOGETHER AND CAN COORDINATE ONE
DEFINITION. BUT IN THE ABSENCE
OF THAT OR IF THE DEFINITION IS
LACK SPECIFICITY, INDIVIDUALS,
ENTITIES THAT ARE ATTEMPTING TO
PROVIDE SERVICES IN THIS SANDBOX
ARE GOING TO HAVE A DIFFICULT
TIME NAVIGATING THAT PROCESS.
AND AGAIN, CONSEQUENCES ARE
PRETTY, PRETTY SEVERE. MR.
MARTIN, LET ME ASK ONE QUESTION.
I MEAN, GIVEN GIVEN THIS IS A
FOUNDATION, ISN'T IT? YEAH GIVEN
YOUR STATUS OR ITS STATUS AND
THE FACT THAT THERE'S AN AUDIT,
ARE THESE AUDITS MADE PUBLIC?
THEY'RE AVAILABLE ON HIS WEBSITE.
SO THE 340 BE SOMEBODY CAN PICK
IT UP AND CAN FIGURE OUT HOW YOU
SPENT YOUR MONEY. YES, SIR.
INTERESTING COLLEAGUES. ANY
QUESTIONS? COMMENTS? DOCTOR
WEBER. GENTLEMEN, ANYTHING
FURTHER? THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME. WE'LL TAKE PUBLIC COMMENT.
THANK YOU. THIS IS THE PUBLIC
COMMENT PORTION OF OUR HEARING.
ANYONE WHO WISHES TO MAKE PUBLIC
COMMENT REGARDING THIS
PARTICULAR HEARING ON
PROPOSITION 34, PLEASE STEP
FORWARD. NAME AFFILIATION AND
POSITION ON THE PROPOSITION. NO
ONE'S RUNNING UP HERE TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT. WITH THAT, I
THINK WE CAN CONCLUDE THIS
HEARING SEEING NO FURTHER
BUSINESS. THIS HEARING OF THE
COMBINED ASSEMBLY AND SENATE
COMMITTEES OF HEALTH ON HEALTH
IS ADJOURNED.